CAN THROTTLE IT DOWN.
GO UP AND HIGH POINT THE
FOOTBALL.
I THINK THAT'S A PART OF HIS
GAME THAT GOES UNDERRATED
BECAUSE EVERYBODY WANT TOS TO
KNOW WHAT A HO SO40 TIME LOOKS
>> WHEN CALVIN RIDLEY COMES
BACK, WHAT A GREAT COMPLIMENT TO
THOSE STYLES, WITH KYLE PITTS.
IT SEEMS THEY HAVE AN IDENTITY
FINALLY BEING FORMED IN ATLANTA
AND IT WILL BE NECESSARY AS WE
MOVE ON FROM THE EAR OF A MATT
RYAN.
PICK NUMBER NINE, THE SEATTLE
SEAHAWKS, THEY GOT THIS PICK IN
THE ALSO U RUSSELL WILSON TRADE
WITH THE DENVER BRONCOS.
THERE HAVE BEEN A LOT OF MOCKS
THIS PICK IS TRADED.
CONNOR, WHEN ARE YOUR THOUGHTS?
>> FASCINATING.
A TEAM WITHOUT A QUARTERBACK, A
REAL ANSWER NOW.
THEY HAVE PLENTY OF NEEDS.
THEY PICK UP 40 AND 41.
THEY HAVE BEEN OPEN TO GETTING
OUT OF THIS PICK.
EXPLORING, SEE HOW MUCH YOU CAN
SQUEEZE OUT OF IT.
JERMAINE JOHNSON, EXCELLENT
SCHEME PICK.
THEY LOVE THAT THERE IN SEATTLE
THAT.
WILL MAKE A LOT OF SENSE.
ALSO A TEAM THAT HAS HOLES ON
THE OFFENSIVE LINE.
>> HUGE HOLE AT RIGHT TACKLE, OR
LEFT TACKLE.
>> DUANE BROWN.
>> AND STONE FORSYTHE IS THERE
AND HE NEVER PLAYED A REGULAR
SEASON SNAP.
>> HE WAS A PROJECT PICK LAST
YEAR ON DAY THREE.
CHARLES CROSS IS IN PLAY HERE.
YOU HAVE TO WONDER IF THAT A
PLUG AND PLAY PICK FOR THEM,
TAKE CHARLES CROSS, PLAY ON THE
LEFT SIDE, OR DO THEY LIKE THE
TIER TWO AND THREE WITH THAT 40,
40 --
>> MAYBE I AM A SUCKER BUT I
THINK OF THE LEGION OF BOOM.
DOES KYLE HAMILTON FIT AT ALL?
>> NO, THEY ARE PAYING JAMAL
ADAMS.
PAYING DIGGS.
THEY WOULD HAVE LOVED STINKLY OR
SAUCE:McDUFFIE A SMALLER CORNER.
I WOULD BE SURPRISE AT THAT
SELECTION.
THEY WILL TAKE SECONDARY ROUND
PLAYER IN THE FIRST ROUND.
>> AND D.K. METCALF.
>> AND HOME RUN ON D.K.
THEY ARE ALL OVER THE PLACE.
I AM FASCINATED BY THIS
SELECTION IF THEY GO OFF THE
RAILS HERE.
OR JORDAN DAVIS AND LIKE, WHAT
THE HELL?
THIS WOULDN'T SHOCK ME.
>> FOR A TEAM UNABLE TO STOP THE
RUN FOR A FEW YEARS, THEY WERE
31st AGAINST THE PASS LAST YEAR.
WHEN I THINK OF RUSSELL WILSON,
I THINK OF HIM RUNNING FOR HIS
LIFE.
WHAT DO WE THINK HERE, FELDER?
IS THIS A PLACE YOU GO WITH THE
CHARLES CROSS OR DO YOU GO WITH
A PASS-RUSHER?
>> I THINK CROSS MAKES A LOT OF
SENSE.
AGAIN, YOU HAVE TO FIND A WAY
TO -- ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU DON'T
HAVE A QUARTERBACK THAT YOU LIKE
>> WE GOT IT.
>> OKAY.
>> CHARLES CROSS.
>> THERE WE GO.
>> THIS IS A GREAT PICK.
>> I WAS GOING TO SAY, YOU DON'T
HAVE A QUARTERBACK THAT YOU
LIKE, YOU PROBABLY NEED TO GIVE
HIM MORE TIME.
>> IT'S DREW LOCK WITH GENO
SMITH BEHIND HIM AND JACOB --
>> WE ARE GETTING AN OFFENSIVE
LINEMAN TO HELP THE SEATTLE
SEAHAWKS FINALLY PROTECT THEIR
QUARTERBACK.
MISSISSIPPI STATE, CHARLES
CROSS, 6'5", 307, 22 STARTS IN
COLLEGE.
ALL OF THEM AT LEFT TACKLE.
NOW, THE INTERESTING THING IS
NEARLY 80% OF HIS PLAYS WERE
PASSING PLAYS.
THAT'S WHAT WE ARE GOING TO GET
INTO NOW.
YOUR INITIAL FEELING OF CHARLES
CROSS AT NINE?
>> I LOVE.
DON'T WORRY ABOUT THE
PERCENTAGES FROM THE OFFENSE
BECAUSE HE WASN'T RECRUITED TO
PLAY IN THAT OFFENSE.
THIS MAN CAN BEAT YOU UP IN THE
RUN GAME.
HE HAS BIG BEAR GRIP STRENGTH
HANDS.
HE HAS LONG ARMS.
HE'S GOT GOOD FEET.
I MEAN, I LOVE THE PLAYER.
I THOUGHT THERE WAS A BIG THREE
OF OFFENSIVE TACKLES IN THE
CLASS.
EVERYBODY TALKED ABOUT ICKEY.
TOOK ALONG TIME FOR PEOPLE TO
JUMP ACROSS THE CHARLES CROSS
BANDWAGON.
NINTH OVERALL PLAYER.
NINTH OVERALL PICK.
A MAVIS NEED FOR THE SEATTLE
TEAM.
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT THE FUTURE
HOLDS AT QUARTERBACK.
GUESS WHAT?
THERE WASN'T A GUY IN THIS SPOT
THAT WAS THE SUREFIRE ANSWER.
YOU TAKE THE FOUNDATIONAL PIECE
THAT CAN BUILD FOR WHOEVER THAT
IS AT QUARTERBACK AND THEY WANT
TO RUN THE FOOTBALL.
IF THERE ARE QUESTIONS ABOUT --
BECAUSE SAMPLE SIZE AS A RUN
BLOCKER, THE SAMPLE THAT IS ON
TAPE ON THE ALL 22 IS EXCELLENT.
NORTH TO SOUTH.
WIDE ZONE, GETTING OUT WIDE,
JUST OKAY.
NORTH/SOUTH HE WILL BEAT YOU UP.
I LIKE CHARLES CROSS A LOT.
T
TIER ONE OFFENSIVE TACKLES GONE.
THIS WAS IT.
>> YEAH.
WE'RE CLOSING OUT.
WE ARE ABOUT TO CLOSE OUT THE
TOP TEN.
THIS IS NINE.
YOU GET HIM AT NINE, A GUY THAT
SOME PEOPLE THOUGHT COULD HAVE
BEEN IN THE TOP SEVEN.
WE HAVE GOT TO GET IT BOTH GUYS.
SO I AM GOING TLOK IN THE A.
I DON'T SEE HOW THIS IS A MISS
FOR THEM BECAUSE THEY HELP A
POSITION OF NEED AND THEY HELP
IT WITH SOMEONE A LOT OF FOLKS
DON'T EXPECT TO BE ON THE BOARD
NOW.
>> JASON KELCE, YOUR REACTION TO
CHARLES CROSS BEING TO THE
SEAHAWKS?
>> LIGHT.
REALLY GOOD PRODUCTION
THROUGHOUT COLLEGE.
I REALIZE WATCHING MISSISSIPPI
STATE MAN, I LOVE MIKE LEACH'S
PRESS CONFERENCES BUT I WOULD
HATE TO BE AN OFFENSIVE LINEMAN
IN HIS SCHEME.
IT IS A LOT OF PASS BLOCKING AND
HE CERTAINLY DOES A GREAT JOB OF
THAT.
HE IS LONG.
HIS ARMS, THEY GET ON HIM.
HE HAS GREAT HANDS.
HE FINISHES.
I DON'T SEE HIM AS THIS
UNBELIEVABLE EXPLOSIVE ATHLETE,
BUT HE CAN DEFINITELY MOVE
PEOPLE.
HE CAN DEFINITELY GET ON GUYS
AND HE'S GOT POWER TO HIS GAME
DESPITE BEING UNDERSIZED.
THIS COULD BE A REALLY GOOD PICK
HERE.
>> HE WILL SLIDE TO THE LEFT
TACKLE SPOT AGAIN.
STONE FORSYTHE NEVER PLAYED SNAP
IN THE NFL AND HE GAS GOING TO
BE THE STARTER.
A FORMER MEMBER OF THE SEAHAWKS
FOR A VERY LONG TIME, RICHARD
SHERMAN.
THEY DIDN'T DRAFT A LOT OF
OFFENSIVE LINEMEN WHEN I FEEL
LIKE YOU PLAYED THERE.
YOUR THOUGHTS ON THIS FICK?
>> I THINK IT'S A SOLID PICK.
I THINK THEM STARTING TO TRY TO
BUILD THE TEAM IN THAT WAY, YOU
KNOW, OBVIOUSLY, THEY HAVE BEEN
UNPREDICTABLE IN THE PASS.
YOU MENTIONED THE PENNY PICK,
BROOKS PICK.
UNPREDICTABLE TO TAKE A TACKLE
THAT WAS CORRESPEXPECTED TO GO
FILLING A POSITION OF NEED
SEALING DUANE BROWN NOT COMING
BACK.
I THOUGHT THERE MIGHT BE A
TRADE, MAYBE THE BECTON TRADE
WITH THE JETS.
HE HAS BEEN MADE AVAILABLE.
I THOUGHT THEY WOULD GET
INVOLVED IN THAT.
A GREAT PICK FOR THEM.
>> CHARLES CROSS OFFICIALLY A
SEATTLE SEAHAWK.
SHORT TERM, KELCE, THANK YOU
GUYS THEY HAVE.
THE DRAFT NOW WE ARE OPEN UP TO
THE WILD PART.
WE HAVE A LOT OF PLAYERS THAT
ARE REALLY GREAT THAT ARE STILL
OUT THERE.
A LOT OF THE GREAT WIDE
RECEIVERS ARE LEFT.
NUMBER ONE SAFETY IN THE DRAFT
IS LEFT.
SOME OF THE OTHER CORNERS, TRENT
McDUFFIE THERE.
REALLY THE WIDE RECEIVERS AND
THE JETS ARE BACK ON THE CLOCK.
CONNOR, FROM WHERE THEY PICKED
AT FOUR, HOW HAS THE BOARD
FALLEN FOR THIS TEAM?
>> YEAH, SO RIGHT NOW YOU ARE
LOOKING AT I CRITICIZED THEM
WITH THE SAUCE PICK.
I SAID I HAVE PASS-RUSH
CONCERNS.
JERMAINE JOHNSON IS THERE.
>> IF THEY LEFT WITH SAUCE AND
JERMAINE JOHNSON, HOW DO YOU
FEEL?
>> ONE OF THE WORST DEFENSES IN
THE NFL LAST YEAR COMPLETELY
FLIPS AROUND.
YOU HAVE JORDAN WHITEHEAD, D.J.
REED, SAUCE GARDNER, JERMAINE
JOHNSON.
YOU ARE STARTING TO BUILD
SOMETHING.
WIDE RECEIVER.
WE KNOW HOW HUNGRY THEY HAVE
BEEN.
I AM FASCINATED.
IF THEY DON'T GO WIDE RECEIVER
HERE, DO THEY THINK THEY CAN GET
DEEBO SAMUEL WITH OTHER PICKS?
IS THERE SOMETHING THERE?
THEY HAVE BEEN SO HUNGRY, SO
THIRSTY.
>> THEY HAVE THE THIRD PICK IN
THE SECOND ROUND.
THE SIXTH IN THE SECOND ROUND
FROM SAM DARNOLD.
THIS FROM THE JAMAL ADAMS TRADE.
INSIDE THE MIND OF CONNOR
ROGERS, WHO ARE YOU TEXTING
RIGHT NOW?
WHAT SOURCES ARE YOU WORKING?
>> I CAN'T SAY WHO, BUT I AM
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHAT THE
JETS ARE DOING.
I HEARD RUMORS THEY ANSWERED THE
PHONES ON TEAMS LOOKING TO COME
UP.
NOT SURE IF THEY WANT TO TAKE
THAT CAPITAL.
THERE ARE PLAYERS THAT THEY
REALLY, REALLY LIKE.
THEY REALLY LIKE JERMAINE
JOHNSON A LOT.
THEY REALLY LIKE THE WIDE
RECEIVER CLASS AS WELL.
THEY LOVE DRAKE LONDON THOUGH
AND HE IS GONE.
THAT'S A BIG --
>> BEFORE WE KNOW THE PICK, ARE
YOU GOING TO BE HAPPIER WITH
JOHNSON, WHO I KNOW YOU
ABSOLUTELY LOVE, OR IF THEY GET
GARRETT WILSON.
>> DON'T SHOW IT YET.
>> I WOULD GO JERMAINE JOHNSON
BECAUSE -- I KNOW THAT DOESN'T
HELP ZACH WILSON.
I AM A BELIEVER THEY CAN FIND A
TRADE FOR SOMEBODY LIKE DEEBO.
JERMAINE JOHNSON I'M HIGHER ON
MOST EVERYBODY THAT DOES THIS
FOR A LIVING.
I HAVE HIM AS THE SIXTH OVERALL
PLAYER.
HE A STUD.
>> THE JETS HAVE TWO PICKS.
THE DEEP WIDE RECEIVER CLASS
COULD GET THERE.
THIS IS IT FOR --
>> HELP YOUR QUARTERBACK OR HURT
THE OTHER QUARTERBACKS.
YOU CAN'T GO WRONG.
IF THEY GO OFF THAT SCRIPT --
>> HERE IT IS.
GARRETT WILSON.
>> HELP THE QUARTERBACK.
>> OKAY.
>> WIDE RECEIVER NUMBER ONE FOR
ME IN THE DRAFT.
A BLEND OF A CALVIN RIDLEY
BEFORE THE CATCH.
REMINDS ME OF CEEDEE LAMB WITH
THE BALL HAD IN HIS HANDS.
EXCELLENT FEET, SHORT AREA OF
QUICKNESS, LONG SPEED.
HE PLAYS BIGGER THAN HIS SIDE.
YOU SEE THE SUB 4.4 SPEED.
I VAL IDENTIFY HIM AS THE BEST
RECEIVER IN THE DRAFT.
I LOVE THE FLOOR.
GUYS THAT EXCEL AT ALL THREE
PHASES BEFORE THE CATCH, AT THE
CATCH POINT, CONCENTRATION,
FOCUS, PLAYING BIG, SECURING THE
BALL AND WITH THE BALL IN THEIR
HANDS, THEY SUCCEED AT THE NEXT
LEVEL.
THERE IS TO NO CAN HE GET OPEN,
THERE IS NO CAN HE CATCH THE
BALL, CAN HE MAKE LIFE EASIER ON
THE QUARTERBACK BY MAKING PLAYS.
THEY HAVE NOT BEEN ABLE TO SWING
A TRADE.
NOW A PLAYER THAT IS PRO READY
AND ALSO FITS MICHAEL J. FOX
LaFLEUR'S OFFENSE.
>> HE IS THE TOP.
THIS.
>> WAS A DIVISION I BASKETBALL
RECRUIT OUT OF HIGH SCHOOL.
OHIO STATE COACHES WHEN ASKED
WERE TO TAKEN AWAY AT HIS
PROFESSIONALISM FROM THE TIME TO
GET THERE, YOU HAVE BEEN LOOKING
AT THIS FY A LONG TIME.
>> FOR A LONG TIME.
>> HE STANDS UP TO THE
SPOTLIGHT.
HE IS CINCREDIBLY PROFESSIONALS.
I TALKED TO HUNTER MANDELL.
HE REFERENCED WILSON IS SUCH A
PRO, A PRO THROUGH THE ENTIRE
PROCESS, WAS A PRO IN HIGH
SCHOOL WHEN HE WAS COMING OUT.
HE DOES THE LITTLE THINGS RIGHT.
THAT'S THE KEY HERE.
THIS IS A GUY THAT DOES THE
LITTLE THINGS RIGHT ON THE FIELD
AND OFF THE FIELD.
AND I LOVE THAT ABOUT HIM.
CLEARLY A STUDENT.
GAME.
UNDERSTANDS THE -- WE SAW THERE.
TEMPOING OUT A ROUTE, NOT GOING
FULL SPEED UNTIL HE KNOWS HE IS
OPEN FOR THE QUARTERBACK.
I GIVE IT AN A.
I THINK THE REALITY IS AS WE --
WHAT ARE WE?
THIS IS PICK NUMBER TEN?
>> TEN.
>> FOR A GUY WE THOUGHT COULD
HAVE GONE ANYWHERE FROM FIVE TO
SEVEN.
FIVE TO EIGHT.
>> YES.
>> YOU GET HIM AT TEN.
THIS IS A WIN.
LIKE I KNOW WE HAVE GOT TO GET
TO SOMEBODY ELSE.
BUT YOU ARE HAPPY.
>> HOW CAN YOU NOT BE?
THE
THAT WAS SOMETHING YOU HEARD
THROUGHOUT THE ENTIRE PROCESS.
COACHES AND SCOUTS WHO CAT GOWN
WITH GARRETT WILSON BLOWN AWAY.
WE ARE NOT TALKING ABOUT COLLEGE
OFFENSE OR THREE ROUTES.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT ANYTHING
YOU THROW AT ME, I AM GOOD TO
GO.
I WANT THE FOOTBALL.
I GOT TO SEE WHEN THEY CAME IN
TOWN AGAINST RUTGERS.
PLAY SPEED PHENOMENAL.
STRENGTH AFTER THE CATCH
PHENOMENAL.
GARRETT WILSON, WEIGHS THE BEST
WIDE RECEIVER IN THE DRAFT.
ELIJAH MOORE, GARRETT WILSON,
COREY DAVIS, TWO TIGHT ENDS,
FINALLY LOOKING COMPETENT ON
OFFENSE.
>> ELIJAH MOORE.
AMON-RA ST. BROWN, YOU WATCHED
FILM.
WHAT DID YOU COME AWAY THINKING,
AMADI?
>> THINK THINK THIS IS ONE OF MY
FAVORITE RECEIVERS.
HE CAN DO IT ALL.ON-RA?
>> THINK THINK THIS IS ONE OF MY
FAVORITE RECEIVERS.
HE CAN DO IT ALL.
I LOVE HIS HIGH POINTABILITY.
YOU WATCH THE TAPE.
THE ONE PLAY THAT STANDS OUT TO
ME IS THAT PLAY, HIS -- AGAINST
CLEMSON WHERE HE JUMPED LIKE
40 INCHES IN THE AIR AND CAUGHT
THE BALL.
HIS HIGH POINT CATCHABILITY IS
GREAT.
HE IS FAST.
HE RUNS GREAT ROUTES.
HE CAN STOP ON A DIME.
THOSE ARE THINGS YOU ARE LOOKING
FOR IN A RECEIVER.
THIS ONE OF MY FAVORITE
RECEIVERS IN THE DRAFT.
I THINK IT'S A GREAT PICK FOR
THE JETS.
>> ALL RIGHT.
GARRETT WILSON, YOU MENTIONED
THAT HIGH POINT.
62% SUCCESS RATE IN CONTESTED
SITUATIONS FOR A GUY THAT'S
6 FEET TALL.
HE IS EXPLOSIVE.
AND THAT'S WHAT'S EXCITING.
CONGRATULATIONS ON A PRETTY GOOD
DRAFT.
>> I DIDN'T MAKE THE PICK.
JETS LOOKING BETTER.
YOU HELP OUT ZACH AND GET SAUCE.
THEY ARE GOING TO HAVE BATTLES
IN TRAINING CAMP.
PICK NUMBER 11, THE WASHINGTON
COMMANDERS, ARE TRADING BACK AND
THE SAINTS MOVE UP.
THIS WAS SOMETHING WE TALKED
ABOUT.
THE SAINTS TRADED WITH THE
EAGLES IN THE BEGINNING OF THIS
PROCESS TO GET THEMSELVES A
SECOND FIRST ROUND PICK AND NOW
THEY ARE MOVING UP.
WE ARE NOT SURE WHICH PICK THEY
IS TO GET UP THERE.
THE SAINTS MOVING UP.
WHAT DO YOU THINK IT'S FOR?
>> THERE HAS BEEN A LOT OF TALK
ABOUT THEM WITH QUARTERBACK AND
THEY HAVE THEIR PICK OF THE
LITTER RIGHT HERE.
BUT, MAN, DO THEY NEED A TACKLE.
THEY LOST ARMSTEAD.
I WOULD NOT AGREE WITH THIS
PICK.
I THINK THE LEAGUE IS HIGHER ON
TREVOR PENNING THAN MEDIA AND
FANS THAT WOULD SHOCK ME HERE.
>> BECAUSE THERE HAS BEEN A
RECENT RUN ON TACKLES, THEY HAVE
TO, YOU ARE THINKING?
>> LAST ONE, THE RUN ON
RECEIVERS HAS STARTED.
I KNOW THE JETS WERE -- NOT
SURPRISED --
>> YOU'RE RIGHT.
>> THE JETS LIKE DRAKE LONDON.
HE WENT AT ATE.
THE JETS TOOK WILSON.
CHRIS OLAVE WILL GO SOON.
JAMESON WILLIAMS WILL GO SOON.
THE EAGLES LIKE HIM.
TREYLON BURKS IS GOING TO GO IN
THE FIRST ROUND.
>> THE SAINTS ARE TRADING THEIR
16th PICK AND A THIRD AND FOURTH
TO WASHINGTON FOR THE LEFT PICK.
SAINTS ALSO HAVE THE 19th PICK.
THEY ARE KEEPING 19.
THEY ARE GOING TO MOVE UP TO 11.
AND THIS IS MICKEY LOOMIS
GETTING IT DONE.
THE STORY FOR THE SAINTS, WE ARE
NOW IN THE POST-SEAN PAYTON ERA.
I DON'T THINK PEOPLE REALIZE THE
KIND OF CONTROL HE HAD OVER THE
FRANCHISE.
IT IS A COMPLETELY DIFFERENT
VIBE.
IT IS JUST MICHAEL THOMAS THERE
ON THE OUTSIDE.
HE DIDN'T PLAY LAST YEAR.
THEY HAVE MARK GALLOWAY AND
TRE'QUAN SMITH IF THEY ARE
COMING YOU HAVE FOR A WIDE
RECEIVER.
ALVIN KAMARA HAD HIS OFF-FIELD
INCIDENT.
THEY DID HAVE SOME SAFETY
QUESTIONS WHICH IS MY ONLY OTHER
THING HERE.
MARCUS MAY REPLACE MARCUS
WILLIAMS BUT MALCOLM JENKINS
RETIRES.
MAKE A KYLE HAMILTON THING?
>> THAT'S A LUXURY FOR THEM
RIGHT NOW THOUGH.
AND I LOVE KYLE HAMILTON.
I KNOW YOU DO, TOO.
>> IT'S HARD FOR ME, FOR YOU TO
GO INTO THE SEASON WITH JAMEIS
WINSTON AND SAY WE DON'T REALLY
HAVE A LEFT TACKLE.
THAT'S TOUGH FOR ME TO SAY.
I AM NOT SAYING THE ANSWER IS
HERE, BUT HOW THEY ARE THINKING.
>> THE IDEA THAT THEY GIVE UP
THIS DRAFT CAPITAL, DRAFT
PENDING --
>> NOT A GOOD MOVE.
>> EXACTLY.
WHAT WOULD BE A GOOD MOVE FOR
THEM TO TRADE UP IT TO DO?
CERTAINLY DOESN'T FEEL LIKE IT'S
GOOD TO GET WILLIS.
>> I DON'T THINK THEY NEED A
DEFENSIVE PASS-RUSHER.
THEY PUT A LOT OF -- DAFB PORT,
THEY GAVE UP FUTURE FIRST ROUND
PICKS TO GET HIM.
>> WHAT'S A GOOD MOVE?
WHAT'S A GOOD MOVE?
TRADING UP TO GET --
>> CAN WIE SEE CONNOR'S BIG
BOARD?
>> DRAFT AND STASH JAMESON
WILLIAMS IS THE MOVE HERE.
THAT'S IT FOR ME.
>> THEY DON'T NEED LINDERBAUM.
THEY DON'T NEED JERMAINE
JOHNSON.
POSSIBLY KYLE HAMILTON.
>> I LIKE --
>> JORDAN DAVIS, NOT REALLY.
DEVIN LLOYD, NO.
SO YOU ARE THINKING RIGHT HERE
IT'S A WIDE RECEIVER OR A REACH
ON A TACKLE?
>> THE VALUE AT WIDE RECEIVER
BECAUSE THEY ARE GOING TO GO.
I AM KIND OF SURPRISED
WASHINGTON WAS WILLING TO DEAL
WITH THEM --
>> NEEDS A WIDE RECEIVER.
>> THEY DO, BUT THEY LOVE DRAKE
LONDON AND THEY LIKED GARRETT
WILSON.
>> IF YOU ARE SITTING THERE
GOING HEY WHEN WE DROP BACK,
OLAVE WILL BE THERE.
SOMEONE ELSE THAT CAN GO ALONG
--
>> SAINTS LIKE OLAVE TOO.
THIS SEEMS EARLY FOR OLAVE BUT
THEY LIKE HIM A LOT
>> DWHO WE THINK THE SAINTS ARE
TRYING TO JUMP?
UP NEXT WAS VIKINGS, TEXANS,
RAVENS EAGLES.
WE HAVE BEEN HEARING RUMORS
ABOUT THE EAGLES.
>> IT'S THE FEAR THAT SOMEBODY
ELSE WILL BEAT YOU TO THE PURGE.
THEY GOT IT DOWN FOR A THIRD AND
FOURTH ROUND PICK.
ONE IS A TOP 100.
>> ALL I'M HERE IS YOU WANT
OLAVE --
>> THE SAINTS DO THIS EVERY
YEAR.
THIS IS THE LEAST PSURPRISING
THING.
THEY MOVE UP EVERY YEAR.
THEY ARE NOT AFRAID TO PLAY THE
BOARD.
I HAVE A FEAR HERE THAT IT IS
FOR A TACKLE THAT IS A REACH
BECAUSE OF DESPERATION.
>> SEE IF YOUR FEAR IS REALIZED.
CHRIS OLAVE IS THE PICK FOR THE
SAINTS.
>> THEY LOVED HIM.
AND THEY WERE AFRAID HE WOULDN'T
MAKE IT TO THEMMISM THOUGHT HE
WOULD HAVE.
>> THEY HAVE BEEN LOOKING FOR
ANOTHER WIDE RECEIVER TO PUT ON
THE OPPOSITE SIDE OF MICHAEL
THOMAS.
WHY NOT ANOTHER GUY FROM OHIO
STATE, CHRIS OLAVE.
WE ARE MOVING ON FROM THE SEAN
PAYTON ERA AND TRYING TO FILL
OUT WEAPONS ON THE OUTSIDE.
WHAT IS THE VALUE FOR CHRIS
OLAVE?
IS THERE WHERE YOU SAW HIM
GOING?
>> YEAH.
THE RUN ON WIDE RECEIVERS HAS
STARTED.
HE IS MY 22nd OVERALL PLAYER.
IT'S GOING HO HOT RIGHT NOW.
IT'S GOING FAST.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT IT PERFECT FIT
FOR THE SAINTS OFFENSE, A GUY
SUPER SMOOTH, KNOWS HOW TO GET
OPEN, CREATES SEPARATION, TRACK
THE FOOTBALL.
WITH OLAVE, THE LACK OF UPSIDE
IS THAT HE DOESN'T MAKE THINGS
HAPPEN WITH THE BALL NIS HANDS,
DOESN'T FORCE TACKLES, DOESN'T
RUN THROUGH ANYBODY.
THERE WILL BE A LITTLE BIT OF AN
ADJUSTMENT PHYSICALLY BECAUSE HE
IS NOT THE BIGGEST GUY.
HE WILL SEE MORE PRESS COVERAGE
AT THE NEXT LEVEL AND LEARN HOW
TO GET OFF.
HE HAS THE FEET AND THE RELEASES
AT THE LINE OF SCRIMMAGE DO
THAT.
SO FOR THE SAINTS HERE YOU WENT
UP, YOU GOT YOUR GUY, YOU DIDN'T
WANT TO WALK OUT OF THE DRAFT
WITHOUT A TOP FLIGHT WIDE
RECEIVER.
OLAVE IS ONE OF FIVE THAT I HAV.
WHAT YOU SEE IS WHAT YOU GET, A
GOOD PLAYER, NEVER AN
EXCEPTIONAL PLAYER.
SO FOR ME A B-PLUS HERE.
ROCK SOLID PICK.
SUPER, SUPER HIGH FLOOR FOR THE
SAINTS.
>> THE ALL-TIME LEADER IN
TOUCHDOWN CATCHES FOR OHIO
STATE, 35.
REFERRED TO HIM AS THE BIG
BROTHER IN THE WIDE RECEIVER
ROOM.
I KNOW YOU HAVE BEEN WATCHING
HIM FOR A LONG TIME.
WHAT DO YOU THINK OF THIS PICK?
>> HE HAS GOT STRAIGHT LINE
SPEED.
HE IS A RABBIT.
TO ME RABBITS DON'T RUN IN
STRAIGHT LINES.
WHILE HE HAS THE STRAIGHT-LINE
SPEED, THE BEST PART OF HIS GAME
FOR ME IS THAT JITTERBUG
ELEMENT, ABILITY TO BEND AND
MOVE AROUND TO GET OPEN.
WHILE HE DOES IS NOT A TACKLE
BREAKER LIKE DRAKE LONDON, HE IS
NOT AS PHYSICAL OR A HIGH POINT
GUY AS GARRETT WILSON, BUT HE
DOES HAVE THE ABILITY TO
UNDERSTAND WHEN HE IS GOING TO
GET OPEN, HE KNOWS WHEN TO LEAVE
HIMSELF SPACE TO FADE TO THE
SIDELINES.
I THINK THAT YOU SAID YOU HAVE
FIVE WIDE RECEIVERS GRADED OUT
AS FIRST-ROUNDERS.
I THINK HE IS THE LAST OF THE
FIVE.
SO FOR ME I GIVE IT A B-MINUS.
THEY GOT A COMPLEMENTARY PIECE,
SOMEONE TOE HELP THEM, BUT YOU
COULD HAVE GOT TWO OTHER GUYS IN
WILLIAMS OR TREYLON BURKS THAT
WOULD HAVE BEEN ABLE TO BE -- I
THINK HAVE A HIGHER --
>> DIMENSION.
>> EXACTLY.
>> PHYSICALLY IMPOSING.
>> YES.
>> I AM WITH YOU.
>> THE DETROIT LIONS WIDE
RECEIVER AMON-RA ST. BROWN.
YOU ARE WATCHING OLAVE ON TAPE
AND YOU CAME AWAY THINKING WHAT?
>> MOST OF ALL, OLAVE, HOW
SMOOTH HE IS.
I WATCHED THE COMBINE, SAW THAT
4.3.
I DIDN'T KNOW HE WAS THAT FAST.
AS A RECEIVER THAT'S SOMETHING
PEOPLE LOOK FOR, SOMETHING YOU
WANT AS A RECEIVER.
SO WHEN YOU ARE WINNING YOUR
ROUTES, DBs CAN'T EEL TELL WHAT
YOU ARE DOING BECAUSE YOU ARE
SMOOTH AND OUT OF THE BREAKS.
OBVIOUSLY, HE WILL BE A DEEP
THREAT.
A GOOD FIT FOR HIM.
YEAH, I LIKE THE PICK.
AND JUST HOW SMOOTH HE IS STOOD
OUT TO ME.
>> AMON-RA, I WANT TO KEEP YOU
ON BECAUSE YOUR DETROIT LIONS
HAVE TRADED UP NOW INTO THIS
SPOT.
>> I GOT THE PICK TEXT.
>> AND YOU HAVE THE PICK TEXTED
TO YOU.
AMON-RA ST. BROWN AND CONNOR ON
CAMERA.
CONNOR, DO YOU WANT TO TELL
AMON-RA ST. BROWN WHO HIS
DETROIT LIONS HAVE TAKEN AS WE
KNOW HE --
>> I GOT A TEXT FROM YOUR
BUILDING THAT IT IS -- I THINK
YOU ARE GOING TO HAVE A LOT OF
FUN WITH THIS AND A LOT OF
SUCCESS WITH THIS.
YOU WILL BE PLAYING ALONGSIDE
JAMESON WILLIAMS IN THAT
OFFENSE.
IT WILL BE ELECTRIC WATCHING YOU
GUYS.
>> LOOK AT THE SMILE.
>> THAT'S GOING TO BE DOPE.
>> THERE IT IS.
>> A THAT'S A HUGE PICK.
>> AND LET'S GO BACK TO AMON-RA
ST. BROWN.
AMON-RA, WHAT'S YOUR FEELING
OTHER THAN THIS IS GOING TO BE
DOPE BECAUSE IT IS GOING TO BE
DOPE.
>> YEAH, I MEAN, I WATCH A LOT
OF BAMA GAMES.
HUGE DEEP THREAT, JAMESON
WILLIAMS.
I THINK IT WILL BE A GREAT FIT
FOR US, SOMEONE TO TAKE THE TOP
OFF THE DEFENSE.
HE DIDN'T RUN HIS 40.
I DON'T THINK HE HAD TO.
YOU WATCH THE TAPE.
HE IS FAST.
HE GETS THE BALL IN HIS HANDS,
NO ONE'S TOUCHING HIM.
I AM EXCITED FOR THE PICK.
GETTING TO PLAY ALONGSIDE HEIM
AND A BUNCH OF OTHER DUDES WE
GOT.
>> YOU GOT A MESSAGE FOR HIM WE
CAN PASS ALONG?
>> GET READY TO ROCK OUT BECAUSE
YOU ABOUT TO HAVE A LOT OF FUN,
BABY.
>> I LOVE IT.
ALL RIGHT.
NOW LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT THE
FOOTAGE, GET SOME GRADES HERE.
DETROIT LIONS SAID WE DO NOT
WANT TO WAIT AROUND AND HAVE TO
MAYBE HOPE A WIDE RECEIVER FALLS
US TO AT 32.
THERE WERE TEAMS IN THE TEENS
THAT WERE LOOKING AT THE JAMESON
WILLIAMS AND THE LIONS JUST
JUMPED UP.
THEIR FIRST PICK THEY FIND AIDAN
HUTCHISON.
NOW THEY GET JAMESON WILLIAMS.
ARGUABLY, THE TOP TWO PLAYERS AT
THEIR POSITION.
WHAT DO YOU THINK OF THE LIONS'
MOVE AND THE PLAYER?
>> I MEAN, LOVE BOTH.
NUMBER ONE, THIS IS GREAT, A
GREAT JOB BY BRAD HOLMES TO
UNDERSTAND HOW THE BOARD WAS
GOING TO BREAK.
WHEN THE WIDE RECEIVER RUN
STARTS, IT IS GOING TO COME IN
HOT AND FAST AND EVERYBODY
THOUGHT ATLANTA IS WHERE IT
COULD BEGIN.
EVERYBODY KNEW THE NEW YORK JETS
WOULD BE IN ON IT THE LIONS MADE
A MOVE FOR MY NUMBER TWO WIDE
RECEIVER IN THE DRAFT.
HERE IS THE REALITY.
GUYS THAT ARE SUB 4.3 PLAYERS
THAT HAVE ROUTE POLISH ARE RARE.
THEY ARE RARE.
THERE ARE GUYS EVERY YORE THAT
GO TO INDY AND RUN SUB 4.3 AND
THE FASHT COMMUNITY AND PEOPLE
BECOME OBSESSED.
WHEN YOU HAVE POLISH COACHES AND
TEAMS BECOME OBSESSED.
JAMESON
JAMESON WILLIAMS MY PICK.
THIS IS AN A MINUS FOR ME.
THIS LIONS RIGHT OFFENSE RIGHT
NOW REAL PLAYMAKERS, REAL
WEAPON.
WHAT JAMESON CAN DO IS TAKE
DEFENDERS OUT OF THE BOX AND
OPEN UP A GROUND AND POUND
ATTACK
>> OUR GUY AMON-RA ST. BROWN
SUDDENLY GOING TO HAVE A LOT OF
ROOM TO DICE UP PEOPLE'S ANKLES.
WHAT'S YOUR TAKE?
>> HE IS MY NUMBER ONE WIDE
RECEIVER IN THE DRAFT.
ONE OF MY FAVORITE PLAYERS TO
WATCH.
HIS ABILITY TO WORK INTO THAT
ROUTE RUNNING IS ABSOLUTELY
BEAUTIFUL.
YOU SEE HIM HERE RECOGNIZING,
HEY, I GOT A BACK-PEDAL.
I AM GOING TO BE WIDE OPEN.
THIS ONE HERE, GOT IT.
I CAN GET OPEN.
YOU SEE HOW WIDE -- NOT JUST HOW
WIDE OPEN HE IS, BUT HE BREAKS
UP OVER THE TOP TO CREATE THAT
SPACE.
HE KNOWS WHEN HE HAS TO TURN ON
THAT SUB 4.3 SPEED TO RUN AWAY
FROM PEOPLE.
THIS GREAT EXAMPLE.
STEP STRAIGHT.
LOOK AT HIM.
BOOM.
NOW I AM GOING.
YOU ARE NOT GOING TO GET ME.
IT'S OKAY.
YOU TOUCHED ME BUT YOU DIDN'T
TACKLE ME.
LOSING HIM IN THE NATIONAL
CHAMPIONSHIP GAME HURT ALABAMA
THE MOST.
FOR ME, I THINK THAT HE IS
SOMEONE THAT IS JUST -- HE IS
INCREDIBLY EXPLOSIVE.
WHEN HE COMES BACK FROM THE
INJURY HEALTHY HE WILL BE AN
ABSOLUTE NIGHTMARE TO COVER.
IF TRUE TOY PLAY HIM IN MAN HE
WILL GET YOU LEANING AND THEN HE
WILL FIND A WAY TO RUN AWAY FROM
YOU.
IF YOU PLAY HIM IN ZONE, HE
KNOWS WHERE TO STOP.
THIS IS AN A-PLUS.
MY NUMBER ONE WIDE RECEIVER IN
THE DRAFT.
MY GUY I THOUGHT WHAT BE A
DIFFERENCE MAKER, SOMEONE THAT
COMES IN WITH POLISH.
HE WON'T TAKE -- THE ONLY TIME
HE NEEDS IS TO BE HEALTHY.
IT'S NOT GOING TO TAKE TIME TO
LEARN HOW TO RUN ROUTES AT THE
NEXT LEVEL.
WE MENTIONED IT WITH GARRETT
WILSON.
THIS IS ANOTHER ONE OF THOSE
PLAYERS THAT CAN ALREADY DO
THAT.
THE.
>> DETROIT LIONS TRADING THE
PICK THEY GOT IN THE RETURN FOR
MATT STAFFORD.
WE WILL SEE IF JAMESON WILLIAMS
CAN BE THE WIDE RECEIVER FOR THE
FUTURE.
WANT TH
TO LET YOU KNOW WE ARE WAY AHEAD
OF DIVISION.
BECAUSE THEY ARE DOING THAT, WE
ARE GOING TO TAKE THIS TIME FOR
A LITTLE MESSAGE FROM ROCKET
MORTGAGE.
>>> AND LOOK WHAT WE COME BACK
TO.
THE OLD DIRTY BIRDS.
THE EAGLES ARE TRADING UP TO 13
WITH THE HOUSTON TEXANS.
WHO ARE THEY GOING TO GET?
CONNOR'S FIRST REACTION?
TREYLON BURKS.
WE HAVE A RUN ON WIDE RECEIVERS.
IT'S THREE IN A ROW FOUR OF THE
LAST FIVE.
THE EAGLES ARE TRADING 15 # 124,
126.
>> 166.
WHO CARES ABOUT THOSE PICKS?
SO THE EAGLES MOVE UP TWO SPOTS
TO JUMP THE RAVENS.
THERE A CHANCE IT'S FOR JORDAN
DAVIS?
>> I KNOW THE RAVENS LIKE
JERMAINE JOHNSON.
IS IT --
>> NOW, I MESSAGED YOU GUYS WHEN
YOU ARE DOING IT LIVE ON THE B/R
APP AND I SAID I FEEL LIKE THE
EAGLES ARE GOING TO TAKE
JERMAINE JOHNSON.
THEY'VE DRAFTED FLORIDA STATE
GUYS IN THE PAST, BUNKLEY COMES
TO MINDFUL I LOOK AT THE EAGLES
AND I DON'T MEAN TO TALK ABOUT
PEOPLE WHEN THEY GET UP IN AGE,
BRANDON GRAMMY IS TURNING 34
THIS YEAR.
LAST YEAR WAS SECOND TO LAST IN
THE NFL IN SACKS.
BRANDON GRACHL HAD AN INCREDIBLE
CAREER.
DEREK BARNETT AN OKAY CAREER.
THEY INVESTED A LOT IN THE
INTERIOR DEFENSIVE LINE, JAVON
HARGRAVE, WILLIAMS IS COMING
ALONG AND THE FACT THAT I TOLD
YOU GUYS THIS, IF IT IS
JERMAINE, I AM GOING FEEL LIKE
A -- THIS IS A GUY I HEARD COULD
GO AS HIGH AS TOP FIVE.
>> THREE-POINTER, TRENT
McDUFFIE.
I KNOW HE IS NOT A LEAPER ON
ANYONE'S BOARD --
>> THE EAGLES TRADED UP AND KEPT
THEIR OTHER TOP 20 PICK IS
EXCITING AS WELL.
I WANT YOUR PREDICTIONS RIGHT
NOW.
>> WOW.
YOU KNOW WHAT?
GO WITH JERMAINE BECAUSE OF THE
MOVE.
IF YOU ARE GOING AHEAD OF
BALTIMORE, BUT I LOOK AT THEM
AND I DO THINK THEY HAVE
INVESTED IN EDGE PASS-RUSH
RECENTLY.
>> YOU'RE RIGHT.
REDDICK
>> AND THEY PAID JOSH SWEAT I I
TALKED TO SQUER JERMAINE AT THE
COMBINE.
HE LOVES TO RUSH OFF THE
SHOULDER.
HE IS A WIDE RUSHER.
I LOOK AT THIS FOR THE EAGLES
HERE.
I WILL GO WITH TRENT McDUFFIE.
I JUST THINK THE LEAGUE IS A LOT
HIGHER ON HIM THAN EVERYONE ELSE
HAS BEEN.
I HAD HIM OVER STINGILY BUT I
LIKE THE FLOOR WITH TRENT.LEY B
LIKE THE FLOOR WITH TRENT.
>> WHO IS GOING TO MAKE ME
HAPPY?
>> I GIVE LEV COTHE WIN HERE.
I THINK IT WILL BE JERMAINE OR I
THINK THE NAME THAT YOU GUYS ARE
BOTH FORGETTING IS KYLE
HAMILTON.
>> YOU HAD THE PICK.
IT'S FUN.
I LIKE IT.
>> IS IT NONE OF THE GUYS?
>> IT IS SOMEBODY IN PLAY FOR
BALTIMORE.
THAT'S THE TRADE-UP.
IT'S JORDAN DAVIS.
>> WOW.
YES!
MY FAVORITE PLAYER IN THIS
DRAFT.
JORDAN DAVIS, THE MONSTER.
>> BOOM, BABY!
>> THE BIGGEST, FASTEST,
STRONGEST GUY ALL OVER THE
PLACE, JORDAN DAVIS, JASON
KELCE, HOW ARE WE FEEL RIGHT
NOW?
A
HOW WITH ARE WE FEELING?
>> LEFKOE, COULDN'T BE HAPPIER.
H
HELL YEAH!
WHY NOT BIG THE BIGGEST MONSTER,
THE DANCING BEAR, 4.7, 3340
POUNDS.
IT'S A HARD MISS.
PHYSICS DO NOT CHANGE.
FORCE EQUALS MASS TIMES
ACCELERATION.
COMING RIGHT THROUGH YOU.
ISAAC NEWTON LOVES THIS PICK.
LET'S GO TO THIS VIDEO.
I LOVE IT.
EAGLES TRADE UP OVER THE RAVENS
BECAUSE IF JORDAN DAVIS WOULD
HAVE GONE TO THE RAVENS WE WOULD
HAVE SAID, WHAT A RAVENS PICK.
WHAT A PERFECT PICK FOR THE
RAVENS.
NOW HE IS AN EAGLE, OKAY?
WE GAVE THE RAVENS LAMAR JACKSON
PICK 32 YEARS AGGIE O AND WE AR
STEALING HIM BACK.
>> I AM HAPPY WE'RE HERE.
LISTEN, HOW MANY HUMAN BEINGS DO
THEY MAKE THAT ARE THIS BIG AND
THIS FAST?
IT IS UNLIKE ANYTHING WE HAVE
SEEN BEFORE WITH JORDAN DAVIS.
HE CAN CONTROL TWO GAPS.
HE CAN CONTROL THE GUY IN FRONT
OF HIM.
HE IS INCREDIBLE THREAT AS A RUN
DEFENDER.
HIS ABILITY TO JUST EAT UP
BLOCKS BUT ALSO PUSH THE POCKET
AND JUST BE A DIFFERENCE MAKER
AS A TRUE ZERO.
A TRUE NOSE.
HE CAN PLAY SHADE NOSE.
I KNOW EVERYBODY GETS SO CAUGHT
UP ABOUT THE SNAP PERCENTAGE AT
THE COLLEGE LEVEL.
GEORGIA 85 MILLION EXCELLENT
DEFENSIVE LINEMAN.
IS THERE A LITTLE BIT MORE TO BE
DESIRED AS A PURE PASS-RUSHER?
YES, YOU CAN TAP INTO IT @THAT
SIZE.
HE WILL COME IN AND BE ONE OF
THE BEST RUN DEFENDERS, ONE OF
THE BEST TRUE NOSE TACKLES IN
THE ENTIRE LEAGUE.
I LIKE THE AGGRESSIVE NATURE TO
JUMP BALTIMORE.
BOINS POINTS FOR THAT.
A-PLUS.
>> AND NOW YOU GET TO BE THE
HATER.
AND I WANT YOU TO REALLY LET IT
OUT.
I WANT YOU TO LET IT FLOW.
DON'T BE WORRIED.
LET IT FLOW.
>> I AM NOT GOING TO BE THE
HATER.
I AM CURIOUS TO WATCH HIM IN THE
SCHEME.
YOU PLAY HIM WITH FLETCHER COX?
>> AND HARGRAVE.
>> HOW DOES THAT WORK?
WHICH ONE OF THESE GUYS IS
COMING OUT?
HOW DOES THAT WORK FOR THEM.
THAT'S THE PART I AM CURIOUS TO
SEE BECAUSE HE IS A TRUE NOSE.
AND GEORGIA --
>> A QUICK NOTE.
FLETCHER COX AND HARGRAVE FREE
AGENTS AFTER THIS YEAR.
>> I LOVE THAT BECAUSE THIS IS A
GUY THAT PLAYED IN A TRUE 3-4 AT
GEORGIA.
THAT'S WHY GUYS LIKE MYSELF SAID
HE IS A PERFECT FIT FOR THE
RAVENS.
HE WOULD HAVE BEEN THE TRUE
NOSE.
THE BIGGEST THING FOR ME, I WANT
TO GET THIS RIGHT BECAUSE I WANT
TO SAY THIS BECAUSE WE TALKED
ABOUT IT OFF AIR, I WANT TO SAY
IT ON AIR.
THE BIGGEST THING IS THE GROWTH
FROM THE S.E.C. CHAMPIONSHIP
GAME TO THE NATIONAL
CHAMPIONSHIP GAME.
IN THE S.E.C. CHAMPIONSHIP GAME
A GUY ON A BAYLOR TOUCHDOWN PASS
STANDING STRAIGHT UP LOOKING AT
THE SIDELINE LIKE, COACH, YOU'VE
GOT TO GET ME OUT OF HERE, THEY
ARE EAT MIEG LUNCH.
HE WENT TO THE TREADMILL, WROTE
AN ARTICLE AND SAID, HEY, AND HE
MENTIONED THE IDEA THAT, HEY, HE
GOT ON THE TREADMILL.
HE PUT IN MILES FOR REAL MILES
SO THAT WOULD NEVER HAPPEN TO
HIM AGAIN.
HE TAKES HIS OWN CRITICISM.
HE TOOK THE MEDIA'S CRITICISM OF
HIM AND TURNED HIMSELF INTO A
GUY THAT GOT PICKED -- WHAT IS
THIS?
TOP 13 OF THE NFL DRAFT BECAUSE
OF WHAT HE WAS ABLE TO DO
AGAINST ALABAMA.
I DON'T THINK I WAS WRONG OVER
THE COURSE.
SEASON.
I THINK HIS ABILITY TO MAKE THAT
TRANSITION, THAT DOES MAKE THIS
AN A LEFKOE PLUS.
>> OH!
NICK SABAN SAID, QUOTE, HE IS
ABOUT AS GOOD OF A PLAYER I HAVE
SEEN IN A LONG TIME AS AN INSIDE
PLAYER ON ANY TEAM.
THE IRONY.
THIS IS YOUR CHUCK BEDNAREK
AWARD WINNER.
YOU KNOW WHO HE PLAYED FOR?
THE PHILADELPHIA EAGLES.
CONCRETE CHARLIE.
WES
WE WERE YELLING EARLIER.
JASON KELCE, WHAT WILL IT BE
LIKE SEEING THIS MAMMOTH OF A
MAN WALKING INTO CAMP?
>> YEAH, FIRST OF ALL, LOVE THE
GRADE, MICHAEL.
I THINK THAT I'M CERTAINLY NOT
LOOKING FORWARD TO BLOCKING HIM
IN TRAINING CAMP BUT I AM
LOOKING FORWARD TO BEING ON HIS
TEAM.
I ACTUALLY THINK HE IS A GOOD
SCHEME FIT FOR US.
GANNON LIKES TO RUN A LOT OF
FIVE DOWN FRONTS.
WE LIKE TO, YOU KNOW, PUT THREE
D TACKLES IN THE GAME QUITE A
BIT AND I THINK JORDAN HAS THE
ATHLETICISM AND THE FLUIDITY TO
BE ABLE TO PLAY NOSE THREE OR
EVEN A FOUR I ON RUN DOWNS, THAT
FOUR I SHADING THAT TACKLE
BECAUSE OF HOW ATHLETIC HE IS.
THAT FILLS A MAJOR, MAJOR SPOT
FOR US.
AND THEN WITH MILTON WILLIAMS ON
THE OTHER -- BEING ABLE TO COME
IN, THAT DEFENSIVE LINE IS SO
STACKED NOW.
THERE REALLY ISN'T A WEAKNESS.
I'M EXCITED TO SEE THIS KID.
EXCITED TO SEE HIM GROW WITH
FLETCHER COX, HARGRAVE, AND,
HOPEFULLY, CALL HELP FROM THE
GUARD TO TRY TO BLOCK HIM
BECAUSE HE HAS ME OUTWEIGHED BY
QUITE A BIT.
>> I LOVE IT.
YOU KNOW WHAT?
THE FACT THAT THEY TAKE HIM WHO
WE'RE SO EXCITED ABOUT THE AND
THE SIXERS JUST ELIMINATED THE
RAPTORS, WHAT A MOMENT.
LIKE WHAT A LAST MINUTE THAT I
JUST EXPERIENCED.
THAT WAS GREAT.
HERE ARE THE LAST TEN PICKS.
WE SAUCE GARDNER AT FOUR.
ONLY SURPRISING BECAUSE HE WAS A
SECOND CORNER TAKEN.
WE WRAPPED UP THE EDGES AT FIVE.
THEN WE FINISHED OFF THE TOP
TIER OFFENSIVE LINEMEN.
DRAKE LONDON WENT.
FINISHED OFF CHARLES CROSS.
WIDE RECEIVER, WIDE RECEIVER,
WIDE RECEIVER, AND THEN
DEFENSIVE LINEMAN RIGHT THERE.
AND NOW WE'RE AT THIS
INTERESTING PART OF THE DRAFT.
THE RAVENS ARE SITTING THERE.
HOW DO YOU THINK THE RAVENS ARE
FEELING RIGHT NOW?
THE EAGLES HAVE NOW DONE THIS
MULTIPLE DRAFTS IN A ROW.
THEY JUMPED IN FRONT OF THE
GIANTS LAST YEAR AND STOLE
DeVONTA SMITH AND THAT LEFT THE
GIANTS WITH A BAD TASTE.
WHO DO YOU THINK THE RAVENS ARE
PIVOTING TO NOW IF YOU THOUGHT
IT WAS JORDAN DAVIS?
>> JERMAINE JOHNSON.
THEY NEED HELP ON THE DEFENSIVE
LINE.
THEY HAVE SOME QUESTIONS AT
TACKLE BECAUSE THEY WENT OUT AND
SIGNED MORGAN MOSES ON A
THREE-YEAR DEAL.
STANLEY HAD SOME TOUGH INJURY
LUCK.
THEY HAVE BEEN BEAT UP ON THE
OFFENSIVE LINE.
THEY NOT THEIR CORNERS BACK
HEALTHY.
>> THEY TRIED TO SIGN ZA'DARIUS
SMITH.
HE WENT TO THE VIKINGS AND BAUER
IS COMING OFF OFFSEASON
SURGERIES.
>> I WOULD BE SURPRISED IF IT'S
NOT JERMAINE.
>> JETS.
>> WOW!
>> I TOLD YOU.
THE RAVENS TO TAKE KYLE
HAMILTON, BUT NOW THE --
>> THAT'S WHY I SAID COULD WE
PULL IT UP?
>> HOLD ON.
LET ME SET IT UP.
THERE ARE CERTAIN POSITIONS THAT
FEEL ROMANTIC, AND ONE OF THEM
IS AN ELITE SAFETY FOR THE
BALTIMORE RAVENS.
AND JUST IT FEELS A POSITION
THAT SHOULD BE PERFECT.
AND THIS GUY MIGHT BE IT.
KYLE HAMILTON, 6'4", 220,
RUNNING A 4.5 NINE OUT OF NOTRE
DAME, GOES 14 TO THE RAVENS.
WHEN THE RAVENS TAKE YOU, IT
FEELS LIKE IT'S A GREAT PICK
ALREADY.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> EIGHTS GOOD SIGN ESPECIALLY
WHEN YOU PLAY DEFENSE.
LET ME START THIS FOR THE RAVENS
WITH A LITTLE EXCITEMENT.
I THINK THEY HAVE POTENTIALLY
THE BEST SAFETY DUO IN THE NFL
BY THE END OF THIS YEAR WITH
KYLE HAMILTON AND, OBVIOUSLY,
THEY SIGNED MARCUS WILLIAMS.
THESE GUYS COMPLIMENT EACH
OTHER.
MARCUS CAN DO THINGS IN
COVERAGE.
KYLE HAMILTON WHO CAN ALSO DO A
LOT INFORM C COVERAGE, SIDELINE
SIDELINE BLITZ.
HE IS THE SIZE OF A LINEBACKER.
HE CAN MOVE LIKE A SAFETY.
I THINK FOR THE RAVENS THIS IS
ALL ABOUT VALUE.
A TOP TEN PLAYER.
HE IS MY EIGHTH OVERALL PLAYER
IN THE DRAFT.
HE HITS WITH A TON OF FORCE.
HE CAN MAKE PLAYS ON THE BALL
BECAUSE HE HAS EXCEPTIONAL
LENGTH.
6'4".
LONG ARMS.
BALL SKILLS.
RANGE.
THIS IS PRETTY COOL.
THIS WILL BE REALLY COOL TO
WATCH.
THE BACK END OF THAT DEFENSE,
THEY ARE AGGRESSIVE WITH THE
CORNERS, BUT YOU LET THE
SAFETIES FLYING AROUND, CHUCK
CLARK IS THE SAFETY RIGHT NOW?
THEY MIGHT HAVE HAMILTON IN THE
SLOT.
THIS IS GOING TO BE AN -- IT
ALWAYS IS AN EXCITING DEFENSE TO
WATCH.
THIS JUST GOT SO MUCH MORE
EXCITING WITH KYLE HAMILTON.
THIS IS AN A FOR ME BECAUSE,
MAN, THEY HAD OTHER NEEDS.
YOU TOOK A GREAT FOOTBALL
PLAYER.
>> YOU AUDIBLY YELLED AND
FIST-PUMPED.
I JUST WANT TO KNOW WHY.
>> I LOVE HIM.
THE PLAY THAT WE SHOWED ON THAT
CLIP WAS A GUY GOING FROM FAR
HASH TO NEAR SIDELINE TO
INTERCEPT THE BALL THAT WAS A
BUSTED COVERAGE HE NEVER SHOULD
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO MAKE.
YOU WILL SEE A GUY JUST BE
PHYSICAL.
LET'S GO.
I AM GOING TO MAKE A PLAY AND
TAKE THE BALL AWAY FROM YOU.
YOU ARE NOT GOING TO CATCH THIS
ON ME.
I LOVE HIM COMING DOWN TO MAKE
TACKLES.
HE DOES EVERYTHING THAT YOU WANT
A SAFETY TO DO.
HE IS MY FAVORITE SAFETY IN THIS
GROUP.
I THINK HE WAS PROBABLY, IF I
GO -- IF I'M BEING GENEROUS TO
KAYVON THIBODEAUX, HE IS ONE, I
THINK HAMILTON TWO, DEAN IS
THREE FOR ME OUT OF MY FAVORITE
PLAYERS.
NO, SCREW IT.
HAMILTON IS MY FAVORITE PLAYER,
THEN DEAN, THEY ARE TIED , AND
THEN THIBODEAUX.
THIS AN A-PLUS.
I THOUGHT HE SHOULD HAVE WENT IN
THE TOP FIVE.
THEY WAY THEY VALUE SAFETIES,
DEFENSIVE BACKS, SAFETIES GET
SCREWED EVEN THOUGH THEY ARE ONE
OF THE MOST IMPORTANT POSITIONS
IN THE NFL.
>> NEL SCOUT SAYS EVERYONE SAYS
HE IS EXTREMELY AMBITIOUS BUT
THE EGO DOESN'T MATCH THE
TALENT.
HE IS HUMBLE.
RICHARD SHERMAN, WHAT DO WE
THINK OF THE TOP SAFETY GOING
OFF THE BOARD TO THE BALTIMORE
RAVENS AND KYLE HAMILTON.
YOU ARE SMILING ALREADY,
RICHARD.
>> WELL, I MEAN, BECAUSE I SHOUT
IT WAS GOING TO BE CRIMINAL IF
HE SLIPPED PAST 15.
BALTIMORE IS JUMPING OUT OF
THEIR SHOES BECAUSE THEY HAVE A
GREAT SECONDARY.
THEY PRIDE THEMSELVES ON THEIR
DEFENSE AND ALWAYS HAVE.
HUMPHRIES IS COMING BACK.
CHUCK CLARK IS GOING TO BE THE
THIRD SAFETY.
YOU HAVE MARCUS WILLIAMS COMING
IN.
THEY WILL BE SO DYNAMIC AND
VERSATILE IN THE SECONDARY AND
THEY NEED TO BE WITH CINCINNATI
BEING AS DYNAMIC AS THEY ARE AND
CONTINUING TO GROW.
THEY HAVE THREE RECEIVERS THAT
YOU HAVE TO DEAL WITH.
YOU HAVE TO BE ABLE TO COMBAT
THEIR VERSATILITY.
YOU KNOW THAT DESHAUN WATSON IS
WITH THE CLEVELAND BROWNS.
THAT DIVISION HAS GOTTEN BETTER
AND THE RAVENS HAVE RESPONDED.
>> MAN.
KYLE HAMILTON, THE SAFETY GOING
TO THE BALTIMORE RAVENS.
IN IS A TEAM THAT WAS BESET BY
INJURIES LAST YEAR.
MARCUS PETERS SEASON-ENDING
INJURY.
HUMPHRIES SEASON-ENDING INJURY.
IF MY STATS ARE CORRECT, THEY
WERE LAST IN THE NFL IN PASSING
YARDS ALLOWED LAST YEAR AND NOW
THEY HAVE A GUY IN THE BACK.
IF THEY GET HEALTHY, IT WILL BE
A NEW DEFENSIVE COORDINATOR IN
MIKE MacDONALD, WHICH WILL BE
INTERESTING.
THEY DRAFT WINNERS.
LOOKS LIKE HE DRAFTED ONE HERE.
>> AND THE CHANGE TO McDONALD
WON'T BE EXTREMELY DRASTIC.
WE SEE A LOT OF TEAMS GO THROUGH
IT.
WINK TO HIM.
>> THEY WILL BE A LITTLE BIT
CONSISTENT.
>> WOW.
OKAY.
A LOT OF EXCITEMENT HERE.
>> YEAH.
>> HE IS GOOD.
THE GUY IS GOOD, MAN.
IF YOU WATCH HIM PLAY, I DON'T
CARE WHAT HIS 40 TIME IS BECAUSE
HE HAS AN INCREDIBLE ABILITY TO
SEE THINGS BEFORE THEY HAPPEN.
AND THAT'S SOMETHING THAT I LOVE
OUT OF A SAFETY AND I LOVE IT
OUT OF A LINEBACKER.
WHEN YOU SEE STUFF AND YOU KNOW
IT'S GOING TO HAPPEN BEFORE IT
DUDS, WHEN YOU CALL OUT PLAYS
BEFORE THEY HAPPEN, WHEN YOU DO
ALL THOSE LITTLE THINGS, I DON'T
CARE WHAT YOUR 40 TIME IS
BECAUSE YOU ARE GOING TO BEAT
THE GUY TO THE SPOT BECAUSE YOU
KNOW WE IS GOING TO BE.
>> ALL RIGHT.
THE HOUSTON TEXANS ARE ON THE
CLOCK AND IF MY MIND IS CORRECT,
THIS WAS THE EAGLES' PICK
TRADED.
>> CORRECT.
>> SO THIS WAS ORIGINALLY THE
PICK THAT THE EAGLES GOT FROM
THE DOLPHINS FROM JALEN WADDLE.
HOUSTON ABLE TO TRADE BACK, PICK
UP A FEW PICKS.
EARLY ON THEY WENT DEREK
STINGLEY AT THREE.
I FEEL LIKE THIS IS ANOTHER
PLACE TO GET JERMAINE.
ARE WE A BROKEN RECORD OR DO YOU
THINK THEY GO -- WHERE DO YOU
GO?
YOU ARE THE EXPERT HERE.
>> IT'S A MATTER OF IF THEY WANT
TO SPREAD THE RESOURCES AROUND.
YOU ACCEPTED YOU ARE GOING INTO
NEXT SEASON WITH DAVIS MILLS AND
YOU HAVE AN EXTENSION WITH
BRANDON BIN COOKS, BUT WHAT SCA
YOU?
I LIKE TREYLON BURKS A LOT.
I HAVE NO PROBLEM TAKING TREYLON
BURKS.
IF YOU DON'T GET HIM NOW YOU
WILL BE IN BIG TROUBLE, AS THE
PICK SOUND GOES OFF IN MY EAR.
>> IT IS GOING TO BE OUR FIRST
INTERIOR --
>> GREEN.
KENYAN GREEN IS GOING TO THE
HOUSTON TEXANS.
>> HOUSTON TEXANS TRADE BACK
FROM 13 TO 15 AND THEY TAKE TWO
TIME CONSENSUS ALL-AMERICAN
KENYON GREEN.
HE IS 6'4", OVER 320, 35 STARTS,
17 AT LEFT GUARD, 15 AT RIGHT
GUARD, TWO AT RIGHT TACKLE, ONE
AT LEFT TACKLE, AND HE HAS NOT
MISSED A GAME IN THREE SEASONS.
GOING TO A TEAM THAT WAS LAST IN
RUSHING, 28th IN PASSING, AND
DOES NEED SOME HELP ALONG THAT
OFFENSIVE LINE.
BEFORE WE GET TO THE PLAYER, THE
VALUE, WHERE DID YOU HAVE
NIMRANKED ON THE BIG BOARD?
>> I DON'T LOVE IT.
HE IS MY 25th OVERALL PLAYER.
THIS ISN'T FROM MARS, RIGHT?
THIS ISN'T TAKING A PLAYER THAT
IS A THIRD ROUND PLAYER.
THE QUESTION HERE IS, GUYS, WHEN
I WATCH KENYON GREEN, I LOVE HIS
TAPE WHEN HE IS PLAYING GUARD.
I DON'T LOVE HIS TAPE WHEN HE IS
PLAYING TACKLE.
>> DID YOU JUST DRAFT A GUARD
THAT'S A GOOD PROSPECT --
>> HE IS NOT GOING UNSEAT LAREMY
TENSELE AT LEFT TACKLE.
QUESTIONS ABOUT HOWARD AT RIGHT
TACKLE.
>> THIS TEAM COULD NOT RUN THE
FOOTBALL LAST YEAR.
I LIKE KENYON GREEN.
A GOOD RUN BLOCKER.
A LOT OF POWER AS A DRIVE
BLOCKER.
HIS PASS PROTECTION WOES CAN BE,
YOU KNOW, ELIMINATED ON THE
INSIDE A LITTLE MORE.
I THINK SOMETIMES HE HAD SLOW
FEET AND HANDS.
SOMETIMES HE DIDN'T COVER ENOUGH
GROUND AT TACKLE THAT HE HAD NO
PROBLEMS AT GUARD BECAUSE HE HAS
THE ANCHOR STRENGTH AT GUARD.
COULD THEY JUST NOT GET FAR
ENOUGH BACK?
NOBODY WAS TAKING KENYON GREEN
IN THE TOP 20 PICKS, 23 PICKS.
MAYBE DALLAS IS WHERE IT
STARTED.
FOR THE TEXANS I WONDER THERE
WAS A LOT MORE VALUABLE PLAYERS
ON THE BOARD FOR A TEAM MISSING
BLUE CHIP TALENT RIGHT NOW.
IF YOU ARE FIXATED ON IMPROVING
THE INTERIOR OFFENSIVE LINE,
TAKE TYLER LINDERBAUM WHO IS A
BLUE CHIP TALENT, A TEN-YEAR
STARTER, PROBABLY A PRO BOWLER
EVERY YEAR.
THIS STINKS BECAUSE I LIKE
KENYON GREEN AS A PLAYER.
THIS FEELS OFF AND I DON'T KNOW
HOW MUCH BETTER THE TEXANS ARE
RIGHT NOW.
IT'S A C-PLUS.
IT'S LESS ABOUT KENYON GREEN BUT
THE HOUSTON TEXANS' PLAN THAT I
DON'T UNDERSTAND.
>> THIS IS ONE THAT IS KIND OF
THE MIND BLOWER.
YOU ARE THINKING WHAT -- IS THIS
THE GUY THEY NEEDED TO GET?
SO FOR ME, LISTEN, I LOVE TO
HEAR THIS EXPLAINED A LITTLE BIT
MORE.
I AM GOING TO GIVE IT A STRAIGHT
UP C.
>> I KNOW THAT SOME PEOPLE HAD
ZION JOHNSON LISTED AHEAD OF HIM
AT GUARD.
WHERE THEY PLAN TO PLAY HIM WILL
BE INTERESTING BECAUSE HE IS SO
VERSATILE.
OUR GUY JASON KELCE VERY
FOCUS ON THE PLAYER AND NOT
WHERE HE WAS DRAFTED.
WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT THIS GUY
WHEN YOU WATCH HIM?
>> YEAH, I MEAN, HE IS A VERY,
VERY GOOD GUARD.
I THINK HE WILL BE A VERY, VERY
GOOD GUARD.
SOMETIMES?
THE DRAFT I DON'T KNOW HOW THE
BIG BOARDS AND RANKING, YOU
KNOW, THE VALUE GOES.
BUT I THINK THIS KID'S GOING TO
BE A REALLY, REALLY GOOD PLAYER.
CAN HE PLAY TACKLE?
YOU KNOW, I THINK HE PROBABLY IS
GOING TO BE A VERY GOOD GUARD
AND HE CAN GET YOU OUT OF A GAME
TYPE OF TACKLE.
VERY PHYSICAL, POWERFUL,
PROBABLY THE BEST PEOPLE MOVER
AT THE GUARD POSITION YOU'LL
SEE.
HE'S A GUY THAT IS GOING TO
CHANGE THE LINE OF SCRIMMAGE,
KEEP IT FIRM INSIDE, GREAT USAGE
OF HIS HANDS.
HE IS A VERY POWERFUL GUY.
AND SO FAR THAT THE HOUSTON
TEXANS ARE GOING TO GET A GUY
THAT IS GOING TO CHANGE THE LINE
OF SCRIMMAGE AND BE A BIG
DIFFERENCE MAKER FOR THEIR
OFFENSIVE LINE.
>> AWESOME.
THANK YOU, MR. JASON KELCE.
IT ALSO MAKES SENSE FROM THE
PERSPECTIVE OF NICK KA SARRIO.
THE PATRIOTS LOVE BIG OFFENSIVE
LINEMAN.
THIS IS A BIG ONE.
THE RAVENS HAVE TRADED WIDE
RECEIVER HOLLYWOOD BROWN AND THE
100th PICK TO THE CARDINALS FOR
THE 23rd PICK.
I HAVE BEEN HEARING EVERYONE'S
BEING HEARING THE CARDINALS
WANTED ONE OF THESE WIDE
RECEIVERS TO GET OUT THERE.
A.J. GREEN, A LITTLE BIT OLDER.
DEONDRE H
DEONDRE HOPKINS WAS GETTING
BANGED UP.
HOLLYWOOD BROWN TO THE END OF
HIS ROOKIE CONTRACT.
FACING AN EXTENSION.
LET'S KEEP AN EYE ON LAMAR
JACKSON'S TWITTER ACCOUNT.
THIS IS ONE OF HIS BEST FRIENDS.
HOLLYWOOD BROWN A LITTLE BIT
BANGED UP.
WHEN HE PLAYS, HE IS GREAT.
WE HAVE ANOTHER PICK,
WASHINGTON, SPEAKING OF WIDE
RECEIVERS, GOING WITH MICHAEL
FELDER ONE OF YOUR FAVORITES,
JAHAN DOTSON OUT OF PATRIOT AT
PICK NUMBER 16.
GUYS, WHDO WE WANT TO GO?
WE ARE AHEAD OF THE BROADCAST.
A LITTLE BIT OF HOLLYWOOD OR DO
WE WANT TO MOVE ON TO JAHAN
DOTSON?
WHAT ARE WE THINKING?
WHAT'S YOUR FIRST REACTION WHEN
YOU HEAR HOLLYWOOD BROWN AND THE
CARDINALS?
>> FITS EVERYTHING CLIFF WANTS.
VERTICAL IS SPEED, BIG PLAYS.
I AM A LITTLE CONFUSED RIGHT
NOW.
WE WILL FIND OUT MORE WITH THAT
23rd OVERALL PICK.
WHAT ARE THE RAVENS DOING
OFFENSIVELY FOR LAMAR JACKSON?
>> JAHAN DOTSON IS GOING TO
WASHINGTON AT PICK NUMBER 16.
WASHINGTON WAS ABLE TO MOVE DOWN
IN THEIR DRAFT, MOVING TO 16,
AND GETTING JAHAN DOTSON OUT OF
PENN STATE.
I WANT TO GO TO FELDER FIRST
BECAUSE I KNOW YOU LOVE THIS
GUY.
I WANT TO SAVE IT.
BUT JAHAN DOTSON, 13 BIG TEN,
ONLY HAD TWO DROPS IN 138
TARGETS LAST YEAR.
AND HE WAS AVERAGING 24.5 YARDS
PUNT RETURN.
HE IS VERSATILE.
DID YOU EXPECT HIM TO GO IN THE
TOP 16, CONNOR?
>> NO.
BUT YOU HAVE TO BE AWARE OF THE
WIDE RECEIVER LINEUP.
29th OVERALL PLAYER, BUT THAT
DOESN'T -- IT DOESN'T MATTER,
RIGHT?
THEY ARE JUST GOING OFF THE
BOARD.
WE HAVE TREYLON BURKS THERE.
THIS IS A DIFFERENT KIND OF
PLAYER.
I THINK WHEN YOU LOOK AT IT WITH
JAHAN DOTSON RIGHT HERE YOU ARE
DRAFTING SPEED.
BUT HE IS MORE THAN THAT.
AND I KNOW FELDER IS GOING TO
TAKE IT AWAY LIKE A RUNWAY.
I DON'T WANT TO GIVE IT AWAY.
JAHAN DOTSON, HE PLAYS BIGGER
THAN HIS SIZE.
YOU SEE HIM GOING UP AND WINNING
THE FOOTBALL.
HE IS A PLAYMAKER.
HE GOT VERTICAL WHEELS.
HE IS NOT THE SHIPPIEST SMALLER
WIDE RECEIVER.
CAN YOU GET DOWN THE FIELD?
CAN YOU GET OPEN AND, OBVIOUSLY,
RUN AFTER THE CATCH?
THOSE ARE THINGS HE DOES REALLY,
REALLY WELL.
EXCELLENT HANDS.
THAT GOES BACK TO THE
CONCENTRATION AND TRACKING, TOE
TAPPING, BODY CONTROL.
WASHINGTON KNOWS THEY HAVE TO
PUT WEAPONS AROUND CARSON WENTZ.
NOW YOU HAVE JAHAN DOTSON.
IT'S A GOOD AMOUNT OF SPEED TO
COMPLIMENT McLAREN.
DOTSON IS A TOP 30 PLAYER.
THIS IS A LITTLE EARLY.
YOU DON'T GET HUNG UP ON THAT
BECAUSE IT HELPS THE QUARTERBACK
YOU TRADED FOR.
THIS IS A B FOR ME FOR
WASHINGTON.
>> THIS GUY SMELLS THE END ZONE.
THAT'S THE THING ABOUT THE CLIPS
WE WATCHED.
ANYTIME HE GETS THAT BALL INSIDE
THE TEN, INSIDE THE FIVE, HE IS
GOING TO MAKE ANOTHER GUY MISS
AND GE GET TO THE END ZONE.
LOVE HIS ABILITY DON TCONTORT H
BODY.
HE IS GOING TO BE THE GUY.
THE FACT THAT EVERYONE KNEW HE
WAS THE GUY AND HE STILL CAUGHT
THE FOOTBALL MEANS HE
UNDERSTANDS HOW TO GET OPEN.
FOR ME WITH JAHAN DOTSON I AM
GOING TO --
>> DO IT.
>> THIS IS ROUGH.
I AM GOING TO GIVE IT AN A.
I LIKE THIS PLAYER SO MUCH.
THIS IS LESS ABOUT WHERE HE IS
PICKED AND MORE ABOUT GENUINELY
BELIEVING THIS GUY IS AN AMAZING
WIDE RECEIVER.
I DON'T KNOW IF HE IS IN THE TOP
FIVE GROUP.
I THINK BURKS SHOULD COME OFF
THE BOARD BEFORE HIM.
WHEN YOU GET A GUY LIKE THIS
THAT STEPS IN AND BE AN EARNER,
I LOVE THAT ABILITY HE BRINGS TO
THE TABLE.
AND JUST WATCHING HIM PLAY, HE
KEPT DELIVERING EVEN WHEN TEAMS
KNEW WHAT WAS COMING.
>> OKAY.
SO WASHINGTON COMES BACK FROM 11
TO 16, TRADE WITH THE SAINTS.
THEY TAKE DOTSON.
AMON-RA ST. BROWN, WATCHING
DOTSON ON TAPE, WHAT STUCK OUT
Y
TO YOU?
>> I THINK HE'S A SURE RECEIVER.
I WASN'T -- IT PICK SURPRISED
ME.
I DIDN'T THINK HE WOULD GO THIS
HIGH.
WATCHING HIS TAPE, HE REMINDS ME
OF OLAVE.
SMOOTH RECEIVER.
GREAT HANDS.
CAN DO A LOT OF THINGS.
I THINK HIM WITH TERRY McLAURIN
WILL BE GOOD FOR CARSON WENTZ.
THOSE ARE TWO, YOU KNOW, PLAYERS
THAT CAN DO EVERYTHING, RUN THE
SHORT ROUTE, RUN THE DEEP ROUTE.
THEY ARE GOING TO CATCH
EVERYTHING.
WATCH TERRY MAKE THOSE CRAZY
GRABS.
THAT ONE CATCH HE HAD AGAINST
OHIO STATE, I BELIEVE.
YOU HAVE THOSE TWO GUYS ON THE
FIELD AT THE AIM, IT'S GOING TO
BE DANGEROUS.
I DIDN'T THINK HE WOULD GO THIS
EARLY, BUT I LIKE IT.
>> HE HAD 21 CAREER TOUCHDOWNS,
TEN OF THEM WERE 40 PLUS YARDS.
GETS THE BALL IN HIS HANDS AND
HE IS GOOD, GOOD, GOOD, GONE.
JAHAN DOTSON THE PICK FOR
WASHINGTON AT 16.
LET'S KEEP AMON-RA ON ONE MORE
TIME.
AMON-RA, YOUR REACTION TO
HOLLYWOOD BROWN GETTING TRADED
TO THE CARDINALS?
HOW DO YOU THINK THAT'S GOING
OVER IN THE RAVENS LOCKER ROOM
AND WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT HIM
WITH ARIZONA?
>> YEAH, LIKE YOU SAID, I THINK
LAMAR JACKSON ISN'T HAPPY ABOUT
THAT.
FOR ARIZONA, A GOOD MOVE.
THEY GOT RID OF CHRISTIAN KIRK,
SIGNED WITH THE JAGUARS.
THAT RECEIVER ROOM, A.J. GREEN
IS GETTING OLDER LIKE YOU SAID.
D HOP.
I THINK HOLLYWOOD BROWN WILL
TAKE THE TOP OFF THE DEFENSE.
PUT HIM IN THE SLOT, MOVE HIM
OUT WIDE, MOVE HIM AROUND.
I THINK FOR THE CARDINALS IT'S A
GOOD MOVE.
I AM NOT SO SURE ABOUT THE
RAVENS THOUGH SKBL.
>> THAT'S THE QUESTION.
WHERE ARE WE GOING?
>> THANK YOU, AMON-RA.
>> YOU NEVER WANT TO, YOU KNOW,
KILL A PLAN BEFORE YOU -- YOU
WANT TO SEE IT COMPLETELY
UNRAVELED.
FOR ME I HAVE BEEN SAYING
BALTIMORE FELT LIKE A SLEEPER
TEAM TO TAKE A WIDE RECEIVER IN
THE TOP 15.
LOOK AT THE AFC RIGHT NOW.
WHEN YOU THINK YOU GOT ENOUGH
WEAPONS, YOU TAKE TWO MORE.
SO I THOUGHT BALTIMORE MIGHT
FOLLOW THAT PLAYBOOK.
INSTEAD, THEY TRADED ONE OF
THEIR WEAPONS.
WHAT HAPPENS NOW?
AND A MAN PICK 23 FEELS LIKE A
MILE AWAY WHEN YOU ARE LOOKING
AT THE WIDE RECEIVER BOARD.
>> YOU GUII CAN'T BELIEVE WE
HAVEN'T DISCUSSED A THING THAT A
COLLEGE FOOTBALL ANALYST --
>> HOLD THE PICK.
FINISH YOUR POINT.
>> THIS IS WHO KYLER MURRAY --
THEY ARE THAT MATCH MADE IN
HEAVEN.
IT'S SIMILAR OFFENSE TO
OKLAHOMA.
THE GUY HE IS USED TO THROWING
THE FOOTBALL TO.
ALL THEY HAVE TO DO IS TRADE FOR
CEEDEE LAMB AND THEY'D HAVE THE
OFFENSE PUT BACK TOGETHER.
>> I WAS LIKE, ARE WE NOT GOING
TO TALK ABOUT THIS PART ABOUT
IT?
LOOK, LOOK, WLOOK WHAT HAPPENED
>> HOLLYWOOD IS LIKE, OH, NO,
OH, WAIT, THAT'S ALL MY GUYS.
THAT'S KYLER.
THAT'S CLIFF.
>> I GOT MY -- I'M GOOD.
I'M GONNA BE GOOD.
BUT CLIFF IS NOT LINCOLN RILEY.
BUT HE IS CLOSE ENOUGH.
>> YEAH.
17.
ANOTHER GUARD COMES OFF THE
BOARD.
CHARGERS TAKING BOSTON COLLEGE
GUARD ZION JOHNSON.
SO A MINI INTERIOR OFFENSIVE
LINEMAN RUN HAPPENING RIGHT NOW.
THE JUSTIN HERBERT ERA, YOU'VE
GOT TO PROTECT THE GUY.
THEY WENT OUT THERE AND THEY
INVESTED IN WIDE RECEIVERS AND
THEY MADE SURE THAT, YOU KNOW,
JUSTIN HERBERT GOT MIKE WILLIAMS
BACK.
6'3", 312, ZION JOHNSON, THE
NUMB ONE GUARD ON A NUMBER OF
PEOPLE'S BOARDS, 17, CONNOR, THE
VALUE OF ZION JOHNSON.
>> I LIKE THIS ONE A LITTLE
BETTER.
I KNOW THAT SOUNDS CRAZY WHEN
YOU LOOK AT IT.
FOR WHERE THE CHARGES CHARGERS
ARE AS A FRANCHISE COMPARED TO
THE TEXANS.
ZION IS 27th, TWO SPOTS BEHIND
KENYON GREEN.
THE CHARGERS NEEDED OFFENSIVE
LINE HELP.
ODD TRANSITION TO BE A LEFT
GUARD AND A LEFT TACKLE AND BACK
TO LEFT GUARD.
YOU DON'T SEE THAT A LOT IN
COLLEGE.
AT THE SENIOR BOWL HE TOOK SNAPS
AT CENTER.
HE IS GOING TO PLAY GUARD.
VERSATILE GUY.
INCREDIBLE GUY TO BRING INTO THE
LOCKER ROOM.
ONE OF THE BIGGEST HIGH FLOOR
PLAYERS IN THE DRAFT BECAUSE OF
THE TLIM, THE ABILITY TO MOVE
PEOPLE IN THE RUN GAME.
FOR ZION A BIG HELP FOR JUSTIN
HERBERT.
THE VALUE I WOULD HAVE BENT
TRENT McDUFFIE HERE.
THAT'S MY ONLY FWRIEP.
BUT IT'S A ROCK SOLID BEAT FOR
THE OFFENSIVE LINE.
>> YOU WERE JUST SAYING 58
STRAIGHT GAMES, DIDN'T MISS.
26 AT LEFT GUARD, 13 AT LEFT
TACKLE, TEN AT RIGHT TACKLE.
WHAT'S INTERESTING IS THEY HAD
MATT FILER DOWN THERE AT LEFT
GUARD.
THIS A GUY THAT HAS PLAYED WHEN
HE WAS WITH THE STEELERS TACKLE
AS WELL.
IN A WAY YOU GET TO MOVE HIM TO
TACKLE, KNOCK OUT NORTON AND NOW
YOU PUT IN ZION JOHNSON AND NOW
THE INTERIOR OFFENSIVE LINE IS
LOOKING GOOD FOR JUSTIN HERBERT.
>> I AM GOING TO GO B-PLUS.
FEELS A LITTLE EARLY, BUT THE
REALITY IS HE IS A REALLY GOOD
FOOTBALL PLAYER AND HE IS COMING
FROM -- WE TALK ABOUT IT WITH
IOWA.
BC -- AND WISCONSIN AS WELL.
BC'S GOT THEIR OWN OFFENSIVE
LINE LINEBACKER GOING TOO.
>> WORKING TOWARDS HIS MASTERS
IN CYBERSECURITY POLICY AND
GOVERNANCE.
LOOK AT THE BIG BRAIN ON ZION.
WHAT?
DON'T DO IT JET.
JASON KELCE, YOUR THOUGHTS ON
ZION JOHNSON, THE FACT THAT HE
IS GOING TO BE BLOCKING FOR
JUSTIN HERBERT.
WHAT DO YOU THINK OF THIS GUY?
>> YEAH, I MEAN, IT'S A GREAT
PICK.
THIS KID IS INCREDIBLY ATHLETIC,
FREAKY ATHLETIC, ZONE OR POWER
SCHEMES.
KIND OF A TWEENER FROM GUARD OR
CENTER.
I LIKED HIM AT CENTER.
WITH LINSLEY THERE, HE FITS IN
NICELY AT GUARD.
A SOLID PLAYER.
THEN YOU TOUCHED ON IT.
YOU CAN SEE HOW SMART HE IS.
HE GETS IT.
THE COACH LIKED HIM SO MUCH, HE
BROUGHT HIM WITH HIM TO BOSTON
COLLEGE FROM DAVIDSON.
YOU KNOW, THIS KID'S GOT A LOT
OF GREAT TRAITS THAT, YOU KNOW,
THEY ARE GOING TO LOVE HIM.
>> KELCE, STAY ON THE LINE WITH
ME BECAUSE THE EAGLES ARE UP AND
APPARENTLY THERE IS A TRADE AND
THEY ARE NOT TELLING ME WHAT IT
IS.
WE WILL FIND THIS OUT TOGETHER.
OH, MY GOD!
DO YOU SEE THAT.
>> WHAT?
>> DO YOU SEE THAT?
>> THEY TRADED FOR A.J. BROWN.
>> GET OUT OF THE WAY!
GET OUT OF THE WAY!
>> KELCE, SIT DOWN.
>> THIS IS BIG, LEFKOE!
THIS IS BIG.
>> THE EAGLES JUST TRADED THE
18th PICK AND A THIRD ROUND PICK
FOR ONE OF THE BEST YOUNG WIDE
RECEIVERS IN THE NFL.
A.J. BROWN.
JASON KELCE, WHAT IS GOING ON
RIGHT NOW?
WHAT IS GOING ON RIGHT NOW?
>> DUDE, HOWIE ROSEMAN IS
WORKING THAT MAGIC.
THAT'S WHAT'S GOING ON.
HE IS MOVING UP IN THE DRAFT TO
GET DAVIS DAYS AND NOW TRADING
TO GET UNBELIEVABLE EEFR.
IT'S LIKE CHRISTMAS RIGHT NOW.
>> REMEMBER AFTER THE SUPER BOWL
YOU WERE LIKE HOWIE ROSEMAN WAS
IN A HALLWAY CLOSET AND NOW HE
IS OUT HERE TRADING FOR A.J.
BROWN.
THEY KNEW, JASON, THEY SAID WE
NEED TO BRING JASON KELCE OUT OF
THE RETIREMENT.
YOU ARE NOT LEAVING.
WE ARE GOING TO PAY YOU 14
MILLION.
NOW THEY ARE GIVING YOU A.J.
BROWN, BRO.
>> A.J. BROWN!
>> YEAH, THIS IS HUGE.
THIS IS AN UPGRADE FOR THE
OFFENSE.
I CAN'T TELL YOU HOW MUCH THIS
IS GOING TO MAKE US BETTER.
HOWIE IS A MAN ON A MISSION NOW,
MAN.
HE IS MAKING THINGS HAPPEN.
AND I AM A BIG FAN.
HERE WE GO, BABY!
WOO!
HERE WE GO!
>> WOW.
THIS HAS TURNED INTO ONE OF THE
BEST NIGHTS OF MY LIFE.
>> INCREDIBLE VALUE, TOO.
YOU TRADE 18.
>> 18!
>> I'M SITTING HERE GOING MAYBE
THEY GO TREYLON BURKS.
I AM LIKE, MAN, MAYBE,
HOPEFULLY, ONE DAY HE COULD
BECOME HALF OF WHAT A.J. BROWN
IS.
>> YEP.
>> LET'S LOOK AT THE EAGLES ROOM
AND SEE WHAT THE EAGLES ROOM IS
SAYING RIGHT NOW.
YOU HAVE GOT TO BE S-ING ME.
LET'S F-ING GO.
REAL S, Y'ALL.
OFG.
HOWIE IS REDEEMING HIMSELF BIG
TIME THIS YEAR.
AHH!
AHHH!
A.J. BROWN?
WHAT?
>> YOU GUYS GOING TO WIN THE
SUPER BOWL THIS YEAR?
>> NO.
>> BUT YOU WILL ENJOY WATCHING.
>> THIS A GUY THAT YOU GO THE
DREAM IS TO TAKE SOMEBODY LIKE
THIS.
>> ALWAYS.
>> AND NOT ONLY THAT.
SO HE IS COMING UP ON A CONTRACT
EXTENSION.
HIM AND DeVONTA SMITH.
GUYS.
AM I BEING TOO MUCH?
>> NO.
I MEAN, THIS IS ELECTRIC.
THIS IS AN AWESOME TRADE.
I MEAN, BESIDES HERE IS THE
CRAZIEST THING.
GOOD FOR THEM.
>> YOU'VE GOT TO PAY HIM.
>> IT'S A.J. BROWN.
>> I AGREE.
HE IS SOMEBODY THAT YOU -- I AM
KIND OF CONFUSED HOW HE GOT HERE
WITH TENNESSEE.
I HATE TO BE THE GUY THAT LOOKS
AT IT FROM THE OTHER SIDE.
I MEAN, YOU JUST SAID IT LEFKOE.
IF EVERYTHING IS RIGHT WITH
TREYLON BURKS --
>> WE ARE TALKING ABOUT TWO OR
THREE YEARS.
>> YEAH.
AND THEN HE A A.J. BROWN.
THEY ARE SIMILAR PLAY STYLES.
FOR ME, EAGLES, I MEAN, A-PLUS,
PLUS, PLUS.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHAT THIS
TENNESSEE OFFENSE IS RIGHT NOW.
OBVIOUSLY, WE WILL GET SOME
ANSWERS HERE.
MAN, YOU ARE THE NUMBER ONE SEED
IN THE AFC.
WHAT ARE YOU NOW?
>> AND THEY ARE TAKING TREYLON
BURKS.
SO THEY SAID, OH, YOU WANT A NEW
CONTRACT EXTENSION BECAUSE
DAVANTE ADAMS AND TYREEK HILL
JUST CHANGED THE MARKET?
WE ARE GOING TO GO OUT AND TAKE,
HOPEFULLY, A YOUNGER VERSION
THAT WE CAN GET ON A FIVE-YEAR
DEAL AND THAT WE ARE NOT GOING
TO HAVE TO PAY.
AND HE IS A BIG DUDE.
6'2", 225, RAN A 4.55, 40.
TREYLON BURKS, MY FAVORITE WIDE
RECEIVER.
SET THE SCHOOL RECORD.
HE IS A WARRIOR IN THE WORKOUT
ROOM.
BE
BENCHES 380, SQUATS 500.
POWER CLEANS 320.
THEY HAD TO GIVE UP A.J. BROWN
TO GET IT.
FACTORING IN, WHAT TO WE THINK?
>> IT'S TOUGH BECAUSE YOU LOST A
GREAT PLAYER THAT YOU SHOULD
HAVE PAID.
YOU WANT TO TALK ABOUT TREYLON
BURKS.
THIS IS HIS MOMENT.
I DON'T WANT THAT TO GET LAST.
BURKS FOR ME, OBVIOUSLY, 14th
OVERALL PLAYER, HE IS AWESOME.
I AM SO TIRED OF HEARING HE IS
BIG SLOTTER.
HE IS ON THE OUTSIDE IN THE
S.E.C. MOSING QUARTERBACKS.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT WE ARE MISSING
THERE.
4.55, 230 POUNDS IS MUCH
DIFFERENT THAN 4.4 AT 380
POUNDS.
SIZE, SPEED, BUILD UP SPEED,
BREAKING TACKLES WITH THE BALL
IN YOUR HAND.
HE IS AN OLD-SCHOOL PLAYER FOR
ME.
I WROTE A BACKYARD BRAWLER
LOOKING TO OUTMUSCLE EVERYONE.
AND YOU CAN.
YOU CAN MOTION HIM OUT.
BACKFIELD AND THROW SHALLOW
CROSSER TOE HIM.
HE CAN WIN THE BALL VERTICALLY
KAZ WELL.
YOU LOSE A.J. BROWN.
I DON'T LIKE THIS TRADE AT ALL.
BUT THIS IS TREYLON BURKS
MOMENT.
I LOVE THE PLAYER.
A TOP 15 PLAYER FOR ME.
I AM VERY HIGH ON HIM.
I DO THINK THERE IS A PLACE
WHERE BURKS CAN BECOME AN A.J.
BROWN KIND OF PLAYER.
I FACTOR IN THE TRADE IN THE
GRADE.
LOVE THE PLAYER.
HATE TRADE.
IT'S A B TORE ME, RIGHT IN THE
MIDDLE.
>> HERE IS THE THING.
THIS GUY IS A FOOTBALL PLAYER
THAT PLAYS WIDE RECEIVER.
AND THAT MEANS A LOT TO ME.
>> YOU LOVE THAT.
>> HE IS A FOOTBALL PLAYER THAT
PLAYS WIDE RECEIVER.
HE DID ANYTHING AND EVERYTHING
THAT ARKANSAS ASKED HIM TO DO
AND I DON'T CARE ABOUT THE
TRADE.
THAT'S NOT MY JOB.
MY ONLY JOB, LISTEN, I DON'T
WORK IN THE NFL, BABY.
FOR ME BURKS IS UP THERE AS
SOMEONE WHO I FIND TO BE
REMARKABLY SPECIAL FOR WHAT
HE -- I AM GOING TO START
CRYING.
I LOVE THIS GUY.
HE IS SO GOOD FOR REAL.
LIKE HE IS -- HE MEANS A LOT TO
ME TO WATCH HIM PLAY.
I WAS DOING RADIO IN ARKANSAS AI
GOT TERRY EYED TALKING ABOUT
WHAT HE MEANS TO THAT PROGRAM.
AN A HERE.
YOU ARE GETTING A GUY WE THOUGHT
WOULD PROBABLY COME OFF THE
BOARD IN THE TOP 15 AND YOU ARE
GETTING HIM -- YOU HAD TO GIVE
UP SOMEBODY, BUT GETTING HIM AT
18 AND SOMEONE WHO IS GOING TO
BRING -- WE TOUNT TALK ABOUT
WIDE RECEIVERS AS TONE SETTERS
IN THE LOCKER ROOM.
HE WILL MAKE EVERYBODY AROUND
HIM WANT TO PLAY HARDER.
>> LAST YEAR 22 PLAYS OF 20 OR
MORE YARDS.
HE IS EXPLOSIVE.
>> HE RAN AWAY FROM ALABAMA.
>> WHICH IS A HARD TO DO.
AMON-RA ST. BROWN, LET'S BRING
HIM IN HERE.
THIS IS NOT YOUR KIND OF WIDE
RECEIVER.
WHAT DO YOU THINK WHEN YOU WATCH
THIS DUDE ON TAPE?
WERE YOU JUST SHOCKED AT HOW BIG
AND FAST HE WAS?
>> YEAH.
I MEAN, HE IS A BIG BODY.
IRONIC THAT THAT TRADE, ALMOST
SEEMS LIKE THEY ARE TRYING TO
GET THE SAME PLAYER WITH TREYLON
BURKS.
WATCHING HIS TAPE, REMINDS ME OF
A.J. BROWN, A LITTLE DEEBO IN
HIM.
HE RUNS A 4.5.
THAT SIZE AND SPEED COMBINATION
IS INSANE.
HE HAS THAT DEEBOESQUE TO ME.
HE IS BREAKING TACKLES.
AND ONCE HE IS GONE, NO ONE'S
CATCHING HIM.
SO LOVE THE PICK.
I DON'T KNOW ABOUT THE TRADE.
BUT I LOVE THE PICK.
I THINK HE IS GOING TO DO GREAT
IN THE LEAGUE, CAN PLAY INSIDE,
OUTSIDE, THROW HIM A BALL,
SCREEN, REVERSE, GET THE BALL IN
HIS HANDS, HE IS GOING TO MAKE A
PLAY.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH, AMON-RA
ST. BROWN.
INDEED, IT IS THE TITANS WHO
TAKE TREYLON BURKS AND HE DOES
FIT THE STYLE OF HOW THEY LIKE
THEIR PLAYERS.
ALSO THEY WENT OUT THERE THIS
OFFSEASON, THEY GOT ROBERT
WOODS.
IT'S A NICE COMPLIMENT TO
TREYLON BURKS OUT THERE IN THE
ALL WHITE.
I WANT TO EMPHASIZE SOMETHING
THAT CONNOR JUST SAID.
LET US NOT HOLD THE WEIGHT OF
THIS TRADE OVER THIS KID RIGHT
AWAY.
>> NOT FAIR.
>> WHAT WILL HAPPEN,
UNFORTUNATELY, FOR THE NEXT FEW
YEARS IS HE WILL BE COMPARED TO
A.J. BROWN.
IT'S GOING TO BE TOUGH FOR HIM.
>> HE IS BUILT FOR IT.
>> THIS IS A DUDE THAT HAD
BIG-TIME OFFERS AND STAYED HOME
AND WENT TO A RAZORBACKS PROGRAM
THAT WAS IN THE DUMPSTER.
WHEN HE WALKED OUT OF THERE THEY
LOOK A LOT BETTER.
>> GOOD LUCK, TREYLON BURKS.
>> ALL RIGHT.
ARE YOU LOVING THIS DRAFT
COVERAGE IN THE PALM OF YOUR
HAND?
THAT'S YOUR CELLPHONE.
OUR SHOW IS SPONSORED BY ROCKET
MORTGAGE.
THEY HAVE ALSO MADE IT POSSIBLE
FOR YOU TO GET A HOME LOAN RIGHT
HERE ON YOUR PHONE.
WITH A PROCESS BUILT AROUND YOUR
NEEDS.
WHEN YOU NEED A HOME LOAN THAT
FITS YOU, ROCKET CAN.
JUST LIKE THE EAGLES CAN,
COMPLETELY CHANGE THE ENTIRE
FORTUNES OF THEIR FRANCHISE IN
ONE DAY, TRADING FOR JORDAN
DAVIS AND THEN ALSO FINDING A
WAY TO GET A.J. FREAKING BROWN.
SPEAKING OF, OH!
TAND WE'RE GOING TO PAY YOU
RIGHT AWAY.
FOUR YEARS, O157 MILLION
GUARANTEED.
WE DON'T HAVE TO WORRY IF YOU
ARE GOING TO GET THAT CHECK
BECAUSE THE EAGLES GOT THE
GREEN, THE EAGLES GOT THE GREEN.
WHAT CAN BROWN DO FOR YOU?
HOPEFULLY, WIN YOU A SUPER BOWL.
THE EAGLES JUST GOT THE BIGGEST,
BADDEST DEFENSIVE LINEMAN IN
A.J. BROWN.
I'M GOOD.
I'M REAL GOOD.
I'M JUST -- WE GOT -- OH.
HE IS PAID NOW.
>> THAT DISCUSSION DOESN'T
EXIST.
>> CAN I TAKE IT A STEP FURTHER?
>> GO FOR IT.
>> HE HAS THE SAME
REPRESENTATION AS D.K. METCALF
AND DEEBO.
IT'S PAY TIME.
HERE IS THE LINE.
>> AND D.K. METCALF, BETTER
NUMBERS.
AND DEEBO'S GOING, I DO MORE
THAN HIM.
>> WOW.
>> SO --
>> GET READY.
I DON'T THINK WE ARE DONE HERE.
>> YOU KNOW, WHAT'S SO
INCREDIBLE, AND I KNOW WE ARE
GOING TO HAVE TO GET READY TO
START DOING THE SAINTS' SECOND
PICK, BUT I JUST WANT TO SAY
THAT I THOUGHT WE WERE GOING TO
HAVE TO FIND A YOUNG GUY AND IT
WAS GOING TO GO JALEN HURTS IS
GOING TO HAVE TO PROVE IT,
DRAFTING FOR THE NEXT GUY.
A.J. BROWN --
>> CAN ERASE A LOT OF --
>> I THINK OF HIM OUT OF OLE
MISS COMPARED TO THESE WIDE
RECEIVERS AND I WOULD HAVE TAKEN
A.J. BROWN OVER THESE WIDE
RECEIVERS.
>> ALL OF THE ONES IN THE DRAFT?
>> I AM SO BIASED NOW.
YOU KNOW WHAT HE IS.
A.J. BROWN IS A SECOND ROUND
PICK.
WE LIKED HIM.
>> OKAY.
>> ALL RIGHT.
I HAVE DONE ENOUGH TALKING.
>> YOU'RE DOING GREAT.
>> I WAS LIKE, WAIT, WHAT?
>> I LICK THE LEFKOE RIDING HIGH
NOW.
I HAVE BEEN PART OF THE DARREN
BARNETT --
>> LAST YEAR DeVONTA SMITH AND
NOW THIS.
OKAY.
NEW ORLEANS SAINTS ON THE CLOCK.
THEY WERE AT 11.
THEY TRADED UP TO 11 TO TAKE
CHRIS OLAVE.
THEY ANSWERED THAT.
WHAT ARE THEY DOING NOW?
TREVOR PENNING.
THEY DO GET A WORRIED THEY WOULE
HIM AT LEP.
THEY TAKE HIM AT 19.
>> I WAS CAUTIOUS, BUT EXPECTED
THIS TO BE THE SECOND --
>> NORTHERN IOWA'S TREVOR PENG,
33 STARTS, 31 AT LEFT TACKLE,
WHICH IS LIKELY WHERE HE IS
GOING TO SLIDE RIGHT IN TO
REPLACE THE ONE AND ONLY TERRON
ARMSTEAD, WHO WENT DOWN TO
MIAMI.
VALUE FIRST.
I GET THE SENSE YOU DIDN'T HAVE
HIM GOING IN THE TOP 20.
>> HE IS MY 47th OVERALL PLAYER.
AND I KNEW HE WAS GOING IN THE
FIRST ROUND.
THIS ISN'T A SURPRISE FOR ME.
I HAVE QUESTIONS HERE WHEN YOU
LOOK AT TREVOR PENG.
FELDER LIKES TO SAY YOU ARE
GRADUATING TWO LEVELS.
YOU ARE COMING OUT OF THE FCS.
HE IS A DYNAMIC ATHLETE FOR THE
POSITION.
YOU TURN ON THE ALL 22 IN THE
FCS TAPE AND HE IS ON THE GROUND
A LOT.
AND I WATCHED HIM WITH ANOTHER
OFFENSIVE LINE COACH IN THE NFL
AND IT'S A CONSTANT THROWING THE
PUNCH WHILE YOUR FEET ARE
LEAVING THE GROUND.
THAT'S HOW YOU END UP ON THE
GROUND.
IF THAT HAPPENS IN THE FCS, IT
IS GOING TO BE A RUDE AWAKENING
AT THE NFL LEVEL I LIKE PENG E
PENNING'S ATHLETICISM.
PENALTIES ARE AN ISSUE.
PASS PROTECTION NEEDS
REFINEMENT.
HE IS NOT A TYLER SMITH.
HE IS GOING TO BE 23 YEARS OLD
ON DRAFT DAY.
HE IS NOT OLD, BUT JUST SAYING
HE PLAYED A LOT OF COLLEGE
FOOTBALL.
HE HAS GOTTEN A LOT BETTER FROM
THEIR SPRING SEASON ALL THE WAY
TO THE LAST FALL SEASON.
BUT THIS IS A PROJECT TACKLE TO
ME.
FOR SOME REASON THE NFL VIEWS
HIM AS A SUREFIRE ANSWER TO
START FROM DAY ONE.
I DON'T AGREE.
I DON'T THINK IT'S HFAIR FOR HI
DEVELOPMENT.
NOT GOOD FOR THE QUARTERBACK
SITUATION THERE.
IT'S A C FOR ME.
>> HE BROKE THE SCHOOL SQUAT
RECORD, 625, AND ALL THE
OFFENSIVE LINEMEN AT THE COMBINE
FASTEST 10EN AND 20-YARD SPLITS.
>> GREAT ATHLETE.
>> ATHLETICISM.
HE SEEMS LIKE A GRABBER.
AND I GUESS --
>> GRABBER?
>> YES.
>> HE SEEMS LIKE A GRABBER,
RIGHT?
WHEN YOU ARE THE BIGGEST AND
STRONGEST GUY AND YOU HAVE THE
ABILITY TO KIND OF GET A TILE
GRAB AND THROW, THAT'S ONE
THING.
LISTEN, I GIVE IT A B-MINUS.
I AM CURIOUS TO HEAR WHAT KELCE
THINGS.
OBVIOUSLY, HE IS OUR EXPERT.
>> YES.
YEAH.
JASON, WE ARE TALKING ABOUT
GRABBING, WE ARE TALKING ABOUT
TECHNIQUE AND ATHLETICISM.
YOU LOOK AT THE FILM OF THIS
KID.
WHAT DO YOU SEE?
>> THE SAME THING CONNOR AND
MICHAEL JUST SAID.
THIS KID HAS ALL THE TOOLS.
HE'S PHYSICAL.
HE'S BIG.
BUT HE IS VERY UNREFINED.
YOU KNOW, HE IS A BIG THROWER.
HE IS A BIG GRABBER.
HE IS A BIG, YOU KNOW, LIKE
BLOCK AROUND GUYS.
AND HE HAS THE TOOLS TO NOT DO
THAT.
THAT'S WHAT'S FRUSTRATING I CAN
BE REALLY GOOD AND IT'S EVIDENT.
HE TURNS A LOT IN PASS PRO,
WHICH WORRIES ME.
YOU KNOW, USUALLY THAT HAPPENS
WITH UNATHLETIC GUYS THAT CAN'T
GET OFF THE BALL.
THEY CAN'T KEEP GUYS IN FRONT OF
THEM, SO THEY HAVE TO TURN.
THIS DUDE'S A FREAK.
SO MAYBE IT'S JUST THE WAY THEY
COACH GUYS DOWN THERE.
MAYBE IF HE GETS THE RIGHT COACH
ON HIM HE CAN STOP DOING STUFF
LIKE THAT, WHICH LOOKS GOOD ON
TAPE BUT ULTIMATELILY LEADS TO
HOLDING CALLS AND,
UNFORTUNATELY, YOU KNOW, SOME
NEGATIVE PLAYS CAN HAPPEN.
>> WE WILL SEE IF THEY CAN
DEVELOP HIM DOWN THERE IN NEW
ORLEANS.
JASON, HAVE YOU SPENT ANY MORE
TIME THINKING ABOUT YOUR NEW
TEAM IN A.J. BROWN?
I MEAN, THIS IS INSANE.
>> MY PHONE IS BLOWING UP.
I AM LIKE HAVING TROUBLE STAYING
ON TRACK RIGHT NOW BECAUSE I'M
JUST ANSWERING TEXTS NON-STOP.
>> HAVE YOU GOTTEN ANY TEXTS
FROM LIKE TEAMMATES?
THE STATE OF THE EAGLES RIGHT
NOW, ARE YOU --
>> TEAMMATES, FAMILY, FRIENDS,
EVERYBODY.
EVERYBODY IS SHOCKED THAT THIS
HAPPENED.
I'M TELLING YOU, MAN, HOWIE, HE
IS ALWAYS READY TO MAKE
SOMETHING HAPPEN.
I MEAN, JUST GOT ONE OF THE BEST
DEEP BALL RECEIVERS IN THE NFL.
>> GIVE HIM A KISS ON THE
FOREHEAD THE NEXT TIME YOU SEE
HIM.
>> MY BROTHER JUST TEXTED ME.
HE SAID YOU GOT THE BIGGEST --
IN THE NFL.
I'M FEELING GOOD ABOUT THIS
MOVE.
>> AMAZING.
>> ALL RIGHT, BROTHER.
I'LL LET YOU ANSWER YOUR TEXTS.
STEELERS UP AT 20.
I AM LOOKING AT THE BIG BOARD
RIGHT NOW.
>> WELL, THE ELEPHANT IN THE
ROOM.
>> THE ELEPHANT IN THE ROOM IS
JERMAINE JOHNSON.
>> NO.
THEY HAVE MALIK WILLIS.
THEY LOVED HIM SINCE THE SENIOR
BOWL.
A LITTLE BUZZ ABOUT KEN KENNY
A LITTLE BUZZ ABOUT KEN
PICKETT.
>> I SAID, LINDERBAUM I THOUGHT
WOULD GO IN ROUND TWO.
JERMAINE JOHNSON I AM CAUGHT OFF
GUARD BY THIS.
BUT I AM FASCINATED BY THE
STEELERS RIGHT NOW.
>> DO YOU THINK THEY GO MALIK?
>> I DO.
I THINK THEY NEVER WANTED TO PAY
ASSETS TO GO UP FOR A
QUARTERBACK IN THIS CLASS.
YOU SIT THERE AT 20 AND GO,
COOL.
HERE WE GO.
KENNY PICKETT.
>> THE QUARTERBACK.
>> KENNY PICKETT.
SO PRACTICELY WORKING OUT IN THE
STEELERS FACILITY, BUT NOT THE
QUARTERBACK WE THOUGHT IT WOULD
BE.
THE PITT QUARTERBACK IS STAYING
IN PITTSBURGH.
KENNY PICKETT WILL NOW BE THE
NEW FACE OF THE PITTSBURGH
STEELERS.
A 42-7 TOUCHDOWN TO INTERCEPTION
RATIO AND YOU ARE GOING TO ARE
HAVE TO GET YOUR HANDS ON THIS.
KENNY
KENNY'S MIGHT BE TOO SMALL.
8 1/2 INCHES.
SORRY, BUT PITTSBURGH STEELERS
GO WITH KENNY PICKETT.
WHERE DID YOU HAVE HIM RANKED?
ARE YOU SURPRISED THIS IS THE
QUARTERBACK THEY GO WITH?
>> A LOT OF BUZZ ABOUT BOTH.
THERE WAS A LOT OF BUZZ ABOUT
KENNY PICKETT.
DIDN'T WANT TO GET ONE, WHICH
THEY KNEW HOW THE BOARD WAS
GOING TO PLAY.
THEY HAVE A LOT OF SMART
FOOTBALL PEOPLE LIKE BRANDON
HUNT IN THAT BUILDING AS WELL.
I LOOK AT IT LIKE THIS.
IS THIS A GOOD QUARTERBACK
SCLAS?
ABSOLUTELY NOT.
IS PICKETT A HIGH FLOOR PLAYER?
AT THE BEST HE IS A DEREK CARR
PLAYER WHICH IS GOOD IF THAT'S
WHAT YOU COME AWAY WITH.
24-YEAR-OLD ROOKIE, PLAYED A LOT
OF COLLEGE BALL AT PITT.
HE THROWS WITH ANTICIPATION.
THINK HE DOES A GOOD JOB THROUGH
THE READS.
HE HAS ENOUGH ATHLETICISM TO
PLAY IN THIS MODERN DAY NFL AND
HE GOES INTO A SITUATION WHERE A
LOT OF PEOPLE THOUGHT HE WOULD
BE THE GUY DRAFTED FOR THE
START.
HE IS GOING INTO A SITUATION
WHERE THEY WILL ROLL WITH
MITCHELL TRUBISKY UNLESS WE SEE
A KENNY PICKETT/MAC JONES.
SO I LOVE THE LANDING SPOT FOR
PICKETT.
THE VALUE, THEY SAT AT 20.
HE IS 32nd ON MY BOARD.
DO I THINK KENNY PICKETT WILL BE
A SUPERSTAR?
THE AFC LIKE MAHOMES, JOSH
ALLEN, NO IT'S INFRASTRUCTURE
FOR QUARTERBACKS TO DEVELOP AND
THRIVE.
THIS IS BRIAN ASAMOAH FOR ME.
I LIKE THEY DIDN'T GIVE UP
FUTURE ASSETS TO GET HIM AND HE
CAN BE A LONG-TERM STARTER.
>> THIS IS A NEW PHASE AFTER THE
BIG BEN ERA.
>> IT FEELS SAFE AND, OBVIOUSLY,
THE STEELERS TEND TO LIKE SAFE.
HE IS A REALLY GOOD FOOTBALL
PLAYER.
I THINK HE IS SUPER ATHLETIC.
THERE WAS A TIME WHEN HE WAS
RUNNING BACK AND FORTH TO THE
SIDELINE TO GET PLAYS LIKE
OLD-SCHOOL HIGH SCHOOL FOOTBALL
STYLE AND WATCHING HIM DEVELOP
OVER HIS JUNIOR YEAR IN HIGH
SCHOOL THROUGH HIS SENIOR YEAR
OF COLLEGE, EVERY SINGLE YEAR
EVERY STEP.
WAY HE HAS GOTTEN BETTER.
WHEN I SAW HIM IN 2016 IN D.C. I
THOUGHT HE WOULD BE GOOD AT
TEMPLE AND THEN HE GETS THE
PITT, GETS BETTER, ENDS UP AT
PITT PLAYING REALLY WELL.
YOU THROW IN MARK WHIPPLE.
HE IS AN NFL OFFENSIVE
COORDINATOR.
HE COMES IN READY TO COMPETE.
WILLING TO COMPETE.
THE HANDS THING IS SOMETHING
THAT PEOPLE BRING UP.
HIS INTERCEPTIONS -- EXCUSE ME,
FUMBLE RATE IS BELOW THE AVERAGE
FUMBLE RATE FOR QUARTERBACKS.
>> EVEN THOUGH HE HAS 38 CAREER
FUMBLES?
THE RATE IS LOW.
>> THE SENIOR YEAR RATE IS
LOWER, BUT THAT'S THE THING.
EARLIER IN HIS CAREER, EARLIER
IN HIS CAREER, MORE OF A PROBLEM
THAN LATER IN HIS CAREER, WHICH
GOES BACK TO WHAT I SAID.
HE IMPROVED EVERY SINGLE STEP OF
THE WAY AND COMING FROM AN NFL
OFFENSE THIS HELPS.
FOR ME, THE BIG THING THAT
CONNOR BROUGHT UP WAS THAT HE
DOESN'T HAVE TO PLAY RIGHT NOW.
IF HE DOESN'T HAVE TO PLAY RIGHT
NOW, WHY DON'T YOU GET THE GUY
THAT'S GOING TO BE BETTER.
I AM GOING WITH C PLUS.
>> WHO WOULD YOU HAVE GONE HERE?
>> MALIK WILLIS.
IF YOU DON'T HAVE TO PLAY NOW --
>> HIGHER CEILING.
>> GO WITH THE GUY I CAN TEACH
TO BE BETTER.
>> IT IS INTERESTING.
THIS MAN PASSED DAN MARINO STATS
AT PITT.
THE PITTSBURGH STEELERS HAD A
CHANCE TO TAKE MARINO AND THEY
DIDN'T DO IT.
ALL THE HIGHLIGHTS ON THE SAME
FOOTBALL FIELD.
THERE IS SOMETHING ABOUT
FAMILIARITY AND HAVING ALL THAT
AROUND THERE.
THE NEW FACE OF THE PITTSBURGH
STEELERS WAS THE FACE OF
PITTSBURGH IN COLLEGE.
PRETTY COOL.
KENNY PICKETT'S THE GUY.
ARE YOU GUYS SHOCKED NOW?
>> NO, I HAD HIM AS THE FIRST
QUARTERBACK OFF THE BOARD.
I --
>> YOU HEAR ABOUT THAT?
>> I DON'T BET.
>> I HEARD THAT -- I HEARD LATE
THAT THIS PICKED UP STEAM.
YOU GET SUCKED IN, RIGHT, AT THE
SENIOR BOWL, YOU SEE MIKE TOMLIN
TALKING TO THE FAMILY, MALIK
WILLIS AND YOU BECOME BIASED.
OH, I SAW THAT.
I THINK NOT SHOCKED.
WE KNEW THEY WERE IN ON
QUARTERBACKS AND I THOUGHT
PICKETT WOULD BE THE FIRST OFF
THE BOARD.
I THOUGHT IT WOULD BE EARLIER.
>> SO IT WILL BE A NAJEE HARRIS
TEAM, CHASE CLAYPOOL, GOOD
POSSESSION GUY.
THEY WENT OUT AND INVESTED IN
THE OFFENSIVE LINE THIS
OFFSEASON, WHICH MADE ME
EXCITED.
MISSING COLE AT CENTER AND JAMES
DANIELS FROM CHICAGO WHO WE
LIKED OUT OF IOWA.
MAYBE IT WASN'T AS GREAT WITH
THE BEARS, BUT IS IT ALSO THE
KIND OF GUY THAT MATT CANADA --
BECAUSE HE IS MOBILE ENOUGH.
WE SAW IT IN THE BOWL GAME, THAT
MOVE.
HE'S GOT WHEELS.
>> YOU CAN GET HIM OUTSIDE THE
POCKET AND CUT THE FEIELD IN
HALF.
YOU ARE SIMPLIFYING THINGS,
CREATING LEVELS ON THE FOOTBALL
FIELD.
HE DOES A GOOD JOB ONE, TWO,
THREE, AND GETTING THE BALL OUT.
THAT'S WHAT KENNY PICKETT CAN
DO.
IT'S BACK TO WHAT FELDER SAID
AND WHAT I BELIEVE IN THE LEAGUE
RIGHT NOW, SPECIAL PLAYERS ARE
GOING DEEP INTO THE PLAYOFFS.
AND YOU HAVE TO BUILD, YOU KNOW,
CAN YOU RELATIPLICATE WHAT THE
NINERS DID?
JIMMY WASN'T DRIVING THE TRUCK,
HE WAS ALONG FOR THE RIDE.
THAT ROSTER WAS ESPECIALLY.
>> 21 PATRIOTS PICK IS IN.
MY GUESS BEFORE WE SHOW IT.
I WANT TO GUESS.
MY GUESS IS GOING TO BE TRENT
McDUFFIE BECAUSE THEY HAVE SOME
HOLES AT CORNERBACK.
>> DEVIN LLOYD.
HE FITS THE LINEBACKER PROFILE.
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> GOING WITH MY HEART.
>> WHAT'S YOUR HEART?
>> NAKOBE DEAN.
>> LISTEN, MAN, WHEN THE
PATRIOTS GET A LINEBACKER YOU
ARE LIKE HE IS GOING TO BE GOOD.
THE PICK IS IN.
AND THE PICK IS, WOW --
>> NICE, LEFKOE.
>> ALL RIGHT.
>> WELL DONE.
>> TRENT McDUFFIE.
THEY LOST J.C. JACKSON.
THEY ADDED BUTLER.
THEY ADDED MITCHELL.
THEY TWO OUT, THE PATRIOTS DO,
AND GET THE CORNER FROM
WASHINGTON THAT A LOT OF PEOPLE
THOUGHT COULD GO IN THE TOP TEN.
TRENT McDUFFIE, FIRST-TEAM
ALL-PAC-12, A TRACK STAR IN HIGH
SCHOOL FROM 100 METERS TO THE
4x100 AND HAS RETURNABILITY,
WHICH YOU KNOW BELICHICK LOVES.
TRENT McDUFFIE PICK NUMBER 21.
WHERE IS YOU EXPECT HIM TO GO?
>> I EXPECTED EARLIER THAN THIS.
I THOUGHT HE WOULD BE A TOP 17
PICK BECAUSE OF THE CHARGERS.
THIS FITS LIKE A GLOVE.
>> LIKE A GLOVE?
>> THE TYPE OF GUY BELICHICK
LIKES.
I STOOD IN FRONT OF THE HIS
PODIUM AT THE COMBINIE.
I THINK HE IS THE SMARTEST
PLAYER IN THE ENTIRE NFL DRAFT.
HE LIVES -- ALL HE DOES IS --
>> A TEAM CAPTAIN?
>> YEAH, HE WAS A TEAM CAPTAIN,
LEADER THE DEFENSIVE BACK ROOM.
>> WHAT?
>> DO WE THINK --
>> PREMATURE.
THE PATS TRADED OUT.
YOU SICKOS!
>> THEY PULLED THEI RUG OUT.
>> EVERYTHING WAS GOING SO
SMOOTH.
THEY TRADED OUT.
OKAY.
FALSE ALARM.
THE PATRIOTS HAVE TRADED TO THE
CHIEFS.
OKAY.
SO ALL OF THAT, WOW.
LET ME ERASE.
>> THE PICK MIGHT STILL BE
McDUFFIE.
THEY NEED A CORNER.
>> THE CHIEFS DO NEED A CORNER.
AT THE SAME POINT, THEY COULD BE
GOING FOR THE FALLING KNIFE,
WHICH IS JERMAINE JOHNSON,
BECAUSE THEY NEED A PASS-RUSHER
OUTSIDE OF FRANK CLARK.
THEY ALSO NEEDED A WIDE
RECEIVER.
ARE THERE ANY WIDE RECEIVERS
THAT YOU TRADE UP FOR HERE?
MAYBE A SKYY MOORE.
MAYBE A PICKENS.
I DON'T THINK YOU NEED TO TRADE
UP FOR THAT THOUGH.
>> THAT WOULD BE SOMETHING.
>> THEY DON'T NEED A LINEBACKER.
BUT, YEAH, JERMAINE JOHNSON OR
TRENT McDUFFIE WOULD BE MAYBE
THE PICK THERE.
I DOUBT YOU TRADE UP FOR A
KARLAFTIS.
>> NO, I DON'T THINK HE IS GOING
TO -- THIS IS A LITTLE --
>> WHAT'S YOUR PICK?
>> GUESS.
>> I THINK McDUFFIE.
I THINK THE VALUE IS THERE.
>> MAYBE THEY SAW McDUFFIE'S
NAME BEING ETCHED ON THE JERSEY,
THOUGHT IT WAS PATRIOT -- OR SAW
IT IN THE SYSTEM.
>> THE SYSTEM.
>> THE CHEEFTS.
>> YEAH, THAT MAKES SENSE, TOO.
THAT'S HOW YOU GET PLAYED.
YOU GUESS --
>> DON'T KNOW WHICH TEAM IT IS.
>> YEAH, YOU GUESS.
THE PEOPLE THAT LEAK THE PICKS,
OBVIOUSLY, HAVE THE NFL'S FAX
SYSTEM.
THEY GET THE PICKS FAXED BECAUSE
WE LIVE IN 1948 OR WHATEVER IN
THE NFL.
THAT COULD HAVE HAPPENED AS
WELL.
>> WE WILL WAIT TO SEE THE
DETAILS OF WHICH KANSAS CITY
PICK THEY TRADED, WHETHER IT WAS
29 OR 30.
I HAVE A HARD TIME THINKING THAT
THEY WOULD TRADE 29 AND LET THE
PATRIOTS BE AHEAD OF THEM.
BUT WE'LL SEE WHAT THE DEAL IS.
>> THAT'S, YEAH.
I DIDN'T THINK ABOUT THAT.
YEAH, THEY DO HAVE BACK TO BACK
--
>> KANSAS CITY IS INSTEAD --
MAN, YEAH.
SO WE'RE ALL THINKING IT'S
McDUFFIE.
IF IT IS, DO YOU LIKE THAT PICK?
>> OH, YEAH.
I WOULD LOVE IT.
HE WAS MY, F CB 2 IN THE DRAFT.
15th OVERALL.
>> THEY DID IT.
>> THEY GIAVE UP 29.
INTERESTING.
SO THEY GIVAVE UP 29.
THE PATRIOTS HAVE THE PICK IN
FRONT OF KANSAS CITY.
THEY SHARE A FEW NEEDS.
I AM SURE BELICHICK WEIGHED ALL
OF THAT IN WHEN HE MADE THIS
TRADE.
SO WE ARE STILL WAITING TO SEE
WHAT IT IS.
>> IT'S McDUFFIE.
>> IT IS?
>> YEAH.
LET'S TO THE VIDEO.
>> THERE WE GO.
>> KANSAS CITY, THEY MAKE THE
SELECTION WITH A TRADE TO GET UP
TO 21 WITH THE NEW ENGLAND
PATRIOTS.
WE KNEW THAT THEY HAD A LEAD --
A NEED AT CORNERBACK AND IT IS
GOING TO BE TRENT McDUFFIE.
THEY LOST THEIR BEST CORNERBACK
THIS OFFSEASON IN TREVARIUS WARD
TO THE SAN FRANCISCO 49ers.
SIGNED A CONTRACT OVER
$40 MILLION.
AND THE CHIEFS LIKE TO PLAY
SPAGNUOLO DOES FOUR CORNERBACK
SCHEMES.
SO IT IS GOING TO BE TRENT
McDUFFIE, THE PICK FOR THE
CHIEFS HERE AT 21.
BRETT VEACH MAKING A MOVIE WITH
BILL BELICHICK TO GET THIS DONE.
A CORNERBACK THAT HAS A LOT OF
SPEED AND A LOT OF VERSATILITY.
WHAT DO YOU THINK OF THE CHIEFS
TAKING McDUFFIE HERE?
>> I LOVE IT.
YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT A
CONTENDER GETTING ONE OF THE
BEST PLAYERS.
15th OVERALL FOR ME.
A BLEND OF A PLAYER.
REMINDS ME OF LOGAN RYAN, JAIRE
ALEXANDER.
HE WOULD COME IN THE NFL WITH
THE SHORT EXIST ARMS FOR A
CORNER.
DOESN'T MATTER.
EXCELLENT TACKLER.
EXCELLENT INSTINCTS.
INCREDIBLY INTELLIGENT GUY.
>> ALSO TRYING TO REPLACE HONEY
BADGER TOO.
>> HE WAS ASKING CAN I PLAY
SAFETY.
YOU ARE TOO GOOD OF A CORNER.
HE LIKES TO TACKLE.
GREAT INSTINCTS.
IT GOES BACK TO WHAT I SAID
EARLIER, PLANT AND DRIVE.
MAKE A PLAY ON THE FOOTBALL.
IF YOU CAN'T MAKE A PLAY ON THE
FOOTBALL, MAKE THE TACKLE.
DON'T GIVE UP ANY EXTRA YARDS.
THAT'S THE NAME OF THE LEAGUE
RIGHT NOW.
HE IS EXCELLENT IN THAT REGARD.
HE IS READY TO PLAY.
HE IS A GOOD ATHLETE.
HE IS THE MENTAL MAKEUP IN MY
OPINION OF A TEN-YEAR NFL
VETERAN WHICH YOU GET MAYBE ONE
OR TWO GUYS IN EVERY NFL DRAFT.
THIS IS AN A FOR ME.
I LIKE THE CHIEFS BEING
AGGRESSIVE TO GET MY CORNERBACK
AND ONE OF THE BEST DEFENDERS IN
THE ENTIRE DRAFT.
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK, FELDER?
>> I LOVE IT.
THE KID IS GOOD.
WE TALKED ABOUT SAUCE, STINGLEY,
THE TWO OFF THE TOP FIVE AND
THOSE GUYS, WE CALL THEM MAN
CORNERS CONSISTENTLY.
THIS IS A GUY THAT IS NOT A MAN
CORNER.
YOU MENTIONED HIM WANTING TO
PLAY SAFETY.
I GIVE THIS A A.
HE IS SOMEONE THAT CAN PLAY --
WE WATCHED HIM ON CLIP.
WE WATCHED HIM TRACK ACROSS THE
FIELD IN MAN.
HE CAN PLAY IN THE SLOT, HAVE
HIM RUN WITH THE SLOT ACROSS THE
FIELD IN PLAN.
PLAY HIM OUTSIDE AND LET HIM BE
A GUY IN CLOUD, THAT THAT COVER
TWO TO FORCE THE EDGE.
YOU CAN PLAY HIM OVER THE TOP
AND PRESS.
YOU CAN PLAY HIM INSIDE AND
PRESS.
HE CAN MIRROR THAT SLOT AND
CARRY UP THE FIELD.
HE CAN DO A LOT OF DIFFERENT
THINGS.
>> THE CHIEFS LOVE TO PLAY THAT
MULTIPLE DEFENSE WHERE THE ROLLS
ARE CONSTANTLY CHANGING.
RICHARD SHERMAN, YOU THINK OF
THE CHIEFS AND TRENT McDUFFIE,
WHAT KIND OF A FIT DO WE HAVE
HERE AT CORNER?
>> I MEAN, WHEN THEY LOST
TARVARIS WARD I EXPECTED THEM TO
MOVE UP IN THE DRAFT AND MAYBE
GET INVOLVED IN TRYING TO GET
STINGLEY OR SAUCE.
BUT, YOU KNOW, I KNEW THAT WAS A
LONG SHOT.
I THINK TRENT McDUFFIE FITS WHAT
THEY WANT TO DO.
A NOT OF MANTA TO MAN.
VERY PHYSICAL, FEISTY.
YOU YOU CAN UNDERSTAND WHAT THEY
SEE HIN HIM.
HE CAN GO INSIDE.
HE CAN GO OUTSIDE.
YOU HAD THE CONVERSATION ABOUT
HIM MOVING TO SAFETY.
I THINK THAT'S WHAT THEY SEE.
THEY SEE A GUY WHO IS A FOOTBALL
PLAYER.
HE PLAYS CORNER BUT HE CAN
TACKLE.
HE HAS NO FEAR.
HE MOVES WELL IN SPACE.
HE TACKLES WELL.
HE IS SMART.
I EXPECT THEM TO FIND A WAY TO
PUT HIM ON THE FIELD HIS ROOKIE
YEAR.
>> RICHARD SHERMAN, ONE OF THE
G.O.A.T.s.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I AM GOING, THEY LOST HONEY
BADGER.
THE CHIEFS ARE ABOUT GUYS THAT
CAN DO A LOT OF THINGS AND THE
WAY THAT YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT
TRENT McDUFFIE, HE KIND OF
COVERS BOTH.
BUT THEY ARE GOING TO NEED
DEPTH.
WE ARE NOW TO PICK NUMBER 22.
BEFORE BE ANNOUNCE THE PICK, IT
IS THE PACKERS.
WE KNOW THAT THENEED TO GET AAR
RODGERS A RECEIVER.
I DON'T KNOW IF THERE IS ANY
RECEIVERS.
>> JUST GOT IT.
I AM PRETTY FLOORED BY THIS.
I AM QUESTIONING THIS SOURCE.
BUT I'LL SAY IT.
>> THEY ARE GOING TO ZOOM IT ON
THE SCREEN.
>> YEAH, I DON'T CARE.
IF YOU ARE WRONG, YOU'RE WRONG.
WHATEVER.
CLAY WALKER IS WHO I HAVE BEEN
TEXTED.
QUAY WALKER.
Y
WOW.
QUAY WALKER.
LINEBACKER OUT OF GEORGIA.
I DON'T KNOW IF HE IS THE BEST
QUAY WALKER GOING TO THE GREEN
BAY PACKERS.
YOU LOOK AT THEIR LINEBACKER
ROOM RIGHT NOW.
THEY DID LOSE.
I'M KIND OF SHOCKED.
I WILL LET YOU GO.
WHERE DID YOU HAVE QUAY WALKER
EXPEC
EXPECTED TO GO?
>> SOMEBODY I KNEW SPRINKLED
1,000 ON HIM.
THIS WAS PICKING UP TOVER THE
LAST WEEK.
I AM FLOORED THAT STILL HE WAS
TAKEN BEFORE DEVIN LLOYD AND
TAKE BRCH HIS TEAMMATE NAKOBE
DEAN.
HERE IS THE SCOOP WITH QUAY WALK
EARLY, RIGHT?
BIG, FAST, ATHLETIC, RANGE,
INSTINCTS, EH.
TAKING ON CONTACT?
NOT GREAT YET.
HE IS A LITTLE BIT OF A PROJECT
PLAYER FOR THIS KIND OF PICK.
IN THE SECOND ROUND, YOU CAN
LIVE WITH THOSE THINGS BECAUSE
HE IS ATHLETIC IN SPACE.
HE IS THIS BIG BRUISER COMING
DOWNHILL?
LISTEN, HE HAS A LOT OF SPACE TO
RUPP AROUND BECAUSE ALL THE GUYS
HE IS PLAYING AROUND ARE DRAFTED
TONIGHT AND JALEN CARTER WILL BE
DRAFTED IN THE TOP FIVE IN THE
FUTURE.
I HAVE QUESTIONS ABOUT VALUE.
IT JUST FEELS LIKE THE PACKERS
HAD OTHER NEEDS IN THIS SPOT.
HE IS MY 74th OVERALL PLAYER.
>> AND THEY TAKE HIM AT 22 WITH
THE PICK THEY GOT IN THE DAVANTE
ADAMS TRADE.
>> I THOUGHT THERE WAS A CHANCE
HE COULD SNEAK IN WITH THE LIONS
PICKING AT THE LAST PICK IN THE
DRAFT AND I GET YOU ARE BETTING
ON THE
ONCE AGAIN, I DON'T REALLY LIKE
THE VALUE HERE.
I DON'T LIKE HOW MUCH BETTER
THIS MAKES THE PACKERS RIGHT
NOW.
AND I DON'T ANOTHER TEAM WAS
REALLY GOING TO TAKE HIM.
THIS IS REALLY HARSH, AND THIS
ISN'T THE FUN PART.
THIS IS A D PLUS.
THE VALUE'S TERRIBLE.
THEY HAVE AARON RODGERS TO WIN A
SUPER BOWL RIGHT NOW.
QUAY WALKER IS WHAT'S GETTING
YOU OVER THE HUMP?
I DON'T GET IT.
>> I DON'T UNDERSTAND.
HE NEEDS HELP.
AARON RODGERS, HE NEEDS HELP.
ALL THE ANTICS AND ALL THE OTHER
GARBAGE, HE'S ONE OF THE BEST
QUARTERBACKS IN THE NFL, AND HE
NEEDS HELP, AND THIS DOESN'T
HELP HIM.
>> BUT GUYS, QUAY WALKER PLAYED
A LOT OF SPECIAL TEAM SNAPS,
ISN'T THAT VALUABLE?
>> YOU KNOW WHAT, I'M GOING, IF
I'M, I GOT, HE'S NOT THE BEST,
HE'S NOT THE BEST LINEBACKER OUT
OF THAT LINEBACKING ROOM AT
GEORGIA.
HE'S NOT THE BEST LINEBACKER,
EVEN, I'M JUST TALKING ABOUT IN
THE DRAFT, FLOTT EVEN OF THE GUY
THAT IS AREN'T EVEN IN THE
DRAFT.
HE'S NOT AN EDGE RUSHER.
WHICH IS WHAT WE TALKED ABOUT
WHERE TAKE THE FOOTBALL AWAY
FROM THE QUARTERBACK OR FIND
WAYS TO HELP THE QUARTERBACK.
HE'S NOT THAT.
HE'S A SIDE-TO-SIDE CHASE
LINEBACKER, BUT HE'S NOT IN THE
SAME WORLD OF GUYS WE'VE SEEN
GET DRAFTED IN THE FIRST ROUND
AS A CHASING LINEBACKER.
HE'S NOT IN THAT SAME WORLD.
SO I DON'T GET THE, I GUESS ALL
IT TAKES IS ONE TEAM TO FALL IN
LOVE WITH A PLAYER.
WHY DIDN'T THEY JUST WAIT TO GET
HIM IN '28.
>> QUAY WALKER THE PICK AT 22.
SO THE RAVENS TRADED HOLLYWOOD
BROWN FOR THE THIRD PICK.
THE BILLS NOW TRADE TO JUMP
AHEAD OF THE COWBOYS FROM 25 TO
23.
SO THE RAVENS, IN THEIR TRADING
OF HOLLYWOOD BROWN PICKS UP
WHAT, ANOTHER FOURTH ROUND PICK
>> I'M TRYING TO DO THE MATH IN
MY HEAD.
>> I WOULD LIKE DAXTON HILL.
FOR BUFFALO.
AND DAXTON HILL CAN PLAY THE
SLOT FOR YOU IF YOU DO FIGURE
OUT YOUR SAFETY ISSUE AS WELL.
IF NOT, HE'S YOUR SAFETY OF THE
FUTURE.
HE'S GOT BALL SKILLS, TACKLES,
AND INCREDIBLE EYES.
IN THAT DEFENSE, YOU HAVE TO BE
ABLE TO SEE EVERYTHING.
THAT'S WHAT THEY'RE GOING TO ASK
OF YOU.
I WOULD THINK THIS IS A MOVE FOR
DAXTON HILL.
IT WOULD BE A SLAM DUNK FOR
BUFFALO.
I HA
I HAVE HIM AT 23.
WHO DO YOU SEE IN THE BIG GAMES?
>> WHY TRADE AHEAD OF THE COWBOY
S
S?
WHO DO WE THINK THAT THE COWBOYS
WOULD SHARE.
>> JERMAINE JOHNSON.
>> VON MILLER $100 MILLION.
>> A LITTLE SURPRISING FOR ME.
>> I'M HEARING IT'S FOR KHAI EAR
ELAM.
IS HE RIGHT?
FAMILY FEUD.
KYLER ELAM, THE CORNERBACK OUT
OF THE FLORIDA.
THE BUFFALO BILLS TRADE TO GET
KHAIER ELAM.
HIGH CHARACTER GUY.
MAKES SENSE FROM THIS.
LEVI WALLACE LEFT IN FREE
AGENCY.
TRA DAVOUS WHITE.
AND THEY NEED TALENT AT CORNER.
>> I LIKE KHAIIER ON THE LINE.
WE'RE GOING TO HIT A PLATEAU
RANGE OF PLAYERS.
I CAME OUT OF SUMMER WATCHING
2020 TAPE, HIS 2020 TAMEPE IS
RIGHT THERE WITH DERRICK SINGLY.
UNFORTUNATELY, FLORIDA PROGRAM,
SOMETIMES THAT HAPPENS IN C
COLLEGE.
I DON'T THINK KHAIIER IS CHECKED
OUT.
YOU HAVE A BIG, PHYSICAL PRESS
CORNER.
VERY PHYSICAL.
HANDS ON BUT THE LINE OF
SCRIMMAGE.
THE BIGGEST PROBLEM VERY WITH
KHAI
KHAIER ELAM, HE CANNOT TACKLE
RIGHT NOW.
HE IS BUILT TO TACKLE.
HE IS IN A FAMILY FULL OF
SAFETIES.
I DOESN'T EVEN THINK THE
EFFORT'S THAT BAD.
HE STRUGGLES TO COME TO BALANCE.
IN COVERAGE, I LOVE THE UPSIDE
OF KHAIER YELAM.
YOU KNOW WHAT THEY'RE GOING TO
RUN INTO.
THE VALUE'S FINE.
ONCE AGAIN, THE QUARTERBACK RUN
GOT A LITTLE CRAZY.
GOING UP TO GET HIM IS A LITTLE
BIT INTERESTING TO ME.
I DON'T FLOWKNOW IF I LOVE THATT
YOU DIDN'T REALLY PAY ANYTHING.
YOU HAVE A CORNER BEFORE THIS
THING FALLS OFF THE CLIFF.
AND KHAIER HAS A FEW TECHNIQUE
THINGS TO WORK ON.
>> I THINK THE TECHNIQUE THING
IS KEY.
HE LIVED ON GRABBING PEOPLE.
MANHANDLING GUYS, ESSENTIALLY.
AND WHETHER IT WAS IN PRESS OR
OFF, THE PLAY FOR HIM DOESN'T
STOP A LOT OF TIMES.
THAT WAS A BAD CALL.
BUT FOR A LOT OF TIMES.
T
PLAY DOESN'T START UNTIL HE PUTS
HIS HANDS ON SOMEBODY.
I LOVE THE FACT THAT THE PLAY
STARTS FOR HIM MOST OF THE TIME
WHEN HE GETS HIS HANDS ON
SOMEBODY.
HIS ABILITY TO ESSENTIALLY STOP
THE ROUT.
YOU SEE HIM THERE PUSH THE
RECEIVER IN THE BACK.
RUN THE ROUT.
FOR ME, I'M GOING TO GO WITH AN
A MINUS.
YOU MENTIONED SOME OF THE WOES
THEY'VE HAD THAT BACK END.
SO THEY ARE ADDRESSING A
SPECIFIC NEED.
I'M GR
I'M GLAD THAT YOU MENTIONED THAT
IT SORT OF PLATEAUS.
THERE'S NOT THAT BIG OF A GAP.
>> 6'1", 191.
4-3-9 SPEED AND HE'S NOT EVEN 21
YET.
THEY'VE GOT TO BE THINKING WE
CAN GROOM THIS GUY.
RICHARD SHERMAN, WHEN YOU LOOK
AT KHAIER ELAM, WHAT DO YOU
THINK OF THE PROSPECT?
>> WELL, I MEAN, THEY GOT A
GREAT SET OF SAFETIES.
YOU GOT TREY WHITE, STILL ONE OF
THE BEST CORNERS IN THE NATIONAL
FOOTBALL LEAGUE.
I JUST FEEL LIKE HE NEEDS TIME
TO DEVELOP.
IN THAT SYSTEM, THEY'LL SCHOOL
HIM.
I FEEL LIKE HE'S A LITTLE BIT
LOOSE IN HIS ZONE COVERAGE.
I'M NOT REALLY A FAN OF THAT.
HE GUESSES A LITTLE BIT.
HE DEPENDS ON HIS FEET A LITTLE
BIT.
BUT I THINK THOSE THINGS CAN BE
CORRECTED, AND WITH GOOD
COACHING, AND THEY HAVE GOOD
COACHING IN BUFFALO, I THINK HE
WILL DEVELOP INTO A BETTER
PLAYER THAN IF HE WOULD WENT TO
SOMEWHERE ELSE.
THE FIT OF THE TEAM IS GOING TO
BENEFIT THE PLAYER TREMENDOUSLY,
SIMILAR TO WHAT YOU HEAR AND SEE
WITH THE BALTIMORE RAVENS.
>> YOU'RE SEEING SEAN McDERMOTT,
LESLIE FRAZIER WERE EXPECTING
SOME TIME.
THEY'VE GOT TO SLOW DOWN JAMAR
CHASE.
YOU SEE THEM HELPING THIS
PROSPECT.
>> NO QUESTION.
I SEE THEM SEEING HE HAS THE
SPEED, HE HAS THE SIZE, THE
WILLINGNESS TO TACKLE.
THEY'RE GOING TO EDUCATE HIM,
PUT HIM WITH TREY WHITE, GET HIS
TECHNIQUE, HIS FOOTWORK, GET HIS
45 DEGREE ANGLES AND HIS PRESS,
MAKE SURE HE UNDERSTANDS HIS
READS AND HE'S GOING TO BE A
MUCH BETTER PLAYER, JUST BECAUSE
HE'S ANTICIPATING THINGS INSTEAD
OF REACTING TO EVERYTHING.
>> I LIKE THAT.
>> THANK YOU FOR THE INSIGHT.
SOMETIMES YOU CAN TAKE MORE
RISKS ON GUYS THAT HAVE SO MUCH
ATHLETIC POTENTIAL WHEN YOU KNOW
THAT YOU'RE AN ORGANIZATION THAT
CAN HANDLE THAT.
DALLAS COWBOYS ARE UP.
I'M LOOKING AT JERRY JONES IN
HIS DARTH VADER-LIKE ROOM, WHERE
HE'S LOOKING AT HIS SONS AND
TREATING ONE BETTER THAN THE
OTHER JUST SO THAT THE OTHER ONE
IS MORE MOTIVATED TO OUTWORK THE
OTHER.
WE'RE SITTING HERE AT 24.
THEY NEEDED AN EDGE RUSHER.
JERMAINE JOHNSON IS STILL THERE.
THEY DON'T NEED LINEBACKER
TA
TALENT, EVEN THOUGH THERE'S GAD
O
GOOD ONES OUT THERE.
>> I'M NOT CONVINCED HE'S
DEFINITELY GOING IN THE FIRST
ROUND.
YOU KNOW JERMAINIONSON JOHNSON
MAKE
MAKES A TON OF SENSE.
THEY HAVE A LOT OF LINEBACKERS.
THE SAFETY FROM GEORGIA, I LACK
AT LOOK
AT THAT ONE, HE ALMOST
DECAPITATED KYLE PITTS.
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT SOMEONE WHO
IS RUTHLESS.
>> WHAT IF THEY GO BACK TO THAT
PENN STATE.
>> LET'S GET OUR GAMBLES, WHAT
ARE WE THINKING?
>> I THINK BRISTER.
>> I'M GOING TO GO LINDERBAUM.
>> WHY DO WE THINK GERMANE
JOHNSON IS STILL ON THE BOARD?
THIS IS ME TRYING TO SPEAK FOR
WHAT PEOPLE WOULD BE CONCERNED
ABOUT.
23-YEAR-OLD, A LONG ROAD.
WHICH I DON'T FKNOW WHY THAT'S N
INSULT.
HE'S VERY SELF-AWARE.
JUCO, GEORGIA.
SAID I WANT TO PLAY MORE.
AND HE WAS RIGHT.
HE WENT TO FLORIDA STATE AND HAD
14 AND A HALF SACKS.
>> HE IS 23.
>> A PHENOMENAL TESTER.
AND HE'S PRO READY.
HE HAS VIOLENT HANDS.
WHE
WHEN HE GETS PICKED, I'LL GO
THROUGH THE HANDS.
HE MAY GO TO A CONTENDER NOW.
>> THE COWBOYS ARE STILL ON THE
CLOCK.
IN TERMS OF REACHES, MORE OF A
REACH, QUAY WALKER AT 22.
OR PENNING AT 19?
>> WALKER BY A FULL ROUND.
WHAT ARE WING TO?
>> YOU NO HE WHAT WE'RE DOING.
IT'S THE GREEN BAY PACKERS.
HE'S NOT A CRYER.
HE'S AN EFF YOU.
>> TO NECESSITATE THE BILLS
JUMPING AHEAD OF THE COWBOYS.
>> THE BILLS PAID THE 130th
PICK.
THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE TO CUT
SOMEONE, YOU THROW THAT PICK
AWAY LIKE CHANGE IN YOUR POCKET
AT THE ARCADE.
DOESN'T MATTER.
>> WITH RESPECT TO THE COWBOYS,
IS THERE A POSSIBILITY THEY WERE
THINKING ELAM COULD TURN INTO
THAT?
>> THERE'S A CHANCE, YEAH.
THERE'S ABSOLUTELY A CHANCE.
>> 6'1", ALMOST 200 POUNDS.
>> SAFETY BLOODLINES.
>> THE COWBOYS ARE A TEAM THAT
NEED A WIDE RECEIVER, TOO.
>> I HAVE THE PICK HERE, AND I'M
NOT SHOCKED BY THIS.
IT IS AN OFFENSIVE LINEMAN.
I'M HEARING IT'S TYLER SMITH,
THE OFFENSIVE TACKLE FROM TULSA.
20 YEARS OLD TONIGHT.
>> WOW.
>> TONIGHT HIS BIRTHDAY?
>> NO.
>> AS OF TODAY.
>> BE MUCH COOLER.
>> SO YOU'RE DOING TYLER SMITH.
WHAT DOES THE INTERNET SAY?
TYLER SMITH TO THE COWBOYS.
THEY LOVE DRAFTING OFFENSIVE
LINEMEN.
HAD 12 HOLDING CALLS IN 2021.
WHEN YOU LOSE CONNOR WILLIAMS,
SOMEBODY HAS TO GET PENALIZED
ALL THE TIME.
JUST KIDDING.
>> YOU GOT TO PAY THE PRICE TO
GET THESE OFFENSIVE LINEMEN.
THIS IS AN UPSIDE.
FROM A FRANCHISE THAT INVESTS IN
OFFENSIVE LINE AS MUCH AS
ANYBODY IN THE NFL.
I COMPARE HIM TO TAYLOR MOTON.
SOMEBODY WITH THE REDIRECTION,
THE HANDS THAT HE DOESN'T KNOW
HOW TO USE HIS HANDS YET,
THEY'RE ALL OVER THE PLACE, AND
HE'S STILL MOVING PEOPLE DOWN
THE FIELD.
THAT'S WHAT'S SO IMPRESSIVE TO
ME.
IF HE CAN KLCLEAN UP THE HAND
TECHNIQUE.
I LOVE THAT ABOUT TYLER SMITH.
HE'S A BULLY IN THE PRUN GAME, E
DIDN'T START PLAYING OFFENSIVE
LINE UNTIL VERY LATE IN HIS
CAREER.
THERE'S A LOT OF MEAT ON THE
BONE I LIKE TO SAY.
YES, THE PENALTIES ARE A LITTLE
BIT OF AN ISSUE.
HE'S LEARNING HOW TO PLAY TACKLE
ON THE FLY THAT AT A SCHOOL, HOW
MANY TIMES DO THEY CHURN OUT
FIRST-ROUNDTACKLES.
I REALLY LIKE THE IDEA OF
REINVESTING IN THE LINE.
THEY WAITED UNTIL HE FELL INTO
THEIR LAP AND HE'S A BULLY THAT
FITS THEIR IDENTITY.
HE'S GOT A LITTLE DEVELOPING TO
DO.
I THINK HE'LL DO IT AT GUARD
RIGHT OUT OF THE GATE.
>> I WAS SUPPOSED TO WAIT FOR MY
PICK.
I WENT FOR THE B PLUS AS WELL.
I WANT TO GET TO KELCE.
THE QUESTION I WAS GOING TO ASK.
LET'S, I WANT TO ASK HIM, DOES
THIS GUY, DOES HE PLAY TACKLE AT
ALL IN THE NFL?
OR IS HE SOMEONE THAT YOU KICK
DOWN THE GUARD TO START AND HE
STANDS THERE FULL TIME?
>> I MEAN, HE CAN DEFINITELY
KICK DOWN THE GUARD.
HE'S GOT THE SIZE.
THE METRICS.
HE'S A BIG, BIG ATHLETE, RAW
PLAYER.
I THINK HE COULD DEFINITELY PLAY
GUARD, FOR SURE.
THAT MIGHT BE THE BEST PLACE FOR
HIM TO START AND ALL OF A SUDDEN
BLOSSOM OUT THE TACKLE.
HE'S A BULLY IN THE RUN GAME
WHICH YOU'RE WANTING IN A GUARD,
HIS HANDS ARE STRONG ONCE
THEY'RE ON YOU.
YOU AIN'T GETTING OFF.
A LOT OF THOSE TRAITS REALLY DO
FIT WELL FOR A GUARD.
>> ANOTHER THING I WANTED TO
GET, HOW DO YOU SOLVE THE
PENALTY ISSUE.
THE GRABBING, HOW DO YOU SOLVE
THE PENALTY ISSUE?
WHAT DO YOU DO FROM A COACHING
STANDPOINT?
WHAT WOULD BE YOUR FIRST STEPS?
>> YEAH, A LOT OF HOLDING COMES
DOWN TO BODY POSITION.
I LED THE LEAGUE IN PENALTIES,
DANG NEAR.
THAT CAN BE COACH STYLE, THAT
CAN BE TAUGHT.
A LOT OF IT'S JUST LEARNING
WHETHE
WHEN TO LET GO.
YOU BRING YOUR HANDS IN TIGHT,
THERE'S DEFINITELY WAYS TO
IMPROVE THAT, AND HE'S SO RAW
THAT, AND YOUNG.
THE YOUNGEST OFFENSIVE LINEMAN
IN THE DRAFT, I THINK.
THE FACT THAT HE'S GOT SO MUCH
ROOM TO GROW, I'M SURE THAT THE
COWBOYS ARE LOVING THE POTENTIAL
DOWN THE ROAD FOR THIS KID,
EITHER GUARD OR TACKLE.
>> JASON KELCE, THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
RIGHT NOW, TERRENCE STEEL AT
RIGHT AT THTACKLE.
YOU CAN PUT HIM NEXT TO TYRON
SMITH.
HE'S BEEN MISSING GAMES EVERY
YEAR DUE TO INJURIES.
SO YEAH, CAN YOU REPLACE CONNOR
WILLIAMS AND SLIDE THIS GUY IN
AT RIGHT GUARD, BUT IF COULD BE
THE FUTURE INVESTMENT IN YOUR
RIGHT TACKLE IF YOU GET HIM IN
THERE.
THE RAVENS ARE ON THE CLOCK.
WE WILL GET TO THAT IN A SECOND,
BUT FIRST A MESSAGE FROM ROCKET
MORTGAGE.
>>> TWO OF CONNOR'S SIX PLAYERS
STILL AVAILABLE.
TWO OF THE LINEBACKERS STILL
AVAILABLE.
THERE'S TWO EDGE RUSHERS, A
LITTLE SURPRISING, A BUNCH OF
SAFETIES.
THE MONSTER OUT OF U CON, TRAVIS
JONES IS THERE.
AND THEN A FEW MORE EDGE GUYS.
BUT WHAT WE'RE NOT SEEING IS
TACKLES AND WIDE RECEIVERS.
FEEL LIKE THOSE WELLS HAVE RUN
DRY, CONNOR?
>> YEAH, THE ONLY GUY WE'VE GOT
LEFT, WHO I'M NOT AS HIGH ON,
BUT HE'S GOOD TACKLE PROSPECT
WOULD BE BERNARD RAYMOND.
HE COULD GO ON THIS TACKLE RUN,
BUT MAN, THIS IS CRAZY RIGHT
NOW.
TAKE A LOOK AT THESE LAST TEN
PICKS.
WHAT JUMPS OUT TO YOU?
>> FOR ME, IT'S AJ BROWN BEING
TRADED.
WHAT ABOUT YOU?
>> THE QUICK RUN ON THOSE
GUARDS.
GREEN TO BURKS TO OBVIOUSLY
PENNING WHO YOU EXPECT TO PLAY
INSIDE EARLY IF POSSIBLE.
AND THEN WE'VE OBVIOUSLY GOT
TYLER SMITH M IN THAT MIX AS WE.
A LATE SHIFT IN TERMS OF
CONVENTIONAL WISDOM.
>> I'M ALSO LOVING, THE MORE I
THINK ABOUT THE TRENT McDUFFIE
PICK, THE MORE I'M FALLING IN
LOVE WITH IT.
THE FACT CONNOR IS TALKING ABOUT
HIS INTELLIGENCE LIKE THAT.
THAT'S THE PART OF HONEY
BADGER'S GAME THAT NEVER GETS
THE CREDIT.
IF YOU COULD FIND THAT NEXT
VERSION OF HIM FOR A TEAM THAT'S
READY TO GO FOR SUPER BOWL, IT
DOESN'T SOUND LIKE HE'S GOING TO
NEED TOO MUCH TIME.
RAVENS ARE UP.
THEY BREWLEW YOU AWAY KYLE
HAMILTON.
WHEN THEY WERE SITTING THERE
AT 14, IT COVERS UP FOR THE FACT
THAT THEY TRADED HOLLYWOOD
BROWN.
>> I STILL DO HAVE SOME
QUESTIONS OFFENSIVELY.
BUT THEY'VE BEEN ALL OVER
JERMAINE JOHNSON.
I'D BE A LITTLE SURPRISED IF
THEY LET HIM BY AGAIN.
>> WHY AREN'T THE RAVENS GOING
LINDERBAUM RIGHT HERE?
>> MAYBE.
>> I GOT ONE FOR YOU.
TRAVIS JONES.
WE TALK SO MUCH ABOUT THE RAVENS
TAKING JORDAN DAVIS.
>> WHY NOT THE OTHER HUGE NOSE
TACKLE.
>> EXACTLY, THE OTHER HUMONGOUS
GUY.
WE HAVEN'T TALKED ABOUT TRAVIS
JONES AT ALL.
U CON, DEFENSIVE TACKLE, BIG
BOY.
>> HE REMINDS ME OF MARCEL
TEAROUS.
6'4", 325.
THE FACT THAT ALL THE BIG
DEFENSE OF LINEMEN.
>> IT SHOWS YOU THE TYPE OF
ATHLETE THAT EXISTS RIGHT NOW.
>> IS THAT YOUR SNPICK?
>> THERE'S NO CHANCE THEY GO
LINEBACKERS HERE.
>> OKAY, I GOT TO.
>> WERE ANY OF US RIGHT?
>> DID YOU SAY LINDERBAUM?
>> I DID.
>> IT IS LINDERBAUM.
>> YO.
>> YOUR BUOY'S FEELING GOOD.
>> THEIR STARTING LINEMAN IS
TRISTAN CALONE.
TCC.
THEY GOT LIMHIM.
YOU'RE HOPING THAT STANLEY COMES
BACK.
SO YOU GO HEY, LAMAR JACKSON.
I KNOW WE JUST GOT RID OF YOUR
FAVORITE WIDE RECEIVER, BUT NOW
WE'RE GIVING YOU A CENTER TO
PRE
PROTECT YOU.
6'2", 296, A TWO-TIME ALL
AMERICAN.
THE REMINGTON AWARD WINNER.
35 CONSECUTIVE STARTS AT CENTER.
IF YOU NEED A CENTER, THIS IS
THE GUY.
WHAT DO YOU THINK AT 25, WHICH I
THINK WAS THE RANGE FOR HIM?
>> DYNAMITE.
TOP FIVE PLAYER TIN THIS DRAFT.
IF YOU DON'T VALUE CENTERS, I
MEAN, I DON'T KNOW WHAT YOU'RE
THINKING, IT DOES MATTER A LOT.
AND HESA  IS A BLUE CHIP TALENT.
SHOT PUT, DISCUS, TEAM CAPTAIN.
>> I SAW THAT HE WAS A SIX-SPORT
ATHLETE.
AND I'M HILIKE, THERE'S SIX
SPORTS?
>> HIS RANGE IS UNBELIEVABLE.
HE IS SO LIGHTNING QUICK.
HE LOVES PLAYING THROUGH THE
WHISTLE.
HE LIKES TO TAKE THE LIFE OUT OF
YOU.
WHERE I WATCH THE COACH'S TAPE
AND YOU WATCH THE OVERHEAD AND
YOU SEE GUYS COMPLAINING TO THE
REFS ABOUT HIM AFTER THE PLAY.
AND THE REFS ARE LIKE, IT'S
FOOTBALL, MAN.
HE IS THE DEFINITION OF TONE
CERTIFICAT
SETTER IN THE RUN GAME.
THIS IS, THIS IS TOP FLIGHT
PHRASE, AND THIS PHRASE HAPPENED
BEFORE WE EVEN BOOKED HIM FOR
THE SHOW.
JASON KELCE.
SO TYLER LINDERBAUM IS AN
ALL-PLUS PICK.
>> I ECHO ALL THOSE SENTIMENTS.
THIS GUY'S A BULLDOG.
PITBULL.
ONCE I LOCKS ON YOU, IT'S GAME
OVER.
HE'S GOING TO MOVE YOU AROUND.
PEOPLE ARE GOING TO LACOOK AT H
AND SAY HE'S A LITTLE BIT SMALL.
HE'S GOING TO MOVE YOU AROUND.
>> JASON KELCE, HEAD COACH OF
IOWA, QUOTE, I DON'T KNOW IF IT
GETS ANY BETTER THAN TYLER.
OUR OWN CONNOR ROGERS COMPARED
HIM TO YOU.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> IT'S A GREAT COMPARISON.
I THINK HE'S AN UNBELIEVABLE
PLAYER.
OBVIOUSLY A LITTLE BIT
UNDERSIZE.
>> I'VE GOT IT.
VER
I HAVE THE TRADE.
>> THEIR IS GUY IS SO POLISHED.
UNBELIEVABLE FINISHER.
TEAM CAPTAIN.
EVERYTHING YOU WANT TO SEE IN AN
OFFENSIVE LINEMAN.
I'M A LITTLE SURPRISED AT
BALTIMORE, BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT A
HUGE ZONE TEAM, BUT OBVIOUSLY,
THEY DIDN'T CARE EITHER.
AND I DON'T SEE THE ANGER ISSUE.
I SEE HIM SIT DOWN WELL, I THAT
I WRESTLING BACKGROUND SERVES
HIM WELL.
HE MOVES HIS FEET, HAS GOOD
AGILITY.
>> AND THAT'S COMING FROM THE
SOURCE.
JASON KELCE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THE JETS HAVE TRADED UP TO 26.
WHO DO THEY TRADE WITH?
>> 26 SHOULD HAVE BEEN --
>> IT WAS THE TITANS.
>> THEY TRADED TO TAKE JERMAINE
JOHNSON.
I THINK I GOT TO BREAK IT FIRST.
>> HEY, LOOK WHO THAT IS.
THAT'S YOU.
>> I'VE BEEN TOLD THEY TRADE
BACK IN.
YOU KNOW, OBVIOUSLY, THEY'RE
PRETTY JACKED UP ABOUT THIS.
>> ARE YOU.
>> YOU BROKE THE NEWS, AND IT'S
A GUY THAT WE'RE LIKE, WHY IS HE
FALLING?
TALK ABOUT YOU.
>> I DON'T LIKE TALKING ABOUT
MYSELF.
>> TALK ABOUT YOU.
>> I MEAN HONESTLY, THIS IS AN
EXCITING PLAYER, A TOP TEN
PLAYER.
I GREW UP IN A HOUSEHOLD WITH A
JET SEASON TICKET HOLDER.
WE DO NOT KNOW WHAT A PASS
RUSHER LOOKS LIKE.
THE ONLY ONEKI RE I CAN REMEMBE
WATCHING AS A KID WAS JOHN
ABRAHAM.
SHOUT OUT TO MY TDAD AT HOME WH
RAISED ME AS A JETS FAN.
HE TEXTED ME AND SAID THIS HAS
TO BE JERMAINE JOHNSON AND I
SAID SORRY, DAD.
AND THEY GO BACK IN THE DRAFT
AND GET HIM FROM EVERYTHING I'VE
HEARD.
>> WHERE WAS HE ON YOUR BIG
BOARD?
>> I'M PROBABLY THE HIGHEST ON
HIM.
BUT I WAS MY SIXTH OVERALL
PLAYER.
>> WHY ARE YOU HIGH ON HIM?
WHAT ARE YOU SIGHINEEING THAT O
PEOPLE AREN'T SEEING?
>> THE BEST HANDS.
I THINK OF ANY PASS RUSHER IN
THE DRAFT, BESIDES MAYBE HUTCH.
AND IT'S CLOSE.
IT'S CLOSE.
SO THE GET OFF, THE TEN-YARD
SPLIT IS AN ELITE METRIC FOR
HIM.
YOU HAVE TO PIN YOUR EARS BACK,
GET UPFIELD AND GET AFTER THE
QUARTERBACK.
NOW YOU GET AWAY FROM THAT,
RIGHT, GREAT HANDS TO SET A HARD
EDGE AGAINST THE RUN, WHICH IS
SOMETHING WE TALKED ABOUT ON THE
PHONE EIGHT MILLION TIMES.
HE'S THE GUY THAT I'M WATCHING
TAPE OF EKWONU.
HE CAN FLATTEN INTO THE POCKET.
I'M NOT SAYING HE'S GOING TO BE
MILES GARRETT, HE'S A
CAPTIVATING PLAYER FROM JUCO TO
FLORIDA STATE.
HE SAID I WANT TO PLAY MORE.
AND YOU HEAR HIM AT THE COMBINE.
A LOT OF GUYS GET DEFENSIVE WHEN
YOU ASK THEM WHY DID IT TAKE YOU
SO LONG TO BREAK OUT.
AND HE'S NOT LIKE THAT.
HE'S VERY SELF-AWARE, A VERY
HARD WORKER.
REMINDS ME OF MATT JUDON WHO
NEVER STOPS GOING.
THEY WOULD HAVE TAKEN HIM AT TEN
IF THEY SOLVED THE WIDE RECEIVER
PROBLEM IN THE OFF SEASON.
THEY TOOK GARRETT WILSON, AND
THEY STILL GET JERMAINE JOHNSON.
THIS IS AN A PLUS FOR ME.
I THINK HE'S FINALLY GOING TO
END THE ABRAHAM CURSE.
>> THE TEAMMATES, WHEN THEY WERE
ASKED ABOUT HIM SAID HE IS A
FIRST ONE IN, LAST ONE OUT.
WE ALL LOVE HIM.
WHAT DO YOU THINK OF THIS GUY,
AND THE FACT THAT HE'S CHOSEN AT
26.
>> HE'S AN A PLAYER IN GENERAL.
I DO A LOT OF ACC WORK, SO I SEE
PLENTY OF THIS GUY OVER THE
COURSE OF THE YEAR.
THE BIG THING I LOVED ABOUT HIM
IS HIS VERSATILITY.
CONNOR MENTIONED ALL THE MOVES.
LINED UP RIGHT OFF THE OUTSIDE
OF THAT OFFENSIVE LINEMAN.
HE CAN MAKE A TACKLE LATERALLY.
HE'S LANE
HE'S LINED UP INSIDE OF THAT
WING.
I LOVE THE FACT HE'S A FIGHTER.
HIS EFFORT NEVER LACKS.
THAT'S ANOTHER PART PEOPLE NEVER
TALK ABOUT.
A LOT OF GUYS CLOSE DOWN
IMMEDIATELY.
THAT QUARTERBACK'S OUT THE GATE
88.
THE BIG THING THAT I'M GOING TO
BE LOOKING FOR WATCHING HIM IS
HOW HE GETS USED.
DO YOU WANT HIM JUST COMING OFF
THE BALL?
OR IS HE A GUY THAT YOU'RE GOING
TO PLAY MORE DOWN SO HE CAN SET
THE EDGE AND BE A DEFENDER IN
THE RUN GAME.
I'M GOING TO GIVE IT AN A.
I LOVE THIS PICK.
I THINK IT'S GREAT THAT HE'S
VALUE FOR THEM AT THIS POINT.
AND THE BIG THING FOR ME AGAIN
IS YOU CAN LINE HIM UP.
WE SAW THEM LINE HIM UP,
STANDING UP.
OUTSIDE OF A TACKLE, HEAD UP ON
A TACKLE.
HE CAN DO A BUNCH OF DIFFERENT
THINGS.
APPRECIATE A GUY WHO'S WILLING
TO DO ALL THOSE THINGS.
HE'S SOMEONE WHO SAID I'LL DO
WHAT IT TAKES TO HELP HIGHMY PE
WIN.
THE JETS LEAVE WITH SAUCE
GARDNER, GARRETT WILSON AND
GERMANE JOHNSON.
AND WITH THAT EXCITEMENT, I CAN
ONLY IMAGINE WHAT THE JETS ROOM
IS LIKE TO PUT CONNOR ROGERS
INSIDE THE JETS ROOM.
LET'S SEE SOME OF THESE
COMMENTS.
>> WHAT AN EFFING DRAFT.
WOW, OUTSTANDING.
JD IS A GENIUS, MAN.
HAS ACTUAL PASS RUSH MOVES.
MAN.
HOW YOU FEELIN'?
>> IT'S AWESOME.
HONESTLY, NOT TO BE SELFISH FOR
A MOMENT.
>> YOU KNOW HOW MUCH I LOVE THIS
PLAYER.
TO BREAK THAT NEWS FOR ME WAS
THE COOLEST MOMENT I'VE HAD IN A
DRAFT, AND THANK YOU TO THE
PERSON THAT ALLOWED ME, I THINK
THEY KNEW.
YOU'RE IN LOVE WITH THIS PLAYER,
AND THIS IS THE TEAM THAT YOU, I
HAVE TO POST THE PICTURE
TOMORROW.
I'M LIKE A LITTLE KID WATCHING
THIS STUPID TEAM ON TV.
IT'S A COOL MOMENT.
>> I'M SO HAPPY.
>> GOOD NIGHT FOR US.
LOOK AT US.
>> SO THE JAGUARS JUST TRADED UP
WITH THE BUCKS, WHICH MAKES
SENSE.
SO THE JAGUARS ARE MOVING UP
FROM 33.
SO WHO COULD THEY WANT THAT THEY
HAD TO MOVE UP BACK INTO THE END
OF THE FIRST ROUND TO GET?
WHAT ARE WE THINKING?
>> MAN.
>> DETAILS FROM MY GUY JORDAN
SCHULTZ.
JAGUARS GET 27.
AND THE BUCS ARE GOING TO PICK
UP A LATE THIRD FOURTH HERE.
>> COULD IT BE FOR LEWIS SCENE?
ARE THEY TRYING TO GET MORE
ATHLETIC PLAYERS ON THE BACK
END?
>> I THINK IT COULD BE THE
LINEBACKER, BECAUSE LAVONTE.
>> THE JAGS TRADED UP.
>> I WAS THINKING ABOUT TAMPA
BAY, I GOT SO EXCITED.
>> SO THE JAGUARS.
>> I SAID BERNARD RAYMOND.
OFFENSIVE TACKLE.
>> BECAUSE THEY WENT WALKER WITH
THE FIRST PICK TO GET DN.
>> WE COMPLAINED ABOUT THEM NOT
PROTECT
PROTECTING TREVOR LAWRENCE.
>> I WAS RIGHT.
AND I WASN'T EVEN TALKING ABOUT
THE RIGHT TEAM.
DEVIN LLOYD.
THE JAGUARS LOST MILES JACK IN
THE OFF SEASON AND SAID WE NEED
AN ATHLETE THAT CAN ROAM.
AND DEVIN LLOYD IS THAT GUY,
6'3", 247 OUT OF UTAH.
TEAM CAPTAIN.
16 AND A HALF SACKS.
YOU WANT IT, HE GOT IT, AND HE
GOES TO JACKSONVILLE AT 27.
THEY TRADED UP TO GET HIM.
WHAT DO YOU THINK OF THE VALUE
THERE?
>> FREAKIN' AWESOME.
13th OVERALL PLAYER FOR A TEAM
THAT, I'VE HAD SOME QUESTIONS
ABOUT THEIR FREE AGENCY PERIOD.
THIS IS A BALL PLAYER, RIGHT,
THIS IS A THREE-DOWN PLAYER.
FELDER AND I DID A LITTLE
EXERCISE.
AND WHAT I LIKE ABOUT LLOYD IS
HE CAN RUN SIDELINE TO SIDELINE.
YOU SEE HIM ZONE DROP RIGHT
THERE AND READ THE BALL AND TAKE
IT BACK TO THE HOUSE FOR SIX.
HE'S THE KIND OF GUY WHO DOESN'T
THINK I'M OUT HERE TO MAKE
TACKLES AND MAKE PLAYS AND GET
OFF THE FIELD.
I'M THE KIND OF GUY, I MAKE
BIG-TIME PLAYS.
I AM GOING TO LIVE IN THE
BACKFIELD.
THIS WILL BLOW YOUR MIND.
YOU WATCH HIM WITH HIS HAND.
DON'T WORE EARRY ABOUT THE RUN.
HE'S ONE OF THE BEST PASS
RUSHERS IN THIS DRAFT.
HE CAN DO EVERYTHING.
JACKSONVILLE GOT A LITTLE BIT OF
PASS RUSH HELP HERE.
A BIG TIME MIDDLE OF THE DEFENSE
FOR US.
A PLUS FOR JACKSONVILLE, THIS IS
THE KIND OF PLAYERS YOU NEED
MORE OF, NOT HOME RUNS, BUT
TRIPLES, DOUBLES.
>> NOW I'M THINKING ABOUT HIM
AND LLOYD.
AND WE WERE THINKING ABOUT WHAT
KELCE WAS SAYING, BUT FOCUS ON
LLOYD HERE.
I FEEL LIKE YOU LOVE THEIRIS GU.
>> I REALLY DO.
WE DID THAT THOUGHT EXERCISE OF
DEAN VERSUS LLOYD.
AND HIS ABILITY OFF THE BALL
LINEBACKER, THIS GUY'S A
TRACKER.
HE'S GOING TO HUNT YOU DOWN.
HE'S GOING TO GET YOU DOWN ON
THE GROUND.
HE'S GOING TO FIND YOU.
HE DOESN'T GET CAUGHT UP IN THE
TRASH, WHICH I THINK IS AWESOME.
YOU SEE HIM, COLLISION, MAKE A
TACKLE IN THE HOLE.
THAT'S WHAT A LINEBACKER'S
SUPPOSED TO DO.
AND LOOK AT HIM.
SO I'M NOT GOING TO GO PLUS.
BECAUSE I STILL THINK DEAN'S
BETTER, BUT I AM GOING TO GO A.
>> WOO.
>> BECAUSE LLOYD'S A REALLY GOOD
PLAYER.
KELCE MENTIONED IT, CONNOR
MENTIONED IT, BUT THE ABILITY TO
TAKE THIS GUY ON THIRD AND 12
AND KICK WALKER DOWN FROM A RUSH
TO A THREE AND LET THIS GUY COME
FROM A FIVE OR SEVEN THAT GIVES
YOU A LOT OF SCHEME VERSATILITY
AND CAUSE PROBLEMS FOR OFFENSE.
>> AND IT IS GOING TO BE DEVIN
LLOYD WHO THEY SAY WATCHES AS
MUCH FILM AS ANYBODY AS WE'VE
EVER HAD EVER.
NOW YOU THINK ABOUT THE WEAPONS
THAT THEY HAVE IN THAT FRONT
SEVEN.
JOSH ALLEN THEY HAVE.
TRAVON WALKER THEY HAVE.
DEVIN LLOYD THOUGH V HAVE.
THEY HAVE LITTLE PIECES WHERE I
STILL THINK WE'RE GOING, WHEN
ARE YOU GOING TO HELP OUT YOUR
FIRST PICK IN THE DRAFT, TREVOR
LAWRENCE.
>> I THINK THEY FEEL HIKELIKE T
SPENT A LOT OF MONEY.
WHETHER PEOPLE AGREE WITH IT OR
NOT, THESE ARE THE PLAYERS THEY
THINK ARE THE BEST AVAILABLE.
>> NOW WE'RE SITTING HERE, AND
THE TEAM THAT SHOCKED OUR FACES
IS BACK ON.
>> QUAY WALKER EARLIER ON.
THE PACKERS ARE SITTING HERE,
AND I'M JUST GOING, THERE'S NO
WAY THEY'RE GOING TO DRAFT
ANOTHER DEFENSIVE PLAYER, IS
THERE?
THERE'S NO WAY THAT THEY TRADE
DEVONTAE ADAMS AND DON'T TAKE
ANOTHER OFFENSIVE PLAYER.
COULD WE GET A WIDE RECEIVER IN
A SKYY MOORE?
PICKENS?
IN CHRISTIAN.
OUT OF NORTH DAKOTA STATE.
WHAT ARE WE THINKING HERE?
CHRISTIAN WATSON.
>> IT'S GREEN BAY, SO PUT ON --
>> THEY'RE NOT GOING TO DO
GEORGE CAR LOFTIS, ARE THEY?
>> I'M GOING TO SAY --
>> MATT ARHESA.
>> THE ONE THAT WOULD MAKE NO
SENSE WOULD BE MALIK WILLIS.
THE ONE THAT WOULD BE A LOT OF
NO SENSE WOULD BE NAKOBE DEAN.
>> THEY WOULD CONSIDER DEVONTAE
WHITE, TREVOR JONES.
>> WHAT'S THEIR TIGHT END
SITUATION LIKE?
>> THEY'RE WAITING FOR THE DUDE
TO RECOVER FROM LEG INJURY.
DON'T SHOW IT.
OH, YOU'RE SHOWING IT.
DEVONTE WYATT.
THERE YOU GO.
>> AARON RODGERS MUST BE LOSING
HIS MIND RIGHT NOW.
>> YEAH, OF COURSE.
>> AFTER TRADING DEVONTAE ADAM,
WE ALL THOUGHT, WELL, THE
PACKERS ARE GOING TO FIND
THEMSELF AS WIDE RECEIVER WITH
TWO PICKS IN THE 20s, BUT NO,
THEY FELL IN WHO HAVELOVE WITH
DEFENSIVE PLAYERS FROM GEORGIA.
NOW THEY'RE GOING DEVONTE WYATT
OUT OF GEORGIA, AN ABSOLUTE
MAULER DOWN THERE ON THE D-LINE.
WHERE DID YOU EXPECT THIS GUY TO
GO?
>> RIGHT AROUND HIRE ISERE IS W
WOULD GO.
YOU SEE HIM RIGHT THERE.
HE CAN PLAY, YOU CAN KICK HIM
ALL OVER THE OFFENSIVE LINE.
REMINDED ME OF DE-RON PAYNE.
THERE'S NO DEVELOPING OR, HE'S
REALLY WELL-ROUNDED.
CAN HE RUSH THE PASSER, STOP THE
RUN, HE CAN HOLD THE POINT OF
ATTACK.
HE PLAYS VERY, VERY HARD,
OBVIOUSLY, DOWN AFTER DOWN.
THERE'S NOT A GEORGIA DEFENDER
THAT DID NOT GIVE YOU 120% EVERY
SINGLE SNAP.
>> I DID WRITE THIS AS A NEED
FOR THE PACKERS.
AND THEN MAYBE DEVONTAE WHITE OR
SOMEONE LIKE THAT, THEIR PLAN AS
A WHOLE HAS ME WONDERING WHAT IS
GOING ON HERE FOR AARON RODGERS.
BUT AT THE END OF THE DAY, WHEN
YOU LIKE THE PLAYER, IT'S A
B-PLUS
>> THIS IS A RUN DEFENSE THAT
WAS ABYSMAL.
60% OF THE TIME YOU CONVERTED.
SO THEY DID NEED THIS GUY.
AND I KNOW THAT I WAS GETTING
EXCITED ABOUT JORDAN DAVIS.
>> HE'S NOT THE SAME BIG
PACKAGE, THE SAME KIND OF LIKE
OH, MY GOODNESS.
BUT WHEN I LOOK AT WHAT HE DOES,
HE AS TRULY A GUY THAT'S NOT AN
EXPERIMENT, IF HE CAN PLAY FROM
A ZERO TO A FOUR.
THIS IS A GUY THAT WE'VE SEEN
PLAY FROM A ZERO TO A FOUR.
LIKE YOU, CONNOR, I STILL DON'T
UNDERSTAND HOW YOU THINK THIS IS
GOING TO BE THE THING THAT GETS
YOU TO THE SUPER BOWL.
>> RIGHT.
>> IF YOU'RE NOT GOING TO HELP
AREA RODGERS.
>> LET'S GO TO KELCE.
DENNY WYATT SURROUNDED BY
PRESTON SMITH.
THIS KID, DEVONTAE WYATT, WHAT
DO YOU THINK?
>> HE'S GOT GREAT SUDDENNESS,
QUICKNESS.
BUT MORE THAN ANYTHING, YOU CAN
TELL HE'S SMART, SAVVY.
HE FIND AS WAY TO GET THROUGH
THE GAP, A WAY TO BEAT PEOPLE,
WHETHER IT'S IN THE RUN OR THE
PASS.
THIS KID IS, THERE'S SOMETHING
THAT'S UNIQUE ABOUT THIS GUY.
DaRON PAYNE WAS PRETTY GOOD.
HE JUST DOESN'T STOP.
LOOK AT THAT.
HE'S FIGHTING THROUGH THAT.
HE'S A REALLY GOOD PLAYER.
>> HE FINDS A WAY TO DIP THAT
SHOULDER AND REALLY SLASH IN
THERE.
I'M JUST CURIOUS, JASON BEFORE
WE LET YOU GO, WHAT DO YOU THINK
A
AARON RODGERS IS THINKING RIGHT
NOW IN.
>> WELL, I'M SURE HE'S PROBABLY
NOT TOO HAPPY.
HE'S SO GOOD THAT HE PROBABLY
THINKS NO MATTER WHAT HE'S GOING
TO BE ABLE TO GO OUT THERE AND
PERFORM.
>> NOT OUR PROBLEM, RIGHT,
JASON?
SLO
LOOK AT US.
>> THANK YOU, JASON KELCE.
>> ONE THING TO WRAP IT UP.
WHAT DOES DEVONTAE SWWHITE DO.
>> WHETHER N I THINK OF THE BAC
STOKES.
THAT'S A HECK OF A DEFENSE.
>> AARON RODGERS IS NOT GOING TO
BE HAPPY.
>> NO, BECAUSE HE HAS LASAR AND
C
COBB AND WATKINS.
>> THE PATRIOTS ALWAYS TAKE A
GUY THAT WE'RE NOT EXPECTING.
NOW I'LL JUST SAY THIS.
NAKOBE DEAN IS ON THE CLORCK.
CLEARLY THAT'S NOT WHO IT IS.
>> KID OUT OF CONNECTICUT.
>> YOU AREN'T GETTING THIS ONE.
>> I WANT TO TAKE A LOOK AT
YOURS.
CAN I GET OFFENSE OR DEFENSE?
>> OFFENSE.
>> IT STINKS, BECAUSE ONCE AGAIN
I LOVE THIS GUY.
>> THE ONE THAT JUST POPPED UP
WAS GREG DOLLAR CHICH.
>> IT'S NOT HIM.
>> CADE AUSTIN?
>> IT'S NOT A TIGHT END.
>> THAT'S STRANGE.
WOW.
>> OKAY.
>> SO THE NEW ENGLAND PATRIOTS
GO TO TENNESSEE CHATTANOOGA FOR
6'5", 307, COLE STRANGE.
>> YOU WANT TO HEAR SOMETHING
FUNNY, THOUGH?
>> I WANT YOU TO TELL ME ALL THE
THINGS.
>> IT ALWAYS HAPPENS EVERY YEAR,
JOE TOONY LIGHT.
LIKE YOU COULD SEE THE SMALL
SCHOOL PRODUCT, THE MOVEMENT,
THE INTERIOR ZONE BLOCKING ON
THE MOVE.
OBVIOUSLY, A TOUGH PLAYER.
WHEN HE PLAYED TENNESSEE AND
KENTUCKY, I WAS VERY IMPRESSED
AGAINST THAT LEVEL OF
COMPETITION, AGAINST KENTUCKY,
HE'S REALLY MOVED PEOPLE OUT OF
THE WAY.
HE'S AN ELITE ATHLETE.
I CAN'T EMPHASIZE THAT ENOUGH
WITH COLE STRANGE.
YOU TALK ABOUT A 9-9-5 RELATIVE
ATHLETIC SCORE.
THAT'S ELITE.
HE'S ONE OF THE BEST-TESTING
CENTERS OF ALL TIME.
>> 42 STARTS AT LEFT GUARD.
A LEFT TACKLE CENTER, FIRST-TEAM
ALL AMERICAN, TEAM CAPTAIN WITH
A 3.71 GPA AND AN ACADEMIC ALL
CONFERENCE, BUT THIS IS WHERE IT
GETS CRAZY.
ALL SIX YEARS?
HOW --
>> BONUS YEAR.
>> THIS MAN IS EXPERIENCED.
THE VERSATILITY.
>> NOW THAT'S A QUOTE.
THIS PLAMAN IS EXPERIENCED.
>> THE FACT THAT HE GOES TO THE
PATRIOTS, THOUGH, OH, HE'LL BE
GREAT.
>> I LIKE CAM JURGENS BETTER.
LYNN T
LINDERBAUM'S GONE.
ELITE ATHLETICISM, FITS WHAT
THEY WANT TO DO.
JOE TOONEY LIGHT.
IN HE'S 23, GOING ON 24.
>> HE'S AN OLDER PLAYER.
I LOOK AT THIS AND THINK THAT,
MAN, I THINK EVERYBODY THOUGHT
HE WAS GOING IN THE THIRD ROUND.
HE'S GOING TO BE A GOOD PLAYER,
SO YOU DON'T KILL THE PICK,
RIGHT?
I CAN'T EMPHASIZE THAT ENOUGH.
BUT DO YOU CARE ABOUT THE DRAFT
BOARD?
THAT'S NOT GOOD.
THAT'S A PROBLEM.
>> SO I WOULD IMAGINE THAT HE
SLIDES IN AT RIGHT GUARD RIGHT
NEXT TO JAMES FARENSZ.
WHAT WAS YOUR GRADE FOR THIS?
>> MY GRADE FOR THIS IS A
C-PLUS.
BECAUSE ONCE AGAIN, HE'S NOT A
BAD PLAYER, AND HE FITS WHAT
THEY WANT TO DO.
THIS IS NOT THE PLAYER YOU TAKE
IN THE FIRST ROUND.
THE VALUE DOESN'T CHECK OUT.
HE'S NOT GOING TO MAKE THAT
LEVEL FOR YOU.
I LIKE THAT THEY'RE INVESTING IN
OFFENSIVE LINE, BUT OVERALL,
THIS IS A REACH.
>> THEY LOST TED CARE RIS.
HOW MUCH OF A FAN ARE YOU OF
COLE STRANGE?
>> I LIKE IT.
YOU MENTIONED THE ATHLETICISM.
HE WAS DOMINANT AT HIS LEVEL.
AND HE DIDN'T HAVE THE
PENALTIES.
HE DOESN'T HAVE THE SETTING
PROBLEMS OR THE GRABBING
PROBLEMS THAT WE TALKED ABOUT
WITH PLAYERS COMING OUT.
>> TOOK 12 YEARS TO FIGURE IT
OUT.
>> LISTEN.
LET ME TELL YOU GUYS SOMETHING.
TRYING TO TRACK THE BONUS COVID
YEAR PLAYERS HAS NOT BEEN, GIVE
US A BREAK HERE.
HE'S A GOOD PLAYER.
FOR ME, I'M GOING TO GO B-MINUS.
BECAUSE I'M THINKING WE'RE NOT
WORRIED ABOUT THEM GETTING A
CENTER.
THEY'RE WORRIED ABOUT HOW HE
FITS WITHIN A GUARD, AND
ULTIMATELY, THEY MAY HAVE END UP
DRAFTING A GUY THAT GROWS INTO A
BIG-TIME CENTER FOR THEM IN THE
NEXT FEW SEASONS.
>> HE IS NOW THE FIRST TENNESSEE
CHATTANOOGA PLAYER SINCE TERRELL
OWENS TO BE DRAFTED IN THE TOP
FIVE ROUNDS.
MR. KELCE, YOU'VE WATCH ADD
VIDEO OF COLE STRANGE.
WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT HIM
JOINING BILL BELICHICK AND THE
PATRIOTS?
>> THOUGH IIS IS SUCH A PATRIOT
PICK.
SUPER OLD SCHOOL PLAYER ALMOST.
HE FINISHES EXTRA HARD.
AND THERE'S JUST LIKE A
NASTINESS AND GRIT TO HIM.
I LOVE WATCHING HIS TAPE.
HE'S A FEW WHO'S BEEN CLIMBING
AS PEOPLE WATCH MORE OF HIM, AND
I THINK HE'S GOING TO FIT IN SO
WELL IN NEW ENGLAND.
LOOK AT THIS.
HE'S A NASTY, DIRTY MAPLAYER.
I LIKE HIS TAPE.
I REALLY DO.
>> COLE STRANGE OUT OF TENNESSEE
CHATTANOOGA.
WE ARE NOW UP TO KANSAS CITY.
THEY'RE STILL ON NEW ENGLAND.
CONNOR HAS ALREADY CHEATED.
THEY TRADED UP EARLIER AND GOT
TRENT McDUFFIE.
WE WORRIED THAT THE PATRIOTS
WERE GOING TO STEAL THE CHIEFS'
PICK.
I HAVE A FEELING THEY WERE NOT
GOING TO GO AFTER COLE STRANGE.
THEY NEEDED WIDE RECEIVER, AND
THEY NEED AN EDGE.
SO THE QUESTION IS, IS IT AN
EDGE OR WIDE RECEIVER HOSPITAL
ARE YOU GOING WITH?
>> I'M GOING DAVID YOE JAW BOW.
>> I LIKE THAT PICK.
I THINK IT'S GOING TO BE YOE
VIEW VOE OR CAR LAUF TIS.
BUT THEY'VE BEEN MOCKED A LOT AT
TAKING CHRISTIAN WATSON.
I'M GOING CHRISTIAN WATSON.
SHOULD HAVE GONE CAR LOFTIS.
>> SOMEONE'S TEXTING ME THE
PICKS AS THEY ROLL INTO THE
PACK.
>> THEY ARE GOING GEORGE CAR
LOFTIS.
AND JUST LIKE THAT, GEORGE CAR
LOFTIS, SECOND TEAM ALL
AMERICAN, 30 AND A HALF TACKLES.
HE'S TRAINING.
HIS NUTRITION ARE INSANE.
AND LIVES IN THE BUILDING.
TO GET HIM HERE AT 30, CONNOR,
THOUGHTS.
>> GOOD VALUE.
I HAD HIM AS THE 28th BEST
PLAYER IN THE DRAFT.
OBVIOUSLY THE EFFORT IS OFF THE
CHARTS.
IS HE THE MOST TWITCHED UP
PLAYER OR SHORT AREA QUICKNESS,
SUPER FAST CLOSING SPEED, I
DON'TLY
DON'T THINK HE'S THAT.
YOU'RE LOOKING AT MAYBE AN
EIGHEI
EIGHT-SACK PLAYER.
HE HAS A REALLY INTERESTING
BACKGROUND COMING FROM OVERSEAS
WHERE HE GREW UP PLAYING WATER
POLO AND ATTRIBUTES THE LEG
STRENGTH TO THAT.
HE HAS A REALLY GOOD BASE.
AND FOR THE CHIEFS, THIS IS THE
KIND OF PASS RUSHER.
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO SWING FOR
THE FENCES.
THIS IS A HIGH FLOOR PLAYER THAT
GIVES YOU UPSIDE BEGINS THE RUN.
>> AND GOING TO PLAY IN THE
BILLS.
>> I LIKE THIS PICK.
IT'S A SOLID B-PLUS.
HE'S A PRO -READY PLAYER.
YOU'VE SEEN THE COMPARISON TO
TREY FLOWERS.
>> I LOVE THE PICK.
I LOVE CARLOFTIS.
WE GUSH SO MUCH, WE CREATED THIS
NEW POSITION THAT'S NOT EVEN
REALLY POSITION OF AGE, RIGHT?
WENT FROM HYBRID LINEBACKER AND
NOW WE JUST LUMP THEM ALL
TOGETHER AS EDGE.
CARLOFTIS IS A DEFENSIVE END.
AND I LIKE THAT ABOUT HIM.
I'M GOING TO GO WITH AN A-MINUS.
I LIKE THE FACT THAT THEY
DRAFTED A TRUE DEFENSIVE END,
SOMEONE WHO'S GOING TO COME IN,
SET THE EDGE HARD AND THEN
SQUEEZE DOWN TO GET TO THE
QUARTERBACK.
HE'S NOT GOING TO RUN AROUND
YOU.
HE'S GOING TO SQUEEZE DOWN TO
GET TO THE QUARTERBACK.
THAT'S IMPORTANT, BECAUSE IT'S
GOING TO BRING TOUGHNESS TO A
KANSAS CITY TEAM THAT A LOT OF
PEOPLE VIEW BECAUSE OF THEIR
OFFENSE AS A FINESSE TEAM.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
AND I WANT TO ADD TO THAT.
WHAT KANSAS CITY TRIED TO DO
LAST YEAR BECAUSE THEY COULDN'T
GET A PASS RUSH WAS MOVE CHRIS
JONES DEFENSIVE END.
THEY BECAME OFF AGAINST THE RUN.
NOW YOU GET TO PLAY CHRIS JONES
AT HIS NATURAL POSITION.
AND YOU GET TO PARTNER UP FRANK
CLARK AND CARLOFTIS.
BOTH GUYS THAT CAN PLAY THE RUN.
NOW SUDDENLY, THE CHIEFS HAVE
DEPTH ON THEIR D-LINE.
SO FAR, VEACH ATTACKING DEFENSE.
OUR DRAFT COVERAGE IS BROUGHT TO
YOU BY ROCKET MORTGAGE.
HOW DO I KNOW?
THERE ARE WORDS UNDERNEATH THE
SCREEN ON THE COUNTER THAT TELL
ME SO.
IF YOU ARE LOOKING FOR AN EDGE
IN THE BUYING MARKET, DON'T CALL
YOUR COUSIN CHERYL WHO HAS
CONNECTIONS.
YOU GOT TO GO TO ROCKET
MORTGAGE.
CHERYL CAN BARELY USE FACEBOOK.
THEY CAN HELP YOU COMPOTEETE IN
CROWDED MARKET.
CONNOR'S BIG BOARD OF WHO IS
LEFT.
I FEEL LIKE YOUR FAVORITE PLAYER
IS DAX HILL.
>> HE IS.
IT JUST MAKES SENSE.
HE'S DREAM CHESS COVERAGE PIECE
FOR DEFENSIVE COORDINATOR.
ANYTHING YOU ASK OF HIM.
THE ATHLETICISM AND SIZE, HE
COULD PLAY CORNER ON THE
OUTSIDE.
HE'S SO GOOD IN THE SLOT AND AT
TRADITIONAL FREE SAFETY, THAT'S
WHERE HE'S PLAYED.
>> WE'VE SEEN HIM DO IT.
WE'VE SEEN HIM DO ALL THOSE
THINGS.
WE'VE SEEN HIM LIGHT UP AS A
NICKEL, HE CAN DO ALL THOSE
THINGS.
>> IT'S INTERESTING THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT HIM.
DID YOU GET THE PICK?
>> NO.
>> IT'S DONE.
CINCINNATI BENGALS ARE ON THE
CLOCK.
LOST IN THE SUPER BOWL TO THE
L.A. RAMS, HAD A PHENOMENAL
YEAR.
THEY TOOK OUR GUY JAMAR CHASE
OVER PENNE SOOL.
WHO WOULD YOU GIVE THEM?
>> I THOUGHT THE SAME AS YOU
THAT THINK DIDN'T GO ONE MORE
OFFENSIVE LINE.
BUT THE PREMIUM PLAYERS ARE
GONE.
SOMEBODY I TALKED TO CLOSE TO
CINCINNATI SAID THEY WANT TO
THINK ABOUT THE NEXT THREE YEARS
IN THE SECONDARY.
>> JESS IE BATES IS UPSET.
COULD IT BE LEWIS SCENE?
>> I THINK BRISKERS BRINGS A TON
OF VERSATILITY, NOT IN THE SAME
WAY AS DAX HILL.
>> LET'S HEAR YOUR GUESSES.
FELDER, YOU'RE FIRST.
>> I MEAN.
>> DON'T SHOW IT!
AH, CRAP, DAX TON HILL.
>> YOU LOVE THIS PICK.
>> IT'S A PHENOMENAL PICK.
PHENOMENAL, PHENOMENAL.
WHO ARE THEY RUNNING INTO?
>> KANSAS CITY CHIEF, BUFFALO
BILLS.
>> YOU GOT TO BE ABLE TO LINE UP
THE FIELD AND RUN THESE GUYS AND
MAKE PLAYS ON THE FOOTBALL.
THAT'S WHAT HE DOES.
SLOT, TWO HIGH, SINGLE HIGH.
THIS IS A BLAST, TAKE IT AWAY.
>> THE CINCINNATI BENGALS WENT
OUT AND GOT A FIRST-TEAM ALL BIG
TEN SAFETY IN DAX HILL.
HAS LED THE WOLVERINES IN
INTERCEPTIONS LAST YEAR, THE
NUMBER ONE SAFETY RECRUITING IN
HIS CLASS.
AND JUSTICE HILL, THE RUNNING
BACK TAKEN BY THE RAVENS WHO WAS
A SPARK ATHLETE, THIS IS HIS
YOUNGER BROTHER, AND THIS IS A
BENGALS TEAM THAT LOVES TO
INVEST IN SAFETIES.
YOU LOVE THIS GUY.
>> I LOVE IN GUY.
FIRST OFF, ELITE.
95th PERCENTILE.
6-5-7.
CHANGES DIRECTION, 97
PERCENTILE.
THIS IS A DREAM COVERAGE PIECE
FOR THAT SECONDARY WHERE HE CAN
PLAY IN THE SLOT.
I REALLY THINK HE CAN PLAY
CORNER IF YOU ASK HIM TO.
THEY DESERVE ALL THE PRAISE IN
THE WORLD.
WHEN YOU WATCH THE TV TAPE,
THOSE ARE THE GUYS WHO GET ALL
THE ACTION.
WHO'S THE GUY IN THE BACK END
WHO'S MAKING LIFE HELL FOR THE
OPPOSITION?
IT'S DAXTON HILL.
HE REMIND THE ME OF MALCOLM
JENKINS.
I'M NOT THROWING OUT THESE CRAZY
COMPS, THIS IS ONE I FEEL
COMFORTABLE.
HE'S WORTH IT.
HE'S AN A-PLUS PICK FOR ME FOR A
TEAM THAT EVEN I HAD MY TIMES
LIKE HOW ARE THEY GOING TO GET
BACK THERE.
WHAT THEY'VE DONE IN FREE AGENCY
AND NOW IN THE FIRST ROUND,
PHENOMENAL FOR THE BENGALS.
>> I LOVE THIS SWISS ARMY KNIFE
CAPABILITY.
A GUY THAT WE'VE SEEN.
WHEN MICHIGAN WENT TO THAT BEAR
FRONT.
DAXTON HILL IS THE GUY THEY PUT.
THIS IS A GUY THAT CAN PLAY ALT
MAN, IN THAT ZONE, INTERCEPTION
AGAINST WISCONSIN.
THAT'S HIM PLAYING IN THE
NICKEL.
SLIDING OUT TO SYNCH UP IN
COVERAGE.
HE'S PLAYED AS A NICKEL,
SINGLE-HIGH SAFETY.
A GUY THAT CAN GET OFF THE HASH
AND COVER TWO AS WELL AS HE CAN
PLAY IN THE MIDDLE OF THE FIELD
AND BEAT TYOU TO THE SIDELINE.
I'M GOING A-PLUS.
WATCHING HIM PLAY IS A TREAT
WHEN YOU POP IN HIS TAPE.
>> I THINK IT'S A GREAT FIT.
IN THE SUPER BOWL LAST YEAR, YOU
SAW THE SECONDARY PLAY WELL, BUT
AT THE CORNER SPOT, ELI APPLE
STRUGGLED, AND THEY DIDN'T HAVE
AN ANSWER FOR IT.
THEY DIDN'T HAVE ANYBODY THAT
COULD GO IN THERE HAN AND CHANGE
DYNAMIC.
THEY HAVE A GUY THAT CAN GO IN
THERE AND IT MAKES THEM A LOT
MORE INTERCHANGEABLE IN TERMS OF
WHO'S GOING TO BE IN THE BOX.
WHO'S BLITZING.
I THINK IT JUST GIVES THEM A LOT
OF FLEXIBILITY.
AND THAT'S WHAT THEY NEED.
IF HE THEHAS TO GO TO CORNER,
THAT'S AWESOME.
HIS VERSATILITY IS GOING TO MAKE
HIM REALLY COOL AND A REALLY
IMPORTANT PIECE OF THAT DEFENSE
EARLY ON, AND MAYBE IF JESSE
BATES CAN'T GET A DEAL THEY MOVE
HIM BACK TO SAFETY.
>> RICHARD SHERMAN, THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
THE PICK, DAX HILL FOR THE
CINCINNATI BENGALS.
CHECKING IN ON OUR LITTLE SOCIAL
MEDIA BOARD, GOING OVER THE
PICKS.
DAX HILL.
MAN, SOME INTERESTING NAMES
HERE, BUT JUST LIKE THEIS, WE AE
DOWN TO THE VIKINGS AT 32,
BECAUSE THEY TRADED BACK
EARLIER, AND I'M LOOKING AT THE
NAMES STILL ON THE BOARD, AND
THE ONE STICKING OUT TO ME IS
MALIK WILLIS.
AND THERE WAS SOME TEAM THAT WAS
TRADING UP TO PICK 32, TO LOCK
IN A QUARTERBACK TO THAT
FIFTH-YEAR OPTION.
SO WE COULD BE WAITING FOR A
TRADE.
I'M SURE THAT -- AND YOU KNOW
WHAT'S INTERESTING?
IT'S A BRAND NEW GM.
IN MINNESOTA.
>> YEAH, YOU LEARN A LOT.
>> I'M ALWAYS CURIOUS WITH WHAT
KINDS OF CONNECTIONS DO DOES A
NEW GM HAVE TO MAKE THESE CALLS.
APPARENTLY THE PICK IS IN.
DON'T REVEAL IT.
WHO DO WE THINK THEY'RE GOING
WITH, MINNESOTA VIKINGS?
THEY DIDN'T MAKE A PICK, THEY
HAD 12.
I FORGOT, THEY TRADED WITH THEIR
INTERDIVISION RIVAL, THE LIONS,
WHO DO WE THINK THE VIKINGS DO
LEER?
A LOT OF TURNOVER AT CORNER.
THEY NEEDED A BIG DEFENSIVE
LINEMAN.
I'M GOING TO GO WITH TRAVIS
JONES OUT OF CONNECTICUT.
>> THAT'S A GOOD ONE.
LET ME DOUBLE CHECK.
>> I LOOK AT TWO OF MY BEST
PLAYERS AVAILABLE.
DAVID YOE JAW BOW.
YOU HAVE TWO EDGE PASS RUSHERS.
I LIKE THAT PICK, AND THEN I GO
TO THE TALENT HERE.
I LOOK AT LEWIS SCENE STILL ON
THE BOARD.
I'VE HEARD FOR WEEKS HE'S NOT
MAKING IT OUT OF THE FIRST
ROUND.
I'D BE SURPRISED IF HE DOES, BUT
NOW WE'RE IN CRUNCH TIME.
>> I'M GOING TO IF CORNER.
I'M GOING TO GO ANDREW BOOTH.
>> INTERESTING.
ZIMMER'S NOT THERE.
THAT WOULD HAVE BEEN A ZIMMER
PICK FOR SURE.
LET'S SEE, THE MINNESOTA VIKING,
THEY'RE JUST DOING THE BENGALS
PICK ON TV.
WE DON'T DO THAT IS CORRECT
BECTHAT.
BECAUSE THEY SLOW.
THIS IS THE INTERNET.
THEY FILL HIM WITH A SAFETY.
SECOND TEAM ALL SEC.
KIRBY SMART SAID, WHEN YOU
DESIGN A SAFETY, HE'S GOT ALL
THE QUALITIES, AND HE IS A
STUDENT OF THE GAME.
LEWIS SCENE, 6'2", ABOUT 200,
WILL NOW BE COMPARED WITH
HARRISON SMITH FOR THE MINNESOTA
VIKINGS.
I IMAGINE THE VALUE IS
TREMENDOUS.
>> DYNAMIC ATHLETE, JUST NOT THE
WAY HE TESTED BUT THE WAY HE
PLAYS.
THAT 133 BROAD IS AN ELITE
METRIC.
HE'S A TRAIN COMING DOWN THE
TRACKS THAT CAN MAKE THE HIT.
YOU AND I HAVE WATCHED THIS PLAY
A LOT OF TIMES.
IT GOES TO SHOW WHAT YOU'S GOING
ON UP TOP.
PEOPLE HAVE MISSED HOW
INTELLIGENT HE IS, AND HE WAS
THE GUY IN THE BACK END OF THE
GEORGIA DEFENSE GETTING
EVERYBODY LINED UP, MAKING
PLAYS.
HE DOES HAVE PBALL SKILLS, BUT
THE NAME OF HIS GAME IS THE HIT
STICK.
HE'S TERRIFYING.
YOU DON'T WANT TO SEE HIM COMING
DOWNHILL AT YOU.
IF YOU'RE RUNNING THE SCENE, YOU
BETTER HOLD ONTO THAT BALL FOR
DEAR LIFE.
A TOP 25 PLAYER FOR ME, THE KIND
OF ATHLETE YOU BET ON IN THE
FIRST ROUND.
THE KIND OF TAPE YOU BET ON IN
THE FIRST ROUND.
I LIKE IT FOR MINNESOTA.
THIS IS AN A FOR ME FOR
MINNESOTA.
WE'RE GOING TO LEARN A NEW
REGIME.
NOT A FOUNDATION PLAYER.
I DON'T THRKNOW IF YOU SAY THATR
EVERY SINGLE PICK.
>> HE WILL MAKE YOU PAY.
HE DOES NOT WANT TO GET UP OFF
THE GROUND.
HE'S A HEAT-SEEKING MISSILE THAT
JUST WANTS TO COME DOWN AND
REALLY WREAK HAVOC ON PEOPLE.
HE IS GOOD IN PASS COVERAGE, AND
I LOVE THE PLAY THAT WE SHOWED
AGAINST TENNESSEE.
NAKOBE DEAN IS ON THAT PLAY.
AND SCENE'S LIKE, DON'T WORRY, I
WILL ERASE THIS MISTAKE FOR YOU.
BUT I ALSO LIKE SCENE CALL
THINGS OUT, GET GUYS IN THE
RIGHT POSITION.
HE WAS A LEADER IN THE FIELD.
THAT'S SO IMPORTANT WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT THESE GUYS, HE'S CLEARLY A
STUDENT OF THE GAME.
I'M GOING A-PLUS.
BECAUSE YOU ARE GETTING SOMEONE
WHO IS TRULY CAPABLE OF MAKING
PLAYS IN EVERY FACET OF THE GAME
AND GETTING HIM AT THE END OF
THE FIRST ROUND WHEN PLAYERS
THAT ARE NOT AS GOOD AS HIM HAVE
ALREADY GONE OFF THE BOARD.
>> ALL RIGHT, MINNESOTA VIKINGS
TAKING LEWIS SCENE.
RICHARD SHERMAN, YOU'VE PLAYED
WITH SOME GREAT SAFETIES IN YOUR
CAREER, WHAT DO YOU THINK WHEN
YOU WATCH LEWIS SCENE OUT OF
GEORGIA.
>> I LOVE IT.
I LOVE IT.
OBVIOUSLY WAS THE MVP OF THE
NATIONAL CHAMPIONSHIP, MINNESOTA
HAS THE 28th-RANKED PASS DEFENSE
LAST YEAR.
THAT'S NOT REALLY HOW THAT
DEFENSE WORKS.
USUALLY THEY'RE AMONGST THE TOP
TEN.
HARRISON SMITH HAS BEEN THIS
THAT SYSTEM FOR A LONG TIME.
I EXPECT LEWIS SCENE TO FIT
RIGHT IN.
THEY'RE DISCIPLINED.
ED DONAFEL HAS JUST BEEN HIRED.
I THINK HE'S GOING TO BE A PLUG
'N PLAY FIT FOR THEM.
HE PLAYS AGGRESSIVE.
HE MAY NEED TO PUT ON A FEW
POUNDS JUST TO BE ABLE TO GET
WITH THE ROUGH, RUGGED NFL, AND
THE THINGS HE'S GOING TO HAVE TO
DEAL WITH, WEEK IN AND WEEK OUT,
BUT I THINK IT'S GOING TO BE A
GREAT FIT.
>> LEWIS SCENE, THE SAFETY OUT
OF GEORGIA GOING TO MOINNESOTA.
BEFORE WE WRAP UP, WE HAVE A
MESSAGE FROM ROCKET MORTGAGE,
CORRECT?
WHY DON'T WE LISTEN TO THE
PEOPLE AT ROCKET MORTGAGE AND
BREAK DOWN OUR FAVORITE PICKS,
OUR BIG WINNERS FROM ROUND ONE.
FIRST THIS
>>> ALL RIGHT, TWO TWEETS.
THE FIRST ONE FROM LAMAR
JACKSON.
I THINK THAT MEANS WE THE FORCE.
NO, IT DOESN'T.
IT MEANS WHAT THE EFF.
WISH I COULD HAVE PLAYED WITH MY
BROTHER FOREVER.
BUT I'M GOING TO SEE YOU AT THE
TOP.
AND LIKE YOU SAID, HE REALIZED,
MAN, I GET TO PLAY WITH KYLER
MURRAY.
I KNOW HIM REALLY WELL.
BUT, MAN, VERY, VERY
INTERESTING.
WHAT HAPPENED THERE.
SO WE WERE WONDERING, WERE WE
GOING TO SEE SOME WIDE RECEIVER
TRADES, DEE BOW SAMUEL GOING TO
GET MOVED?
WE DID SEE TWO IMPENDING FRIDAY
AGENTS GET TRADED, ONE IN
HOLLYWOOD BROWN, ONE IN DE-E BO
SAMUEL.
WE SAW SIX GO IN THE TOP 18.
WE ONLY SAW ONE QUARTERBACK
DRAFTED IN KENNY PICKETT, MALIK
WILLIS NOT DRAFTED.
AND I THINK OVERALL, WE DIDN'T
REALLY KNOW WHAT WAS GOING TO
HAPPEN AT ANY TIME.
>> NO.
>> I THINK THAT THERE WERE A FEW
REACHES.
QUAY WALKER STANDS OUT AT 22 TO
THE GREEN BAY PACKERS.
PENNING AT 19 TO THE SAINTS, BUT
THAT WAS MAINLY BECAUSE THE
OFFENSIVE LINE RUN.
>> WE WERE READY NOR THFOR THAT.
>> LET'S DO OUR BIG WINNERS.
SO CONNOR, WOULD YOU LIKE TO
LEAD US OFF SNR?
ARE YOU READY?
>> I'D LIKE TO DIGEST
EVERYTHING.
>> WE CAN TALK IT OUT.
>> I'M NOT GOING TO TAKE THE
JETS.
>> I WAS GOING TO GIVE YOU THE
SGR
>> WHY DON'T YOU DO THE JETS?
>> YOU LOOK AT THE JETS.
OBVIOUSLY, IT STARTS OUT, FWLAUS
BECAUSE THIS IS A ROLLERCOASTER.
THEY PICK SAUCE GARDNER.
FEELS GOOD, AND YOU GET HIM BUT
YOU'RE STILL LIKE WE DIDN'T
ADDRESS THE THING WE WANTED TO
ADDRESS.
DON'T WORRY, YOU'RE GOING TO
COME DOWN HERE AT TEN AND GET
WILSON.
SO WE GOT GARRETT WILSON.
WE WERE ABLE TO ADDRESS THE WIDE
RECEIVER SPOT.
OKAY.
THAT FEELS GOOD.
>> OH, NO, WE MISSED OUT ON AN
EDGE RUSHER.
>> MISSED OUT ON AN EDGE RUSHER.
DON'T WORRY, PICK 26.
JERMAINE JOHNSON.
>> WE WERE ABLE TO GET THESE
GUYS.
THEY GOT ALL THE GUYS THEY WANT.
>> THREE POSSIBLE TOP TEN PICKS.
>> THE ONLY THING THAT WOULD
HAVE BEEN EVEN MORE IS IF THEY
HAD BEEN ABLE TO GET ONE OF
THOSE TOP THREE OFFENSIVE
LINEMEN.
THEY GOT HELP FOR ZACK WILSON.
THEY GOT HELP FOR THAT EDGE
RUSH.
AND THEY GOT THE BEST CORNER IN
THE DRAFT.
THEY'RE WINNERS.
THEY ARE BIG WINNERS.
>> IT'S HARD TO DISAGREE.
YOU LOVE THE MANEUVERABILITY.
THEY HAD AS A TOP TEN PLAY NER
THIS DRAFT, THE PLAYERS THEY
WOULD HAVE TAKEN AT TEN.
YOU HAVE TO TAKE CARE OF WILSON.
WE LOVE GARRETT WILSON.
I THINK HE'S THE BEST RECEIVER
IN THE DRAFT.
HE'S AWESOME.
BUT THERE'S A LITTLE PART OF YOU
WHO GOES WAIT ABOUT THE EDGE
RUSH THOUGH.
FOR ME, WHEN I LOOK AT THIS
DRAFT, JUST WHAT THE EAGLES WERE
ABLE TO DO.
>> WOO.
TALK ABOUT IT, CONNOR.
>> WE'RE JUST PATTING EACH OTHER
ON THE BACK.
>> IT'S JUST UNBELIEVABLE, WHEN
YOU LOOK AT, WHEN YOU'RE TRADING
FOR APARTJ BROWN.
THAT DOESN'T MAKE SENSE.
A GUY WHO'S ENTERING HIS PRIME.
HE CAN KACHCATCH THE BALL DOWN
FIELD.
THE WAY TH THEY NAVIGATED.
.
>> AND IT IS, OF ALL THE
POSITIONS, IT IS THE ONE THEY
VALUE THE MOST.
>> KEEPING GUYS A LITTLE BIT
MORE CLEAN.
RI
RIGHT
>> I'M EXCITED TO SEE HIM EVOLVE
IN PHILADELPHIA.
THAT'S A PLACE YOU GO TO EVOLVE
ON THE DEFENSIVE LINE.
>> HE'LL EXPERIMENT.
SO YOU DID TAKE MINE.
I WROTE DOWN THREE THAT ALSO
STUCK OUT TO ME.
ONE BEING KANSAS CITY LEAVING
WITH McDUFFIE AND CAR LAUF TIS.
ADDRESSING BOTH.
THEN I WROTE DOWN THE RAVENS,
AND I THOUGHT KYLE HAMILTON AND
LINDERBAUM.
BUT THEN I WENT THEY ALSO TRADED
THEIR QUARTERBACK'S FAVORITE
WIDE RECEIVER.
AND OTHER THAN THE EAGLES, I'M
GIVING MY BIG WINNER TO THE
DETROI
DETROIT SLOOI LIONS.
YOU'RE ALSO GETTING A JAMESON
WILLIAMS GUY THAT YOU PARTNER
UP.
BUT ALSO, WHOEVER THE NEXT
QUARTERBACK IS, AND HECK, GUYS,
THEY MIGHT GET MALIK IN THE
THIRD PICK OF THIS SECOND ROUND.
I DON'T KNOW EXACTLY --
>> DID THEY MOVE IT?
>> DIDN'T THEY HAVE TWO PICKS AT
THE BEGINNING OF THIS ROUND?
JAMESSON COULD BE THE GUY FOR
THEIR QU
THIS QUARTERBACK OR THE NEXT
QUARTERBACK.
I WOULD BE LYING IF I TOLD YOU
THAT THE EAGLES ARE MY BIG
WINNER, BECAUSE I'M JUST IN
SHOCK.
>> I'LL SNEAK ONE MORE IN.
>> I GOT TWO MORE.
>> I GOT THE GIANTS.
>> I LOVE WHAT THE GIANTS DID.
JUST TO GET KAYVON THIBODEAUX
AND STILL GET EVAN NEAL.
THE GIANTS, WHAT THEY'VE MISSED
FOR SO LONG IS A GROUND FLOOR,
RIGHT?
THEY TRIED TO PUT A ROOF OVER
NOTHING.
STRANGE SELECTIONS.
THERE'S GROUND FLOOR, GROUND
FLOOR.
KAYVON THIBODEAUX.
>> CAN'T BUILD A HOUSE WITHOUT A
FOUNDATION.
>> SURE, MAYBE NOT THE MOST
GLAMOROUS, BAUGHUT A SMART,
EFFECTIVE DRAFT.
>> I'M GOING TO GO TO MY ROOTS,
I'M GOING TO GO TO COLLEGE,
GEORGIA EVERY SINGLE PIECE , FIE
FIRST ROUNDERS.
LISTEN.
I BET THE PROMO TWEETS ARE
ALREADY OUT THERE, LOOK, YOU
WANT TO BE A CHAMPION?
COME PLAY FOR THE DOGS.
YOU WANT TO GO TO THE NFL?
THEY'RE GOING TO GO ALABAMA, HOW
MANY DID YOU HAVE?
OH, YOU HAD TWO.
>> I KNOW HOW FELDER FEELS ABOUT
THIS.
THE SECOND BEST GEORGIA PLAYER
BEHIND JORDAN DAVIS IS GOING TO
BE ON THE BOARD WHETH.
>> THESE ARE THE BEST PLAYERS
AVAILABLE.
DAVID YOE JAW BOW IS STILL
THERE.
BIG DEFENSIVE TACKLE OUT OF U
CON.
AND WE DID NOT SEE A RUNNING
BACK.
NO RUNNING BACK AND NO TIGHT
END.
IF I HAVE THIS RIGHT HAS NEVER
HAPPENED IN THIS ERA, GONE BACK
70 YEARS OR SOMETHING.
>> WE TOOK A LOT OF THE WINNERS.
SO IT'S FOKOKAY IF OUR GUYS STE
SOME.
WHO JUDGED OUT AT YOU.
>> IT HAS TO BE DERRICK SINGLY.
I THINK COMING OFF AN INJURY TO
GO NUMBER THREE IN THE DRAFT, TO
BE THE FIRST CORNER TAKEN,
OBVIOUSLY, TESTED INCREDIBLY AT
HIS PRO DAY.
I THINK YOU'VE GOT TO BE JUMPING
FOR JOY.
THERE'S A LOT OF DOUBT, A LOT OF
UNCERTAINTY.
YOU ONLY PLAY A FEW GAMES, AN UP
AND DOWN SOME MORE YEAR.
SO I THINK HE HAS TO BE FEELING
GREAT ABOUT EVERYTHING.
I KNOW THE HOUSTON TEXANS ARE
HAPPY AND EXCITED TO GET HIM.
HE'S GOING TO BE A BIG-TIME
PLAYMAKER FOR THEM, BUT HE'S MY
WINNER FOR TODAY.
>> SIX WIDE RECEIVERS TAKEN IN
THE FIRST 18 PICKS.
THEN WE DIDN'T HEAR FROM THEM
AGAIN.
I CALLED YOUR DETROIT LIONS A
WINNER.
WHO DO YOU SEE AS A WINNER,
PLAYER OR TEAM IN.
>> I'M GOING TO GO WITH PLAYER.
MY GUY JAKE LEONARD.
AFTER HAVING ANKLE SURGERY,
SEASON-ENDING INJURY, WEEK EIGHT
OR NINE.
IT'S HUGE FOR HIM.
ATLANTA, THEY GOT PITT, MARIOTA.
THEY'LL DO JUST FINE OVER THERE,
AND ONE MORE KYLE HAMILTON ON
THE RAVENS.
FOR HIM, THAT DEFENSE, I THINK,
FITS HIM PERFECT.
LIKE WE TALKED ABOUT EARLIER,
YOU GUYS TALKED ABOUT EARLIER, A
SAFETY IN THAT DEFENSE, IN THAT
DIVISION.
THE TYPE OF OFFENSES THAT HE
WILL SEE, A LOT OF RUNNING, A
LOT OF RUNNING THE BALL THIS
THAT DIVISION.
I THINK HE'S GOING TO DRIVE IN
THAT DEFENSE.
THAT'S A PERFECT FIT FOR HIM.
YOU TALK ABOUT PLAYERS GOING TO
TEAMS.
>> HAN WAND WE WILL WRAP IT UP
JASON KELCE.
WHO DO YOU SEE AS THE BIG
WINNER, WHETHER IT'S A PLAYER OR
TEAM.
>> I SEE THAT NEW YORK'S COMING
AWAY WITH PROBABLY THE BIGGEST
NIGHT FOR THE MOST PART ON THIS.
JOE DOUGLAS WAS EXTREMELY
ACTIVE, ABLE TO PULL OFF A BUNCH
OF SOLID MOVES.
A LOCKDOWN CORNER NO SAUCE
GARDNER, AN EDGE DEFENDER WHICH
WILL PAIR UP WITH SOME OF THE
GUYS UP FRONT.
NEW YORK, EVAN NEAL WAS PROBABLY
MY FAVORITE PASS BROCLOCK AND
TACKLE.
TWO SOLID TACKLES TO ADD TO AN
EDGE DEFENDER TO GO ALONG WITH
THE TWO MONSTERS INSIDE THAT
THINK HAVE.
BUT, BUT.
>> BUT.
>> WHAT AN AMAZING NIGHT,
BECAUSE WE GOT TO WITNESS A
BUNCH OF PEOPLE REALIZE THE
AMERICAN DREAM.
>> HMM.
>> A BUNCH OF KIDS ARE REALIZING
THE DREAM OF PLAYING IN THE NFL,
AND THAT'S WHY THE NFL DRAFT IS
SO FRICKIN' AWESOME, MAN.
IT'S INCREDIBLE.
IT'S AN INCREDIBLE MOMENT FOR
ALL THESE KIDS AND ALL THEIR
FAMILIES AND ALL THEIR HOMETOWNS
AND EVERYWHERE THEY'VE BEEN.
BUT, ONLY ONE TEAM HAD GOT A
CERTIFIED DOG IN THE NFL
TONIGHT.
AND THAT'S THE PHILADELPHIA
EAGLES.
SO I DON'T THINK IT'S ANYWHERE
CLOSE.
MY MAN HOWIE ROSEMAN WAS AT
WORK.
AND I'M READY TO GO TO WORK.
>> JASON, I COULDN'T UNDERSTAND
A WORD WERE YOU SAYING, BECAUSE
I WAS WATCHING PORN ON THIS
TELEVISION.
AJ BROWN HIGHLIGHTS.
AND I WAS SITTING HERE GOING
THIS GUY'S ON THE EAGLES RIGHT
NOW?
UNBELIEVABLE, MAN.
HOWIE ROSEMAN.
JASON KELCE WAS FIRED UP.
MAN, WHAT A GREAT NIGHT.
HUGE THANK YOU TO JASON KELCE.
AND RICHARD SHERMAN.
THANK YOU FOR THEIR TIME AND
THEIR ANALYSIS.
THANK YOU TO CONNOR AND HIS BIG
BRAIN AND HIS BIG BOARD.
BIG THANK TO YOU MICHAEL FELDER
FOR HOLDING IT DOWN.
WE ARE BACK TOMORROW NIGHT.
SHOUT OUT TO KAPLAN, SHOUT OUT
TO McMANIS.
SHOUT OUT TO BRETT ROZEN IN THE
BACK.
EVERYONE IN PRODUCTION MAKING IT
HAPPEN.
TOMORROW'S BETTER?
>> TOMORROW'S ALWAYS BETTER.
WHERE SUPER BOWLS ARE WON.
REAL DOGS DRAFT IN THE SECOND
AND THIRD.
>> IF YOU WANT TO BE A NUB,
ENJOY TELEVISION.
PEACE.
SEE YOU TOMORROW.